It's signed up my YouTube again for the very first time.
Good morning.
Hi, Baudry Plain.
Mm, I'm giving you technical.
I've not even got Elden Ring open. Oh my god, stop!
Such a bad streamer. I've not even started to play Elden Ring open.
I don't even know where we are in the DLC, but that's okay because
as long as I have you and we're together you will carry me through the game
because I don't know how to play Elden Ring.
Good morning.
Hold on, let me check.
Yes, and everyone should be able to carry me in the DLC now
because you've played it so much. Good morning, Nan.
Good evening, good afternoon.
Hi, little Baudry Plain. How are you today?
Are you ready for three long days of stream sniping?
Um, I just want to start this stream off by saying
I'm sorry for getting political, but I had liquid diarrhea.
Um, I don't know why.
I've, I don't, I'm not sure why, um, but the fucking smell was bogging.
So, um, yeah, I just thought you should know.
I don't know if I need to go for like five minutes and disappear.
Oh, that was me.
That was my PC.
That was me.
Hold on.
Hold on, it was me.
I need, I need to plug him a little fucking, my controller, please.
Why do you do that so easily?
Oh my God.
See this keyboard?
I'm actually gonna, oh, I need it to be wired.
Uh, I don't know why.
I had a chicken burrito in there, but it tasted fine.
That was me.
That's not you.
That's me.
That's my PC.
My PC is popping off.
Um, right.
Updates.
If you are a harem, a snippet and a pinpal, there's content on Patreon.
If you are a snowberry and a bleeding heart within 24 hours,
you have an emergency audio commission coming through.
It will be uploaded in, I repeat, 24 hours.
You will have the audio.
If you are a refling as always, we get cast to decide a little bit.
I need a bit of time.
Um, the audio manager is coming in today.
Like it's already been set up in the background.
I don't know what's happening.
I just need to write a little sheet that says at the end of the month, tell us
how many hours you took to edit and we will pay you your payment.
Basically is what I have to do.
So I am no longer the owl for sending audios back and forth.
Yeah.
Um, so what does that mean?
It mean at the start of the month, I can finally post a graphic of what the content
is on Patreon for the month.
Okay.
Finally.
I know I said I'd do it this month, but the manager got delayed.
Things got delayed, but I can finally do it.
So you'll finally know what comes up.
Where the, what am I wearing?
Are we in the flower field?
Oh my God.
I don't want to be alone.
How do I know?
How do I summon refling?
Stop.
I don't, I've forgotten everything.
No, that's stop.
I'm alone.
How do I call you in X?
No, that's to heal.
Okay.
Why shows me?
I don't know how to come.
I don't know how to get you here.
It's been so long.
Do you guys know where I am?
I'm a lamenter's gown.
Please come.
Please save me.
Oh God.
What's her password?
Wait, hold on.
Multiplayer password.
Reef.
Okay.
I'm, I'm a pin that right now.
It's been, it's been so long.
Okay.
I will pin.
What's it called?
Multiplayer password.
Reef.
And now as always today is very most likely, very most
likely, uh, and God, please pin.
Step outside and use it.
Oh my God, refling.
Oh my God.
Save me.
Thank you from soul.
Is that a refling?
No, I'm, I'm, I'm just, I think you're a refling.
Thank you from soul.
Yeah.
Cause I'm using a public password thing.
My barber.
He got the refling hat on me.
Okay.
Um, this is an endurance stream.
So please do not be afraid at any point to pop out to
watch any of my gen mates when they go up, please.
Oh my God.
The coconut moons.
I forgot.
Oh my God.
I forgot the coconut moons.
Oh, I'm going to reef so hard.
Hi, you me.
Are you excited or collapse going to be wrapped up very
soon?
I'll keep you updated in them deums.
How many bosses have you defeated?
Now when you say I defeat, do you mean we as in the
reeflings helping me do everything?
Why is the cars?
Oh, we got an enemy refling.
Okay.
I'm got math, but that doesn't count.
Enemies don't really count cause you don't really get to
play.
Okay, ma you're in.
And what is this?
Sacred Golem Fist.
Are you fissing me?
Oh, you give me flowers?
Oh, they're so cute.
Hell yeah.
You me, sister-in-law.
Thank you for the membership.
I appreciate it.
How strong are you?
Take your time to worry.
I'm sick right now.
I have something to watch.
Oh my God.
Check out the fit.
Right.
Let's analyze the map.
It's been a hot second of the DLC.
Right.
I think we're hot.
Oh, oh God.
I remember the scary fingers.
Yeah.
They were like getting sniped from halfway across the map.
We seem to be at some sort of cavern pass.
And if you haven't fought bail curse you bail.
Thank you for the extended membership.
Hell yeah.
Hi Leah.
Now, if I recall correctly, we were stuck on the sneak guy
and I couldn't figure out how it progressed.
Oh my God.
That's right.
I can jump on you.
How did I do it?
Oh my God.
Muscle memory is kicking in.
There's an item that I can slam you down with.
Oh my God.
What is it?
No.
I forgot.
Is it this one?
I think it's this one.
What did I do?
Nope, that's slash.
Nope, jump.
How did I use my ultimate?
No.
Stop drinking the flasks.
Oh my God.
I'm so sorry.
I've completely forgotten how to play this game.
I remember.
Okay.
I was a bit of a range but there you go.
We're remembering.
This is going to be very painful.
Painful.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me.
Leah, just make sure that I'm calibrated.
Ground pound.
Sorry.
I send you off to war with ground pound.
Oh my God.
Yes.
Right.
How do I upgrade my weapon?
I forgot everything about this game.
Oh, is that your ass, man?
Let me hold it.
Oh, no.
I've started the freaking battle music.
I forgot.
Right.
Let me.
So this was my main sword.
I can swing my sword.
Right.
Land octopus ovary.
Are you implying Gen 2?
I can't believe that.
What are we doing first?
You know how to play.
I've like completely forgotten.
Right.
We seem.
Oh, I can't open up my map.
Oh dear.
Oh God, heals real.
Right.
I don't actually recall a single thing.
I guess we'll go up the hill.
Or do I just throw you into that boss fight with a snake?
Oh wait, how do I do two-handed?
No, not that one.
Is it that one?
No.
Why?
And then two-handed.
There we go.
Go has been well.
Apologies, Mama.
I am running on zero.
Oh, no.
It's been their party.
So I'll be on and off all streamers.
I fight the cousin of death.
Cousin of death?
Enjoy the birthday party or enjoyed in the past tense.
Uh, right.
Well, we go.
What will we do?
I don't know.
Wait, did we even do that cavern?
I can't.
Unfortunately, I'm in a fight right now.
So I can't open up the map because I think I'm fighting the
friendly refling.
Right.
These sneaky things are bad.
Cousin of death low.
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh, how did I run?
You won't be able to join me since I don't have the game,
but I will be learning for all your streams.
Good luck and have fun you and the other reflings got this.
Uh, oh my God.
I didn't know we attack them.
Yeah, fuck them.
Sorry.
I forgot you're supposed to like attacking stuff in this game.
Hold on.
It's been a while.
At least I can stagger them.
Oh, I'm out of stamina.
Hold on.
I'm out of stamina.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Look at that frame perfect frame perfect.
Thank you, Husky.
I'm sorry.
You don't have the game.
I promise I'll play more stream snake game.
God, those guys are so creepy.
I don't like them.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Wait, just let me wake up.
You know, I need to wake up a bit.
Good morning.
I did literally, I've been up since midnight trying to do all this background work.
I had to fucking teach the script writer to write scripts the way I do it.
And we were having to like psychoanalyze.
Psych analysis.
Psychoanalyze.
Yeah, I think that's the word.
I had to like analyze the scripts and be like, okay, this is how I would do it.
This is how you've done it.
Right.
Remove this.
This is the fucking exhausted.
I'm not even starting the day yet.
But good morning.
No, I did sleep.
Basically, I went to bed early and I was like, I'm just going to wake up and do all of my work.
Where the fuck are we going?
I still can't open the map.
That's so annoying.
I know I'm supposed to kill that refill, but I don't want to.
I have no idea where to go.
Not a clue.
Did we go down the water?
God, my game feels really big.
I don't know if it's me, but my, it feels like I'm dropping frames, bruh.
I'm like, I can't even get up a hill.
I don't know where we're going.
Will we go do the snake guy and try and remember how to fight by taking on the snake guy over and over again?
We've got the lion.
I remember the dancing lion we did.
My game is struggling here too.
Yeah, I was going to say, mine feels a bit, huh, and I'm like, huh.
I see that bird.
I see that.
I see.
I've not got a sniper.
I'm more of a 200 myself.
Mizzmer's one of the hardest bosses in the DLC.
Well, this thing's going first.
Gang violence, gang violence.
Okay, can I open up the map now?
I can't.
Right.
Okay.
Analysis.
Right.
I went up to there.
We can't actually physically go there.
I think this is what I had a problem with last time.
I don't know where the F to go.
So there was a big fucking dragon boss in there.
I couldn't get any further.
I can't seem to figure out how to get this wayward map.
Hmm.
Oh, God, there's so much to this deal.
I recognize nothing.
I'm like, should I have played this offline and then played it with you?
But I can't seem to figure out how to get on the ground over here.
I'm following the path.
And then it looks like a, it doesn't even look like a jump down.
Honestly, maybe it's this way.
Hmm.
Maybe some weird thing over here.
What we teleport there and take a left and then jump down with Lee Torrent.
We'll help you point out location and we'll guide you.
If you want me to guide your hips, there's a big castle.
You gotta go to it and then hold on a minute.
There's a cat comb at the bottom of the river above the gray area that gets you there.
At the bottom of the river above the gray area.
We can guide you on foot.
Do you know where to go?
Fuck it, I'll follow the refland.
Surely you guys know where to go.
Take me somewhere new.
Take me, refland, take me.
Do you know where to go?
Maybe?
I don't know.
I like, that's how much we've done.
The air to tree is untouched.
Okay, I'm just following the refland.
Following the reflings, the reflings, the reflings, the reflings and following the reflings on the way to go.
We may be blocked by a fog wall.
That's like, geez, you scared me.
Yeah.
I'll just, oh well that refland's got a torch so that means he knows where he's going.
Clearly.
There is a furnace golem near your location.
Be careful.
What does that mean?
What is a furnace golem?
Whoa, that was big.
I'm trying to stagger.
Oh my God, I'm so bad at the combat.
Oh, reflings, did we go for it?
No, you guys see the big problem?
Yeah.
You guys see the problem now?
Oh God, I'm stuck on a fence.
Will someone please think of the, no, leave him alone.
He's mine.
Fuck, fuck.
Oh my God, it's been, no, no, no, it's fine.
Copium, it's fine.
It's been a while.
But it was not fine.
No, it fucking was me.
Oh, didn't he put me back at Big Lamentons?
Go wherever the fuck it is.
Get me out here.
Right, go on.
Why are you taking me?
That was so terrible that attempt.
Exactly.
No, I never said that.
No, I said, I said, I would.
I may or may not have been reading hate word marshmallows.
Well, I haven't diary on the toilet.
I've been misquoted, okay?
I've been misquoted.
How dare you?
No, I threw an ink on the toilet.
That's a really strange location to ink.
Where are you taking me?
I don't want to spawn you then,
because obviously I can go a lot faster.
Did I go to the hut?
This seems to be some sort of hut.
Can I not teleport to it?
No, okay, I guess I'll fuck you again.
And what the heck am I?
Mummy ink.
Go to Cathedral of Manus Mightier.
Manus Mightier.
Cathedral of Manus Mightier.
Okay, and then I'll call you in,
and then you'll hold my hand.
And please clean it up afterwards.
You ink straight into the toilet bowl?
Yeah, take that toilet, you sexy bitch.
What?
Who said that?
Why can't I summon inside the church?
Don't do that.
Is this guy mean to me or is he nice?
No, he still seems to be nice,
and his regard dog is nice as well.
Okay, let's go inside the church then.
Head in sign.
Examine the chair.
I'm examining so hard right now.
As much as I love to stay and watch little Inge play,
I have to have some rest so I can be able to work tonight.
I hope you have a good day and fun with the reflings.
And guys, look after her, please.
Aw, thank you, typical Mason.
All reflings look after me.
Okay, hello chair.
I believe I can feed brewing.
Mmm, yeah, it's brewing.
This evening is a sign of a greater night to come.
Mm-hmm.
Study sorcery?
If you want the greater,
it's south of the Recluses River downstream,
gray south of the church.
Ask about Gunson's sorcery.
Ask about the nature of the world.
Sure, why not?
I hear that you have borne witness to the whole of it.
The conceits, the hypocrisy of the world
built upon the earth tree.
Is there no hope for a de-answer?
There never was any hope.
They were each of them defected, Marika herself.
Okay, right, wrap it up.
Wrap it up.
What?
You need to reload the area.
He needs to disappear.
Rest well.
Like, come from here and run up to the church.
I will run up to the church.
Yes, then examine his chair.
Uncle.
Pop me on a horse.
And then the church is this.
Not this.
Oh, it's actually this.
Oh, the path.
Oh, you know that really obvious path
that leads up to the church?
Yeah, that one.
Peace off, ghost.
Elden Ring is so sad.
You never, like, get a break from any fighting at all.
They're so mean.
They're so stinky.
I could have picked up materials there.
I didn't even have a moment to think.
I think you could.
I think you have to exhaust his dialogue for him to disappear.
Oh, I.
I come on tour and let's go inside the church.
What is that random?
Oh, it's the sunset.
I was like, why is there random lanes on the church floor?
What does it mean?
Is it like salt?
All Elden Rings characters have sad back stories.
What is this, Warhammer?
Oh, for folks sake, he's still here.
Peace off, ghost.
Right, you.
Right, right, right, right, right, right.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Lore, yes, juicy lore.
Look, I just want to play with the refluence.
I said what I said.
Study sorcery.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's so cool.
Glenstone.
Oh, yes, Glenstone.
Mm, yes.
Oh, greater world, greater world.
Yes, look.
Ask about makeup.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Yes, filled with pleasure.
Lovely.
Jay-Z Lee, thank you.
We need a mother.
That's why I'm called Mummy.
Right, that to me sounds like a cheeky exhausted dialogue.
Okay, now rest at the grace site until night.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I can do that.
Hold up.
Opening up.
I have sprite today because I don't know what's wrong with me too,
mate.
Is he still in that chair?
Oh, yeah.
He's no in the chair.
Right, now to analyze this chair.
What was so special about this chair?
Let us discover together.
Hmm, examine.
Oh, my.
Oh, there's a wee, a wee knob on it.
Oh, I do love pushing a good knob.
Oh, I'd say hydration.
Oh, see, sometimes in life, the answer is just to give a knob a good push.
I don't know why you're the dark, deep hole.
I'm sure this won't freak me out at all.
Surely I can summon you guys at the bottom of the ladder, right?
Right, you guys are here, right?
No, I can't do anything.
Okay, that's fine.
I like adventuring alone.
No, it's my favorite thing.
The secret gun cave under the throne.
Real.
No, I love.
I love.
Oh, okay, okay.
All right.
Remember how to play, right?
Roll.
Oh, is that a heavy roll?
That looks like a medium roll to me, right?
Okay.
What can I do from afar?
Uh, nothing.
Right, I have, I have 11 heals.
Oh, any blood loss?
Me a bam.
Fucking low poise motherfucker.
Get out of here.
Don't do that move again.
Hold on.
I need hydrate.
No, don't do that.
Don't get me blood loss.
You, you think you, you wait for you.
No, stop it.
You have higher agility than me.
That's cheating.
Hold on.
Let me hydrate.
Yeah.
Fuck you bitch.
Take that you poise poise poise.
Yeah.
No poise for you.
Fuck you.
Oh shit.
No poise for me.
No agility and no endurance.
Hydrate and back off.
Oh, yeah.
That cheeky roll.
No, don't take blood loss.
Wait.
What are you fucking?
No, let me back in.
Let me, no, put me back in.
I had that.
Sorry.
I got greedy.
Put me back in.
Actual, put me back in.
No, then he'd be giving me leaving hostile signs.
Put me back in chief.
I had that.
No, put me back in.
Right.
Hold on.
I'm holding two hand in it.
Right.
Put me back in.
Into the goon cave we go.
Mm-hmm.
Put me back in.
That was the easiest fight in my life.
Watch your stamina.
Watch your mouth race when I'll plug.
I'll put something in it to keep you quiet.
Right.
Back into the goon cave.
I can't believe there's a fucking goon cave defender.
Seriously.
Right.
Come.
Fight me.
Binch.
Do it.
You got this.
Easy.
No, I do.
Literally goon cave.
Right.
Spawn in.
You be right.
Fuck you.
Bitch.
Are you fucking serious?
I just hit that.
I dodged.
Oh.
Are you fucking serious?
I need hydrate.
Oh my god.
I'm getting sunblocked.
And I don't have any.
Fuck off.
Let me hydrate.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Poise bitch.
Yeah.
Nice try.
Try again.
I dare you.
Come close.
Fuck you.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Piss.
That's cheating.
No, it's too early in the morning for this.
Too early in the morning.
Yeah.
You're not the only thing I'm shitting on.
You're not the only thing I'm shitting.
Ooh.
Blood loss.
Get.
Don't get cocky.
Eh.
Defend this.
Oh.
She's no dead yet.
No.
Don't freaking cock up.
Don't cock up.
Don't cock it.
Don't cock it up.
Don't cock up.
Oh my God.
Oh.
All right.
Hold on.
Hold on a minute.
Stop.
Let me get this.
Oh.
Let me get this right.
My fellow Americans.
I have the highest fucking poise in the game.
I have heavy, heavy armor.
Heavy, heavy armor.
And I'm the one who gets sunlocked by we fucking needle.
Right.
Okay.
Apparently needle.
I hate needles apparently.
Okay.
Right.
Let's try that again.
Shhh.
No.
What do you mean I can't just summon reflans to do every single fight
so I can enjoy the game for what it is?
What do you mean?
I can't just do that.
Honestly.
Short on behavior.
Summon us up by the ladder.
No.
When it comes to the red people in game,
you can't like,
I can't believe I fucking cocked that up what a twat bag honestly fucking two-brained idiot
No, even I actually knew even no you're actually getting jumps. No keep up your dialogue bitch
Even though you don't talk you wait for
No, as if that hit me
Shut up your arse like honestly, are you fucking I'm actually getting twat so hard this time
No
What do I have that I can use against this
Right, it's fine. I literally have this fight. I'm sorry, but I literally have this fight. It's so fucking easy
I don't know why I'm struggling
Can I just can I say it's the lag because I'm in Australia?
It's the lag obviously. I've got 300 ping right now
No, put me in put me in the sand and then
Her name is Anna also it is a slag do you want to get hired by the other by the way Anna while you're at it
Since you're like inserting your fingers where they don't fucking belong prick honestly
Right put me in chief right don't don't get cocky that's what it is
I get cocky and I start swinging my hand around like sauce. That's what the problem is right one swing
Are you you're actually zero poise bitch get out here
Yes, I'm jumping like a superhero
Can you jump off that what happens if you rolled off the map right now? I don't think anyone would miss you
Who's supposed to have low poise
You fucking skinny little rat fucking wasting away call you Anna
Rex it call you at it like going fucking get a break honestly. Go and let me heal. Oh
We're just rolling. Oh rolling rolling rolling rolling. What the rolling rolling rolling rolling come on
I'm just doing a wee swing, you know, I'm just we swinging on this bitch fucking rat
No, then he's stun lock me because I'll start getting region fucking
Why is it on one HP all of a sudden the AI is like actually can what let me just turn it up to a billion like
I'm fucking calm down sit the fuck down. Right. Can I summon you in now?
Claws of the night more like claws of shite. Thank you. I'll be here all week. Can I know I still can't summon in response
Okay, this is terrible news
That was awful don't ever make me play this game again without you right I swear if anything else jumps me
I'm actually gonna be frothing at the mouth and anger. What is this? Oh a summoning pill? Oh
No a
summoning pill
Which means there's a boss ahead. Oh, no. Oh, no, this can't be
No, you guys patiently waiting for me on the other side like fucking hell hurry up, right ma
No, well, no, right. I know you didn't do like with me. I
Didn't want to do it. Oh
Wait, no, that's red hold on. Mm-hmm. Jay. Oh
Yeah
And then no, I'm at the cross
When you don't watch you call yourself normal across I'm so sorry, I don't know why that was an interesting film
That was an insight thought that came out. I'm guessing since this is a fey
Is there a point in summoning in an evil reefing?
Sure a good time I
Don't think there's not really a point. Okay, where's the other one? Okay, we're ready hydration
Okay, are we ready to touch? Oh?
Wait, I need to I need to the coconut on you. Oh
Right, let's see what boss this is my sign is down the hill I can only have two good reeflings at once
Right what fight is this?
Where's my refund bro, give me my refunds. Oh
My god, is there like a cutscene or something? I'm actually scared right? Okay. Where's my refunds? Oh, I can't do this
I'm not built for this. I'm actually not built for this murder mother of fingers. I need fucking shite. Right go refunds go
Go refunds go refunds go don't upset the rhythm now. Don't you do?
Don't worry. I got the ass
Why did that take half my health? Oh, yeah, oh
I'm so skinny. I'm in between the attacks. Oh
Wait, I know how to help hold on a minute
You get you keep doing what you're doing refling. I know how to help watch this. Are you ready? Oh?
Oh, maybe not maybe not
Okay, you know what I was gonna swap to the crossbow wait hold on I have time hold on watch this watch this
I'm helping I'm helping
See look I'm hitting I'm hitting. Oh, yeah, take that
Take that damn. Oh
cheeky we hang have I got a girl
Oh
Yeah, that's right 18 damage. Yeah, that's right. You take that damage
Mmm. Oh, yeah, that's right. I've got I go
Hello, hello
How did you dodge that I'm not even sure how you did that I'm helping I promise I'll do blood arrows, okay?
No, I miss
Okay, I need to stay away though
It has a finger kitchy. Oh my god, there's like bombs on the battlefield
Helping helping helping I'm helping my refling. We're all gonna win the boss fight
Did it did it? Oh fuck that. I'm out. No sauce. No, what are you doing? What are you doing?
What is this?
Why these attacks
Why these attacks I can't he keep up with this year and I can't he keep up with this one
Okay, I'm gonna just
Fucking oh my god, it's summoned like little baby ones out. Hold on wait. Let me go my sword again
You can swing my sword
And then hold Y right trigger and then me to hand it, okay
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, baby lead. Let it rep baby. Let him with a baby lead. Let it
Stop it. You're hurting them. That's not nice. Oh, you're hurting me now. That's not nice either
I think I'll play it safe and stay back so the refunds do all the damage
I gave birth
Hi Leo, thank you for this hit
It's the arc from Titan. Do we need the ball on his back? It just kind of looks like a Elden orb thingy my Bobber
Baby lead let it rip
But it didn't go for me. Um, oh
What's this one?
Not again, bro. I'm gonna let the refunds kill it. Sorry, but it's too dangerous
How are you supposed to dodge that
It's not possible
I'm gonna stop
No, one of the reflings are done. Oh my god be up go refling go. It's all on you
It's make or break. Let's go. I didn't have to do anything. Is it still alive? Oh
Thank you, I'm so sorry to the other refund that died. Oh my god. Thank you for carrying me through the game as always
Oh, wait, wait, how did I do the microphone? No, not the microphone. How did I do it back?
I want to do it back so badly. Oh
Oh, I know I know I know me me me
No, what no, that's all I said at all
Thank you for your service, I'm sorry you died
That was a freaky boss. I like that. Well, like it was a very unique boss
I like the attack pattern on it as well like the wee bombs that laid down. I'm a rest
Can I level up? No, but I have a rado shell best thing. Oh, okay. Nice try. It's a could
Sky do tree blessing. Okay used to them sure
So what now I have nine defense a
Skibbity blessing you know that honestly would have been better used to Reverend spirit ashes not enough. Okay, that's fine
Okay, I don't
Where are we?
Where do I go from here?
Or is this a teleport out kind of location? It looks like a teleport out location. I just think I'm
I don't think it's about to be here
That refund will be remembered for the what sadly these bosses are made for both close scores and range combat
Which makes you think on your feet
You should get all your blessings to max. How did I do that?
Skadoo tree is actually pronounced Shadoo tree
And now I'm your worthy ally in battle. Oh
Yeah
Blessings armor weapons max upgrade. Okay, where'd I upgrade my weapon?
Shibbity
You need all the shibbity fragments. Okay, where'd I go?
Oh
What you thought I was gonna know what to do. No, I've never played this before
And what's that you're gonna carry me every step of the way damn straight you are. This is the way we play video games around these parts
from around here
um
Right if I upgrade my weapons, can I go back to the guy in the not dlc?
Explore or fight a boss. I don't know. They said I should level up my thingy my bobber
My shadow realm blessings if I remember correctly the blessing raises my defense against the enemies or something
Smithing master huig. Yeah. Aye that right. Okay. We'll go to the round table and I'll see what happens
I thought I had to go bomb. Yeah like this. Okay. I'll go to master big hui
Defense and attack just go home. Oh just got home. Are you winning? I said just go home. I was like, yeah, I can't
Uh, right big master hui more like big master
Uh, it's stuck in chains tea
What I need to do better than this
This will never kill a god. Oh, yeah, what do you mean? Oh
It's you. Hi
It's not important
There should be a smith in the dlc as a quality of life thing. I thought I think there's no new interaction at the church. Ah
Uh strengthen me weapon. How'd I do that?
Great sword of solitude
Sombra smithing stone
Okay, I'm out of smithing stones. Okay, and then can I do my weed for an arrow? That's op
What one was it that was op was it this yen the spread crossbow?
I can tell you what else can spread. Um
the crossbow
What when this one's worth the most money which makes me think this was the crossbow I was mucking about
With that you guys told that you gave me
I recently gave me this and I was supposed to use it in the fights, but I kept missing on my shorts
and
Upgrade that one. Okay. Got you. Got you. Got you. Okay. One two three four five
Okay, that was good
We got a wee bit out of it
That's the main thing. How do I moan into the fucking coconut? It's very important
It's very very important. You don't understand. It's so important
Right memory of grace you can get switched out for the coconut. It's so important that I can moan in the reason that you're
Hello. Thank you. You're beautiful. Let's get to it. Please help wonderful apologies
Is it please help?
Oh, no, like it just straight up is actually please help wait did I not pick up the morning coconut?
I could have sworn I picked up that coconut
The gray one
The gray one no
Am I staring at it?
Lamentation
Okay, I love it. Love this 10 out of 10 game. Right. I've upgraded that. I don't know how to upgrade my
Armory
Uh, you should go to shadow keep back gate what shadow keeps in this bit or in the other bit
Shadow keep shadow keep shadow
Shadow keep
Oh, wait, I'm supposed to go back to the chair at the thingy. I'm supposed to go back to the chair, right? Let's analyze the chair first
Let's get to it
Oh
We must analyze the chair
What's going on in here you sassy backers. Oh the guard lady's gone
She's out. She doesn't want nothing to do with it. Hello, mr. Chair. I don't know
Riffling
Riffling you little pisser
To the count
Riffling you eat piss stain. Are you serious?
You never warned me
Oh my god, stop. I'm scared. I'm scared
Oh my god, please have zero poise. Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow. She's making me bleed. She's making me bleed
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't fucking no i'm out of stamina
I'm out of stamina. Leave it in hen back up back up back up back up. What the fuck is that sordar online?
Oh my god, remember that anime sordar online? I guess instead of that real true
That's what I'm thinking about you
Hydration, please hydration, please
Okay, you know, uh, don't get greedy now let that let that come back up
All right, that's what I think about you. Bitch. Oh shit. I'm getting greedy. I'm getting greedy. I'm getting edy McCready
No
Why is always one HP is when I go down, sorry, but actually it's all
I fucking up your
I'm already a mummy
Oh, please not another fight are you
Oh my god, can I call you in mid fight? Are you here? Are you at the door? Oh my god, please come please come to this one
Oh, he's coming over
What does he do? He teleports
Oh, don't forget to hand it off fucking to hand you in a minute
Oh
No, no the creepy crawlies reefland where the fuck?
Oh my god, stop
Stop this is so fucking creepy and I literally don't even one shot them
Is he serious right now?
I think I'd rather I think I'd rather die than do this fight and we'll be honest
Uh, I'm gonna be so serious right now. I think I would rather die than do this fucking fight
What are you doing? What are you doing?
Go and cast magic up someone else's are you fucking serious? It's a fucking hands-all arrow. I know I was playing over watch
Oh my god, stop
Ah up Mars. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah my dear child my dear child. Hold on. Let me hydrate
Okay, let me hydrate no
Okay, they don't actually do that much damage. That's the good news
Don't hit the wall hit him
You know the fucking problem hit him and I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina. Oh, yeah
I'm not I'm not making this
I'm actually not making this
Oh, go and fucking finger someone else. Oh and hands-all arrow right around the corner
He wasn't even aiming for me and he gets me around the corner on
Stop spawning them. I understand that's the mechanic, but stop it seriously. I'm out of stamina
I'm
I don't have the stamina to be doing this. I genuinely don't
Please give it a rest mate mate. Give it a rest for your fucking hands-all arrow. PISH!
Okay, what even was that bro? It's a bit early in the morning for this
You can summon us. Yeah, fucking damn right. I'll be summoning you. You'll be doing all the fight fucking two fates in a row
I ain't got that kind of skill. I don't have that kind of caliber
Are you can I not come you in can I not bring you in?
Mmm
Is this one of those ones where it's like, yeah, you're not allowed to bring them in
I swear to you. I assume you guys are putting your symbols down
Give it a minute. I'm impatient. I want my refunds
I had you just had a shot
Smart you've not had to show it yet
Let me have my refunds
There's only one other
Mm-hmm
Is it reef and all cats? Yeah, did I do it wrong on the pinned post hold on?
No, I did it right on the my barber
Okay, there we go foam. Okay, pineapple's not had a shot
Okay, you guys go do all the work and I will sip my spray and have a good time tiki
I actually did really well. Sorry. I actually did for considering that's the first time I've ever experienced that fight
I did really well. I just didn't know how to like overwhelm the
The wee finger guys on the ground were like overwhelming me
Uh, but for my first play
Oh behold, what is that? Why is your hands like that?
Oh
Also, can I tell you what a
Immeasurable pain my body's in from the ring fit stream yesterday. It wasn't even that bad. I don't know what that motor is
Uh, am I just mowing on you?
Right ready
Okay, the lady's gonna attack me first
So I'm gonna examine the chair. I assume you guys are stuck by the oh no, you guys can come in with me
Okay, that's good. Right examine the chair. Let's go again
You've wound it counting
Most irreparably. Oh my god. I'm being blessed
Blessing. Oh my god. Fuck your poise, bitch
Fuck your poise
I have so much poise. It's so big and juicy
All of it all of us just crashing on her. This is so fun
I don't know why they don't just make an actual official multiplayer. Sorry, this would be so fun
Oh who died reefling
Reefling wait, what oh, no, sorry. Sorry the notification made it look like a reefling died
You're a man. You can't be a mother
No, you can't be
You have a pentas. That's illegal
Whoa, I didn't really mean to jump in the middle of that but hold on. Let me hydrate
Okay, sorry, I got a bit overzealous that was me
I do excuse me. I got excited there
No, no hands or arrows. Okay, that wasn't hands or arrows. That doesn't count
Fuck your poise. God, he like casts bells so quickly
Oh, we did it. We did it. We did it. See proof I need reeflings at all times
Ymir's bell bearing
A staff, a high priest hat, a high priest robe, a high priest balloon, a high priest undergurn
We did it
Might I suggest a quick detail maxing out the flask upgrades could be useful in the future and it shouldn't take too long
But those two ranks could make a difference at some point the flying conquerors
The flasks. I don't use my wonders physique if I'm being honest controversial, but I never use it
I'm a bad player
So now can I touch it without being
I assume it just opens the pathway again. Is there something new down here?
No, I mean a healing flask. They mean your health. Oh, you mean I can abuse the healing even more
So there's just nothing down here anymore
That just was the secret. Okay. We did it. We did it
It goes up to 12 Ymir's robes have a secret if you alter them. Ooh
Remember that time people were complaining that you can't play the game without knowing everything
Like having to look it up online and I was like, honestly, can I agree go to shadow keep shadow keep
Can you tell I don't know anything yet here
Shadow keep backgate
Okay, okay, we're goldy you can unlock the tail lip
tail
Lee trust rotation spell if you rest at the church and go to the right. Why?
Do I need this?
I'm gonna let you guys get to me
Vlad you've not had a shot
Is it dragon
Uh
Maths shot doesn't count. Yeah, I was gonna say your shot didn't count. You're literally an enemy. Oh
The misery
Enemy who wants to be the bad refling
Who wants to be the naughty refling? Hmm who wants to be the big bad man?
Hmm
You get one moon
It's a boss fight. We're here. Haven't we not already done it?
Why are you naked you took off your clothes so oh
You really are dragon. Hi refling. No, don't be sorry
Vivi watch along last night and time stamped it all in the comments
Such as an enemy. I was crying too. Good luck with the elven gaming. Oh, thank you so much tiny spiny
And thank you for the timestamp. I actually need to update vivi and also need to update the workout stream that got time stamped as well
Uh secret doors open. I don't think she did hog ride
I've been through the door before
What
So there's no fight here refling show her the secret door. Okay, show me the secret door
Uh
Hello
Wait, I need to write down your name. Why does it not show me your name? Okay?
This doesn't count but I do put you down if you've been an enemy at least
Go outside go outside. Uh, excuse me reflin. Tell me you've got enough. Yeah
Wait what?
Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no, it is a fey. Uh commander geus
Geos I kiss more lake. Uh, ha ha ha
He's raiding a piggy
I'm helping I'm helping I'll call the damage I've done
What does the gray on it mean on the health bar
Okay, let me stand and I'll recover. Oh my god, that reflin's getting shagged. Hold on. I'm coming to save you
Did I save you? I don't think okay that reflin's down. Uh, let me hydrate a little bit and think about what I need to do
I uh-huh
Oh
My god when they hold the attack I can never predict when it's gonna swing. I'm like so bad for it
Okay, I'm not going in front of that because that was brutal
Okay, uh
I didn't get a lick on that at all
Hold on. I got this. Okay. I think you're about to take aggro reflin. Hold on. Let me come in. I'm coming
Well, I'm doing terrible. Um
Oh, shit, what is that?
What is that, you know, did you guys ever see that tweet that was like this is what Japanese toys looks like like figurine to oh come
um
You know, and it was like one of them was dancing up and down like wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
Like do you know what I mean? Do you know what tweet I'm talking about?
Uh
Torin is allowed to be on the fight
The whole grader got me this dude can be annoying. Well, good thing. I have an infinite army of
Reflings
Okay, who's joining this one? Did you
You were in that last one ruin reef one. He's not union ruin. Oh
Okay, I won't summon a mini reflin
I'll just have two good reflin to do the fight
Jimmy McGee
And before this is actually secretly in me. Oh, I've just called you McCree. Whoops. Sorry. Jimmy McGee
I've just put McCree down. I'm sorry
Yeah, watch an ace in you at the same time. Oh ace is doing a DJ stream if you're not watching it right now
Wait, who couldn't come in? Who couldn't come? Oh my god. It's okay one in three men
Wait, what? Jimmy? I couldn't get you in
La la. That's not your name
My beloved is so cute
Wait unable to summon as well. Wait
It's me it's me dying came
Is that is that your version of how you swuck ham? Oh my game just crashed. I just killed it
Oh, uh weapon weapon need to bless you before the fight weapon weapon weapon
Hey
Get blessed pop pop pop pop pop pop get blessed pop up up up up up. What's this?
What's going on here?
I don't know how to pause a long save you so you're getting coconuted
Okay, where came you getting shocked?
Okay, you've been you've both been blessed are we ready for the hogs
And then press Y
My beloved my beloved
Okay, are we ready to rumble traverse that mess
Oh, I'm traversing so hard right now traversing all the way over to my uh my we souls
Give me muscles. These are mine
I earned them. Okay, right. Who am I looking at?
Piggy
Okay, piggy time
Okay, I've locked on to the piggy piggy's locked on to me. Give him a little I was far too early
I like your enthusiasm far too early
It was good
Oh got a magic going on
Oh
Oh, did you see that perfect? Oh
Ha ha I was gonna say did you see that perfect dodge instantly gets back like kicks out by the thing
Okay, and then one big well, okay, did I even hit it there? Oh, well, I got his aggro so I must though
Uh, excuse me, sir. Oh my god. Stop with the delayed attacks. I can't tell
Oh, it's so hard
To
Tell who's got aggro
But I like it this way. I like when we're all like
Fucking hell you guys have some really good stuff. I need like the distance poison like wrought or scarlet wrought
I'm gonna just hear from the sideline. Wait, hold on. I can put my weebo and arrow on
Whoa
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Why I'm not even doing anything to you. Why I'm literally the weakest link and he's gone for me
How
I can't even get close right. I'm gonna pretend to do some attacks
Oh, you see that a whole
200 damage. Oh, yeah
And maybe should I put blood loss on on knight's weapons?
I could
Oh, I did like a thousand there. Oh, no, it's not someone's got a
Someone's got like wrought on it or something
Oh, I miss
Okay, I hit that one. I gave it I gave it a spank. That's all I had to do. Let's be honest
Yeah, get right. Oh, I just rolled into that reef and I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I accidentally killed in the reef feelings. Hey, hey accidentally destroying my army. Hey
Whoa, I missed. Oh, well he didn't miss
Oh, get right you get uh-huh and get a loser major loser. Get right
Right, I'm going for him. I'm gonna finish him off
No, I'm not I'm too slow. Okay, hold on. Let me try and finish him off again. There we go. I got hit a whole 800
Oh, yeah
Oh, no
I almost died
Leave that reflin alone. Oh, I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm so I'm so
I'm so sorry. Uh, right. I'm putting the bow and arrow on I'm putting the bow and arrow on
I'm so sorry those reflins had it. I'm so sorry
I got over zealous. No, that's not the word. What does over zealous mean? You don't fuck it
We're in the digital age. Hold on. Let me let me open up over zealous meaning
I must know what this word means. It's gonna annoy me because I keep using it over zealous
Two-zells having or showing too much zeal excessive eager enthusiastic. Oh, it's right. I'm using it right. Oh my gosh. I'm so smart
I'm using the word correctly and I don't even know what it means
I'm showing too much zest. I'm a zesty vampire. Oh, no, don't sit down. No summon the reflins in
Uh
And you come I'm actually gonna have to wait down
Oh my god, I didn't even write down who that nice name
Oh wait, I need to make sure you come in before I get you in the throngler
Anyone else here to throngle?
Any thronglers what does throngle mean before I start adding blues to it?
Smart mummy with a big cool vocabulary and even bigger heart
Oh
I listened back to my heartbeat in the workout stream yesterday. Oh that thing was
It makes me want to do
Oh, are you ready to receive me? Um, it makes me want to do the
blessing time
It makes me want to
Do an audio where I have it on my heart for the entire I would get you but we're about to do bus fights
So it doesn't work
Okay, I will totally not die to the pig this time. Where's my lips?
Okay, here they are right and you know how we're not gonna die to the pig. I'ma take my crossbow bow
Okay
And then I'm gonna press y and hold it and then I'm gonna look at it and then I'm gonna
Go
Did I even do anything
Is it working? Why is it spring so high?
It's spring so high
Thank you crazy jest for the extended membership mummy isn't always will be best girl. Love you so much. Love you too
Why is it so high? Oh my god? No, I'm putting my sword back on at least I'm look. Are you serious? I'm actually getting
Okay, let's not do that again
I don't know why that crossbow is going so high
I mean, I think I'm barely fucking doing one in this weird bathroom. No
Oh, it's like rapid fire
Well a little bit a little bit more controlled rapid fire. I'm helping I'm helping
When he stands still I'm getting all the attacking. Oh, yeah
I'll make him frostbitten at this rate. I'm doing fucking nothing to help. Oh my god. It's been like 100 damage
And nothing more. This is terrible
It's not gonna stop me from being bad at this game
199 damage
Oh, this is
I oh, I completely missed that time
Well, please don't go for me. That's really rude
Well, I thought I dodged that but I didn't right. Hold on. Let me put my sword back on
Cannot change equipment at this time. Uh, please don't ever do that again or insinuate that again
Mm. I'm helping
Oh, I missed
Wait, I still do such little damage with my sword
Am I? Hold on how much damage do I do if I get a big whammy on them? Oh
Okay, I do 700 with my sword. That's not bad. Honestly. That's really advantageous. That's good to know
Oh
That I just let this refund it. I don't know
It might be on you
I'll get a cheeky 700 right. Okay. We're not doing that again
Not doing that again
What is that what is that it's putting bows on the battlefield
Oh
I don't know if I should go in or not
Do I have an ultimate on this sword? Oh, I have an ultimate. I didn't even know
Wow
I'm like trying to analyze it's fucking fighting pattern. Okay. I'm missing. Hold on. Can you stand still for a second?
Thank you. That didn't even hit
Okay, that hit
But my ultimate's already finished. I have like zero mana
That's what I get. Oh, I got sucked. I'm getting the good suck, but not the good good
Hold on hold on. What are these?
Okay, main take that. No, fuck you got me back. Oh, fuck you
No
Don't pick on me. Okay. He's getting both of us
Oh, if we're going down, you're coming with me refund. Do you understand?
Right. I have a wondrous flask wherever that does. Okay, apparently it heals
Okay, let me use my ultimate
Oh, and I'm too far away. Hold on. Let me get a bit closer. Are you ready? Little 700 cheeky 700
I'm
I'm not awake enough even though I woke up ages ago
To have this reaction time to this stuff right now. Oh my god, I need hydrate. I need hydrate
Oh my god
Yeah, oh my I'm out of heals after this
I suck I've not even got my second hand on the sword out. Right. Okay. Right. Let's try that again. Let's try that again
I suck I suck I suck I suck
I'm like goofy. Yo, yo, are you ready to do it? Okay, let's go again. Let's go again again again again
Ain't nobody gonna break my smart
Yeah, anybody found me in the home. Oh, yeah, you've got to keep on moving
You had a shot
Yeah, you did have a shot, didn't you? I just never wrote your name down
So I think this refund is next
Math you've had a shot
Jimmy McGee you lagged out. Let's see if you don't this time
And before it like corrupts every time you try and come on come into my game for some reason
I
Unable to summon I broke his fucking thing again lol get wrecked
Wait, so then is it you first? I think it's your first
I guess it's not meant to be how does he break in? No, you didn't summon renala. Oh rella. La nana. Sorry. I don't know why I thought it did
Oh, you're getting ready to be
It's time. It's time for your blessing
Would you like to partner up so I can take two on you at a time two briefings at a time?
I've proved on alt where I can take on three briefings at a time
Okay, ready
You have been blessed get blessed pop up up up up up up up up
Okay, you're ready this time. We're so totally gonna win. Okay, let me equip this
easy peasy win
Easy peasy win you guys just have to spam whatever attack it is that everyone complains about on tick tock
or whatever
There's like this parody tick tock that count
That's like strength players have it so easy
And he does magic and he like purposely breathes heavily down the mic and everything
And I'm like t he's the funniest thing I've ever seen
Stop it main
Oh my god, he that briefings getting his ass beat. Oh, I'm out of stamina
Literally should have thought about that first before showing up
Oh
Right, okay, let me oh get lightning strikes even the elements of the world when you win
Uh
Yeah, that aggro change in every two seconds
Oh my god, you got it
Oh, I'm gonna take it though my critical hit
Yikes or that per animal. That's not fair on him
I feel really bad for him. He's just doing what his master tells them
Hold on. I'm out of mana
Sure, I'll take this
Why did it go come for me?
I almost come for me in that move. All right, hold on. Let me hydrate
I
Okay, no, let me attack
No, let me attack
Okay, use my ult
Did I hit it? I think it is
Ah
I forget how long the lines is
in the in the midst of a fate
I've actually done so much more of this like little distance sword attack
I'm like, I don't want to speck into magic though
I feel like that's not me
Like I like taking a big wall up out to someone and breaking their poise
Like I find it really satisfying when the enemy stops attacking me because I've broken them
Oh, you got a critical. I'll do it. Oh, I was too late
Oh, oh my god, easy peasy first try we did on our first try. Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah. Thank you for your service. Mwah. Mwah. Thank you for your service. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah
Easy peasy. Let me squeeze you
Accept your role become a magic. I kind of feel like I should honestly if I'm just to stand back so much
Uh, right what now?
Oh, there's something over there. I see it
We've never been here before
Okay, let's go to this grease site and then
Or is there already a fight past this? I wouldn't put it past the game to be like, um, yes a fight right here
A big upgrade this week. Does that mean big fight this way as well?
It's just a quick run through the area. Okay
I'm on my heavy plane
Mmm
Okay, where's the thingy mub over is it just inside the castello?
Wow, that's a big castello big many years to build many many
Although many hands make light work or whatever it is. They say
Start in the support rule arc go further up the path and there's a skeebie fragment
Yeah
It's also blinding very blinding. Hello skeebie par. I would like your help
And making myself even stronger
Oh, okay, I see all the parts
I'll take you and you I'll take you and I'll have you think he is gorgeous juicy
Mm-hmm vibrant love it. I'm here for it
Hey Jason check get me in the bowl. I'm gonna cook myself. I'm cooking myself
This is a really strange bowl
Oh
Thank you crazy. Jesse. Hold on. Hi, Jason
Sprite counts, right?
Cut fish wait, can I even get out? No, I must be able to
Okay, uh, and then I go back. So this is just the dead end up here
Yeah, it's just the dead end to collect whatever bits and bobs you find
um
So those are oh, what were you I saw you acquire materials
Blessed boon shot. Oh my so blessed so boony
A bale next
Mesmer, I'm not sure. I was gonna go back to the traveling
my little
state of grace and upgrades and then
um
I'm not sure
Don't forget to drink some water. Yes. I want to go easy on my tummy. Um
Oh, you're annoying
Uh, I got
I'm not very hungry at the moment
um
Just because of what happened before stream started
Okay, hold on shout around person
Oh, it takes three. I'm at 10. So the max is 12 as well
Uh, right. What or where or when or who or what or why?
Oh, I discovered it the set could do three chalice
I've completely forgotten where any other fights are. Um
Max is 20 you need to find 50 fragments. What do you eat to soothe your tummy? I don't know. I was just gonna have more take away
I don't have time to prepare food. I was like just have a cheeky take away
um
I'm not sure what to do
There's an enemy inside the summit that we didn't do will we do him?
Dark chamber entrance has a boss dark chamber entrance
Dark chamber enterons
Any dark chamber enterers look at me for real for real
Dark chamber entry deep dark
Dark have I not unlocked it? I don't think I've unlocked that
I just look
Nord
And the name of the Nord's I pray to the Lord's
At the top where you are. Wait, there's something here. Show me
This this way no, that's where I came from
I have to be probably second most annoying boss. I'm satisfied. It's your dark chamber. No dark chamber in dark chamber entrance
That castle near you
Oh, okay, and now what?
Oh
Oh, you mean you mean behind that portal, huh? Yeah, I wonder if there's a boss behind here
I didn't have we already attempted it
What's the bot? Oh my god, I love you reflings. Thank you for one to play with me. Holy shit
um
I'm just gonna make sure no everyone gets a chance
I
Write your name down on my wee piece of paper
You've not had a shot either
Thank you for wanting to play with me. Uh, it makes me very happy. Okay, not to get too staffy. Okay. It makes me happy
I like being able to play games. Yeah, and even though I know I'm probably really if you do genuinely like are like really into
Elden Ring, I'm probably the worst person to watch
And play it because I'm just like
Um, right what boss is behind here? I don't remember a boss behind here
Oh, why would you do that?
Roofling, why would you do that?
I'm not ready
Oh my god, I am not ready
You little thing you refling
Oh
I don't recall. I don't recall any of the moves
I don't remember a thing
Hey, he doesn't even have poise breaking things
Am I going mental and he just spams
You're so stinky. Oh, there's just a little boss behind here. Oh, yeah, just a wee one. I just a wee boss. I just a wee a wee boss
Bruh, we aren't even going to get to the snake stage right
I'm going to have to lock in to try and remember his attack patterns. Oh, I should have been in that trap
Oh my goodness right, hold on. What was I don't know what my flask does well take it
I mean, I can't do that. Is that even going to hit him? No, I'm too far away
Oh my god, I forgot. Wait, let me watch see the trans
uh, the trans changing thing
From one thing to another
Transition there you go
I've not seen it since obviously the last time we played
What does he do
To change
He's a snake a sneaky snake
No, mother
Figure it for me
There seems to be a lot of mummy issues going on in the dlc. Oh, not to be eyeball
Hey, don't don't don't pop it out. You keep that eyeball
Pop goes the eyeball
Pop goes his eyeball
And now he becomes a sneaky snake
His grape of frenzy he popped his ball just to become a snake
Oh my god, give him- Mommy, please forgive me, mommy, for I have sinned.
I can't even remember.
Ooh, he looks mad.
Of the abyssal serpent, shorn of light.
He's like me, I have worms for brains too.
I don't recall a single thing. I do not recall a single thing.
Okay, he's extra agile. I'll give him that, extra agile. Let me just give him a good old
tallywax so I can see I hurt him. Oh, there's a good reflin, good boy reflin. Keep it up.
Oh, you're such a well-behaved boy. Keep going. Show him a good time. Oh, that's right.
Mommy's so proud. Keep it up. Mommy's really proud. You can do it. You can carry me on
down this wall. I'm helping, I'm helping. I just not go far enough. Oh!
Oh, I had a one-shot bubble on me that protects me. Okay, fuck it, I'm going in.
I'm not, I'm going out, I'm going out, I'm going out, I'm going out, I'm going out, I'm going out,
pull out, pull out, a bore, a bore. Okay, I have more art war now.
Stop wiggling. There you go. Stop wiggling. Out. Oh my gosh, he does so much that. I'm like,
how do you guys survive for so long? You already have like the, the thing
against you that makes things this harder. Oh my god, please don't die now, reflin.
I love you. Please stay up for mommy. Mommy's scared. Mommy's really scared right now.
Please. Am I helping? I think I am.
I just need to not die. Copy. Copy. Oh my god, reflin. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god, you can do it.
You can do it. You can kill him and keep me alive at the same time.
I believe in you, refling. I'm staying away. Out. I don't, okay, maybe I shouldn't stay away?
I don't know. Fuck it. I'm, I'm just going to cheer from the side lanes. You can do it.
I believe in you. You can do it. You go, refling, refling. You did it.
A curse upon thee. Oh wait, he just cursed. Why? Oh my god. Mesmer's kindling? What does he kindle?
Give me a healing stone. Thank you. Oh, you're like, oh, your watch is over. Oh my gosh. You guys
have fucking upgraded. What was Mesmer's thingy, my boba? Or was it not that well I picked up?
No, I guess not. Beloved starter. What does it do though? I don't know. Why did I just take
off to do that as well? Oh god. Someone's not being paying attention. Yeah, well,
sure. That reflin was a Slavic chad. Oh, chad, sorry.
Oh my gosh. Okay, I'm going for a sleepy at the rest of the day so I can get all my things back.
You guys are fucking MLG though. What's this? Am I supposed to read something over here?
No, definitely not. Read message. I did it. I did it. That was fun. Thanks, mommy. Why are you
thanking me? You carried me. Why are you saying thank you to me? It's all you. Where did I go?
It's pointing this way. Thank you, no, Alessandro, for the moony money.
Dad, I need to summon you in here to take me where to go next.
This is a furl... Oh, sorry. Didn't see that. What are you? Hello.
What cruelty is this? I'm not sure.
Rather than my one vital purpose, how I saw fevered, worthless, dull, uplaid that vengeance
was never to have been my... Oh no, he was the one that wanted to kill Bill. Oh, I'm sorry, mate.
It was me. It was that reflin over there. Him over there.
Almost cherished wife. Child. It seems vengeance was not mine to enact.
You didn't summon him, are you sad? Tired blade. I'm not, like, corrupted my game, though, no.
Where now should I point my tire? Look, your enemy's defeated. You're welcome.
Shouldn't have said it. Okay, I can't seem to summon you guys in here, so I guess we go elsewhere?
Uh, now you have to fate him later. Jagged Peek Summit. A body hook not.
When you say I have to fate him later, you mean you, right? You mean you?
Yeah, you're gonna be fainting him later. Yes, you are. Yes, you are.
He's my handsome little refling. He's a good boy. Are you gonna fate for mommy?
Yeah, you're gonna make me proud on the battle field.
Yes, I can reflin to you. Is it it?
Who's fainting for me this time? You. You're at the start. I'll just make sure there's no new.
Okay, Galavan, we always knew.
I will do a whole praise audio ASMR right now. If we defeat the DLC in one day, you're getting a praise
audio. Just fight Bale at Jagged. Wait, Bale shows up here? He's that mad at me?
I'm sorry, big Bale. We're like...
You're getting a moan.
Could you imagine if I could do a roly-poly right on your tentacle? That would be pretty mental.
Hello. Oh, you've got a coconut weapon. Look. It looks like a glintstone coconut.
Are you ready? Well, mommy and Rufan's on your head. Thank you for hanging.
Okay, taint to destroy some things. I forgot every fate. I just know there's something big and bad behind.
Oh, yeah, he doesn't have his wee wings. He has, like, sticks. Oh, per guy.
What is the dragon without his wings?
Oh, he doesn't have a leg either?
Is there, like, a benefits system in this, like, area? I feel like he needs, like,
there's no way he can make an income for himself. How is he gonna make food?
Like, he needs to go with the lobster shack and stuff.
Is it hot in here? I'm not sure why. Oh, my gosh. I feel really bad for him.
Summon Igon? How'd I do that? Is he at the door? Sorry. Well, it's the Riefling's
fight for their lives. Igon. Igon, where are you? Igon, are you at the door? I think you are.
Okay, let me get him.
Oh, he does have wings. Okay, someone's looking for, you, keep up, reflets, you're doing great.
I'm just looking for a gold sign. I'm looking, I'm just looking. I'm brosing, I'm brosing the
catalog. Where the fuck? Am I going mental? Have I seen it? Gotta use his finger in your
inventory? Right, Riefling, you keep it up. I've got, I've got fingers. In my inventory? Right,
a finger. Igon, Igon. Like this? No. What? What's the, what's the thing called?
No, you don't use it from inventory. Did we just kill it? Oh, you didn't do the quest?
Whoops, question mark.
I tell the, you can't summon him if you don't do his quest. You either have the finger or you're
doing, so am I, are we killing him or not? Did we come back? I mean, the Rieflings are
kind of smoking him. I'm not going to lie. Did I tell the Rieflings to stop?
Extra only working hard during this one. Literally, I'm fucking about in my inventory
while the Rieflings are absolutely decimating him.
You, you're killing him. Kill him, kill him. Go, no, keep going. Right, keep going, Rieflings.
Keep going. Mummy's so proud of you. Keep it up. You're doing amazing. Go, go, go, go. Destroy him.
I'm helping too. I'm helping too. Look, see him coming over. See me losing all of my stamina
before I get close? That's my super awesome move. It's my best move. I call it losing stamina every
second. Please don't fly so I can get one hit in, please. I've literally not done a single bit of
damage. Right, hold on. Okay, I missed. And he's gone. Uh, oh, and he's back. No, stop. Can you
target his leg or something? Oh, there's his little, little meaty leg. I think I did 700 damage.
You're welcome. You're welcome. I did 700 damage. Oh, he came in like a Riefling. No, we've lost one.
I'm running, running, and running, running. I'm out of stamina in like a second.
How did you dodge? Oh, you didn't. Sorry. Bro, I can't get close enough to kill.
Stop it. Leave my Riefling alone. He didn't mean it. It was a misinput. Oh, no, I'm on my own.
Oh, no. Please, please don't embarrass me. Please don't embarrass me. No, he's 1 HP. Please, please.
Don't, please. Don't, please let me heal. Please let me heal. Please let me heal, please let me heal.
Right, I healed, I healed, I healed. This is embarrassing. This is embarrassing. Hold on. I need one
hit. Okay, he walked away. That's fine. He's allowed to do that. This is embarrassing. This is embarrassing.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on!
Mmm, mmm, mmm-hmm.
Mmm-hmm, mmm, mmm-hmm, mmm-hmm.
I was lagging, I was, I was lagging all over.
Did you not see that lag?
Right, Jimmy, if this breaks, I think your console just hates me.
Is anyone?
Grats, gee, you've not had a chance.
I am so sorry, Reflins, that did that fey.
I am so fucking sorry.
I am so sorry.
I mean, I did do 700 damage.
I hit him once, so I did my part.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, you made it, you can connect.
Okay, Reflins, are you ready?
Oh my God, what are you wearing?
Oh my God, it's so late.
Right, you have been blessed.
Okay, now, you need to do what the other team just did,
where I get to sit and do nothing.
Okay, whilst I was mucking about my inventory.
Alright?
Okay, okay.
Good news is you can go find Aegon.
Oh, should we?
Oh, go do the quest.
Oh wait, sorry, Reflins.
Right, come take me to the quest instead.
Right, where do I go for the quest?
Come, Reflins, come.
Where does it start?
That's the question.
So this is what the map is unlocked.
I have a really itchy fucking nose right now.
I've been like itching it and nothing is making it less itchy.
Bottom of the mountain, kill two dragons at the bottom of the mountain.
At the jagged peak mountain side?
Need your horse, so might do solo.
I need to fight a boss on my own.
Right, so as Reflins come back, so as I'm not fighting on my own, fuck that.
No.
One Reflin just fell off.
No, I'm not.
No, I've had to fight on my own.
No, get shagged.
Sorry, Aegon can, Aegon piss off because I'm not doing it.
Grats, do you want to put down your sign again?
I don't know if I can get you Grats.
No, you can summon for the boss.
Oh wait, I can summon for the boss.
Oh, you don't have to fight them, right?
Okay, Jimmy, I know you just connected, but can you not be here and then...
No, just disconnect with the furl-
Don't jump off!
Why do you always go Reflins?
Is there something going on?
Why do we always go straight for imminent death whenever I need you to leave?
You never use the furled finger, so it's just imminent death.
Okay, right.
I go...
I let it disconnect, and then I go down to the mountainside.
It's that Mummy doesn't want me.
Mummy doesn't want me, what's the point?
Right, I'll take your names off the list because you didn't even get a fight.
Right, I'm at the jagged peak.
I'm on my horse.
Now what?
Jagged peak base.
Jagged peak base?
Wait, I don't know where-
I'm not- I didn't even find the base, apparently.
Bro, I can't find your base, where the fuck is it?
Where did I go?
You can't summon for this, wait.
Left, left, okay.
Inside the hole?
It's to the west.
Outside or inside the mountain?
Inside, okay.
Inside the hole, got it.
Wait a minute.
I ran away from this boss.
I ran away.
You said the two dragons fight each other?
They better.
I swear they better.
I swear they better start fighting each other.
Right, wakey, wakey.
Oh my god, it's got sacks in its name.
Right, and where's the second dragon?
Wrong dragon?
What do you mean wrong dragon?
Oh my gosh.
Is it here?
Who's the right dragon?
Well, I'm out of range, okay?
I'm out of range, I don't have to deal with it.
Where- who's the other dragon?
Ooh, shiny red thing.
Am I being chased?
I think I'm being chased.
I'm being chased, something's going on behind me.
Oh yeah, I'm not turning around so it's not my problem.
Right, I'm turning around a wee bit now.
It's left of the mountain.
You went to the midpoint?
This isn't the right way.
Not the equivalent to a pillow princess.
Excuse me, pillow princess is best if you play this game.
This isn't where I was supposed to go.
You can't summon for the fight, the dragons will fight each other,
but one of them is much stronger.
You will likely have to fight one on your own.
Right, so because of that, for no particular reason,
put your thing down at Jagged Peak Summit.
For no particular reason, we're gonna skip that quest.
No particular reason.
Okay, who hasn't...
Takum, you were at the start.
Jimmy, you never had a shot, right, go.
And then...
Grat Zed, are you here?
Oh, I named you!
That's your gamer tag!
I'm gonna see if Zed...
Okay, Grat Zed, you're here.
And Jimmy...
Wait, am I being dumb?
Did I not write anyone's name down?
What the fuck?
It's better if Aegon dies in agony than shame.
I'm the best Elden Ring player ever.
What are you talking about?
The only reason I'm good is because you guys helped me.
But I'm literally MLG, like, every fight I've already deaths me.
It's like, sorry, look how far I got.
What do you mean Elden Ring's easiest game?
Elden Ring's easiest game?
I'm summoning the Dark Souls.
Okay, good for Dark Souls, I guess.
Right, go!
Go fight, Reflins!
Fight, fight, fight!
Who will be crowned the champion?
Someone says you can summon for the Drake Soul.
I'm getting...
I'm getting misleading information.
What's going on here?
Okay, I rolled right into that, my bad, chief.
I couldn't beat the first boss.
This is really hard!
Go Reflins, go!
I'm providing emotional support.
This will be your reward when you win.
This is your reward.
I'll make you sound like that through any means necessary.
At the grace I can summon them in.
You can summon players, but you can summon spirit ashes down there.
Okay.
Yeah, very contradicting, Reflins.
One says something, one says the other.
We don't know!
You can summon.
We're bickering!
The Reflins are fighting!
I'm cheering them on!
Go Reflins, go!
Okay, this...
This duo don't seem to be unfortunately complementing each other.
Sometimes the T...
Sometimes the Reflins get really lucky and complement each other.
And then other times it's really hard.
He's very got...
Very fast.
I did a whole 500...
300?
700?
Oh, that's right, I'm just that good.
Oh, back off, back off.
Easy.
What is that Reflins going...
Ahhhh!
Four!
Oh, jeez.
Is that you?
It is you.
All up in my ear.
Last time it only got so far because of an exploit.
Really?
What is it?
Let me do it right now.
Reflink down, I repeat, Reflink down!
It's not looking good, bruv.
It's not looking good.
Wait, did I leave my...
Am I...
Hold on, I can't open the map because there's an enemy.
Oh, there they are, there's my soul.
Magical Spiral can hit a bunch of times.
Who's got Magical Spiral?
Can I even do any magic?
I think I'm like too weak to do like one bit of magic.
I'm not even kidding.
Yeah, like I literally cannot even hold weapons of magic.
Go, Reflink, go!
I'm sure this is a totally fair fight and you're not at all nerfed.
Because of how the multiplayer works in this game.
What's that?
You're one shot and taking on this?
Oh my god, I'm so bad at dodging.
Excuse me.
Oh, what is he doing?
Oh, oh!
Okay, I deserve that, I'm gonna be honest.
I thought it was gonna be like one of them delayed attacks.
I deserve that, sorry.
Oh!
Maybe not on the fire.
Okay, we have Phase 2 unlocked.
Ow!
Bruh, I'm not gonna even survive.
Wait, what?
I can't get up!
I couldn't get up!
I got a stun lock!
Maybe, I think I just lucked.
I got a sticking stun lock there.
I was getting wrecked and decked.
Shaking my head, my head.
Okay, let's try that again.
You've had a shot, you've had a shot.
You've not had a shot.
When was that hit stop, man?
You've not had a go.
Tonsel Storm, a fucking ninja.
Tonsel...
Storm...
Power!
That means Ratt was too strong.
Yeah, there's glitch.
You guys better start abusing that glitch.
Like, you abused it.
Hydration check!
He's...
I was gonna do endurance until Mercy comes on.
Oh, you're kneeling already?
Are you kneeling like a good little piece of...
Hold on.
Eek!
Oh, wait.
Bunk!
Oh, eek.
Okay, and then two-hand it.
And then I'm ready if you're ready!
Nice and chill up in this game.
I'm so sorry.
I'm trying to make sure everyone who shows up gets a chance,
and then I'll bring in reflins that I've been in before.
Are you ready?
The other one isn't ready.
Is he away for a piss?
Piss faster. Piss harder.
Squeeze out your bladder.
Or let me press.
Let me press down on your prostate to make it come out faster.
Fry that chicken.
Until Mercy will be here at least Monday.
Oh, is Mercy off?
Okay, my bad.
Just because I've woken up four hours before stream?
God, you're pissing hard.
God, damn.
How much have you gotten the engine?
What happened?
How do I mo-
No, not status.
Gestures.
Let's sit.
Low rest.
I'm gonna put my foot up your ass.
I'm like, I'm floating next to you.
No, no.
Bladder for the prostate brain.
No, I think that if your prostate is in trouble,
your pee, your ability to pee is the first thing that goes a bit funny.
Like, it doesn't come out properly.
He's gonna rip starting a chainsaw.
Still 30 plus before I can join?
Oh, minutes?
Oh, no, I'm streaming quite a bit.
Mercy might not be streaming tonight since she is staying with a friend.
Her friend is streaming for the time since they lost their pet colon on the score monitor.
Aw, that's a shame.
Thank you, Sashpower, for telling me.
I didn't realize.
Aw.
That's not so nice.
Mate, how did I do that mimic thing?
I didn't pick up the mimic thing yet,
because we've not even played the base game.
We started, like, on a fresh account,
and then you guys gave me everything to level up.
I don't have that mimic thing.
The best I can do is a mo-
Oh, mother!
Oh, Reefling, please!
Reefling, please carry me!
Please!
I don't know.
Please carry us!
Come back!
Unlarged prostate presses on the urine pipe making pain harder.
Exactly, that's why you need to eat tomatoes.
I've told you once, I've told you twice.
Even ketchup counts.
Yes, ketchup counts.
I don't know why it does.
It just does.
What are you doing?
How do you put your thing down in BAFK?
Into a seamless co-op mod.
I would play seamless co-op,
but I thought it showed your IP or something like that,
whereas playing it through the servers definitely helps.
I'm sorry, I went to go eat.
Can I kick you out?
I don't really want to kick you out, but...
Oh, I can kick you out.
Sorry, right, itadakimasu.
Bye.
I won't write down your name because that doesn't count.
Itadakimasu.
Eat the talking mod.
Cheeto the man.
I'm not a Jewin.
There we go.
Itadakimasu.
You're making me hungry and it's not even 6am.
There's literally need deliveries for another two hours.
Although, I don't want McDonald's breakfast
because it makes me sick.
Well, McDonald's...
McDonald's...
I'm sorry.
Did you know in French they say McDonald's is McDonald's?
Are you ready?
Are you ready to carry me through the dragon?
I check my prostate regularly, mommy.
It's good, good!
As you should, Refling.
As you should.
I don't...
I didn't even...
I'm getting walloped.
Okay.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
I'm getting them while it's distracted.
He's distracted.
I'm backing off, I'm backing off.
Okay, he's burning, he's burning.
Okay, let's get his tail.
I'm actually doing damage this time.
A Christmas miracle.
I'm helping my team.
Hitting the stump deals extra damage.
That seems so mean.
Hit the disabled dragon on his little disabled parts.
Okay, jeez.
Who coded that one?
I'm stuck under him.
Oh, you got a...
I'm literally stuck at his bobby.
I repeat, I'm stuck in his bobby.
I'm stuck in his bobby.
Oh, my God.
Let me go.
I'm stuck at his fucking winky.
I'm growing stuck, growing stuck.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that makes sense why I was getting
fricking runnily at that last round.
That dragon, that was a bad dragon.
Come on, come on.
Go for his tail.
Oh, yeah.
400 damage, baby.
That's what they call me.
The old hack and slash.
Oh, why are you targeting me?
Oh, my God.
Did I pick up my tear, my souls?
Where are they?
Or do I not have souls anymore?
Did I not die here?
Hold on.
Excuse me, whilst you fight,
I'm going to go look for my dead souls.
Where are they?
Are they not here?
I must have died.
Whoa, I don't know what's going on behind me.
I'm just happy to be here.
I'm just happy to be here, honestly.
Thank you, folks, for having me.
No, really, it's been a pleasure.
Did I not die somewhere?
I don't remember.
Oh, one of my refunds have died, Monka.
Helping a little bit.
I'm helping a little bit.
See, I'm helping.
And being helped to some HP damage.
Oh, jeez, Louise.
Can Cheeto do it?
Oh, he's getting burnt alive.
Don't worry, I'll do some damage.
Look at me go, look at me go.
A whole 3,000.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
It's done a lot.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
It appears.
Okay, 400, 7,000, 1.4, 1.7.
Hydration.
Ooh, I got his tail.
I'm actually not being useless this fight.
Please don't die.
Oh, please don't die.
Okay, and then hydrate that.
No, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold on, let me drink that.
And then let me ult.
Ow.
God, I just, I can't even catch a break.
Curse you, Bail.
I actually still don't know what the lore of Bad Bail is.
Like, is he a really, really big baddie?
Or is he a wee baddie?
400, ow.
I keep getting killed by his fire.
Okay, 400, take that.
400, take that.
Oh, shit.
No, not again, Reefling.
Not again.
Reefling, no, he's 1 HP.
And I'm 1 HP.
Hold on a hydrate.
I don't have any heals.
Not again, not again, not again.
Please, swing, swing, swing.
Oh, no.
Why?
Whoa.
He's a pixel.
And then a swing in his head's not even in front of me.
How did I keep doing this?
I'm fumbling.
I don't know how to, how about, I did so much damage that time.
Like, I actually damaged the enemy.
You've had a, oh, no, don't sit down.
Bruh, that's the second time already.
Like, a slither.
Bubble boy, you've not had a chance.
Bubble boy.
Here's not.
You've had a chance.
You had a chance.
Dizzy, you're new.
I can't believe I've done that twice now.
You could probably put a compilation every time, like,
it's 1 HP and I'm the last one standing and I completely bowls up.
I'm gonna kick its arse.
Can I say that?
Yes, you most certainly can.
Third time's the charm.
Literally, surely I will clutch up.
I was doing so well, like, actually doing like a wee bit of damage
and then backing off and going in and backing off and going in
and backing off and going in and backing off and going in
and backing off and going in.
I did like a whole 5,000 damage
against the 1,500 HP bots.
I actually don't know how big, are you ready?
Muah, muah, let's go.
Fuck em up.
And by, by let's fuck em up, I mean you fuck em up.
Okay, let me run a little to the left.
Oh, he didn't aggro to me.
He instantly went for a refund.
Curious.
That's right, take this.
There we go, 300 damage.
Take that.
Oh, I missed.
300, 600.
Oh, don't go for me though.
Oh, he got that scarlet.
He got that scarlet brought to his doorstep.
Oh, yeah.
Take it, take his wee hand.
Oh, his hand, his hand.
All right, well, that was close enough.
Right, I'm getting absolutely decimated this time around.
I don't know what's going on.
It's almost like there's a common denominator.
That's the problem.
And the problem is me, let's be honest.
Okay, I'm helping.
There, I hit this tail, I'm helping.
Oh, come on.
Oh, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Okay, and then aggro swap.
No, no, no aggro swap.
Okay.
I'll take it.
I've got it from here.
1,000, 1.4, 2.6 or something.
I don't know.
I'm going for the tail.
I'm kind of helping.
It's like a group effort.
It's like a group project, you know?
I'm going to take my wondrous physique,
because I have no idea what to put on it.
It was like heels I put on it, purely and nothing else.
Oh, I found my souls.
But those will be my dead, dead souls.
Oh, easy.
I don't need to get too scandalous.
How does this always hit me?
Right, fuck it.
I'm doing that from away.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
400.
Oh, we've got a critical.
We've got a critical.
Got a wee cheeky critical hit.
Oh, I'm off.
I'm away.
He's away doing something.
Oh, phase two already?
Isn't that a bit early?
That's not 50% of his HP.
I feel like that's cheeky, little one.
He thinks he's powerful.
I miss.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Am I going to go?
No.
I can go in.
I need like fire resistance on or something.
Hold on a minute.
You guys keep the good fight.
I'm sure I have a fire resistance.
Yeah, you guys keep going.
No, you're doing great.
Yep, keep it up.
Fire.
No, you're doing great, sweetie.
Keep it up.
No, one refund stone.
Oh, this is too much HP for a meter.
Be able to...
Oh, I'm not even...
See, this is why I don't like the auto lock
when it's constantly the face and nothing else.
I'm trying to get as we nub...
Oh, I miss.
I think.
I'm a stamina.
I'm staminaing away.
I'm running away.
Right, give me your wee leg.
I've noticed this tail actually covers this wee leg,
but that's a good detail in the design
that his tail, like, covers it.
And maybe he uses his tail for a balance as well,
because he's not got it.
No, don't leave me a defeat.
He's not even half HP, is Ogre.
See that?
That's what I can't be arse with.
No, I'm going for it.
I'm going for it.
Right, no.
I'm calling in for reinforcements.
Okay, I didn't do not do enough damage
to deal with any of this.
Not me perfectly avoid...
Yeah, just kill me.
Balls in your core.
Yeah, the ball's out my core.
I'm kicking it.
I'm calling for backup.
The low HP transition,
because he was stuck in an animation
while refling said a lot of damage.
Uh-huh.
You can...
If you need a fire resistant talisman,
I'm pretty sure that's what I put on.
I can't...
What do these do?
Why do they not...
Why does it not say what it does?
Details, not the wrong one.
Boost fire negation, yeah.
And then what about that one?
Greatly raises stamina.
Enhances jump attack, I do like jumping.
Raises maximum HP stamina and equipment, yeah.
These ones were good for me.
Was there anyone who's not had a chance yet?
Hermione?
Fucking clean Harry Potter over here.
Elvarith, you came in earlier.
Oh, I guess we're back to the start.
Right, okay.
Who was first?
Takum, you're first.
I think packs are wallet both fire and lightning oh
ummmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm
and lightning I even have anything for lightning it's under button lighting very very very
Galileo
Okay, uh, what are you ready to fuck them up?
Have is one glowing and one not
I'm not sure how we done that
Check if you have livers
But that would imply I'm the one needing to do the damage
Oh
Hold on how is they paying attention? No
Please don't die as soon as we enter the arena. That would be rather embarrassing
Please don't do that
livers or defense
Are they a resource?
Actually gonna have to change to magic spec
So I can do something for my team
Okay, so that fire blast isn't as big as I once anticipated. Oh my gosh, I missed I did 300 damage though
I
Can't believe it. I can't get away from the healer
The gender rules these gender rules have hands
I'm order some
Okay, there we go. Oh
I miss oh
We're doing good. Oh, I like that attack was at the Sun. Oh
We're going all to a critical hit on them
300 600
I'm just out of range and no more
Okay phase two we can do it
I'm not being attacked by those bolts either
Where is it?
The mages doing damage. Oh
No
Reflings down
No pressure
Instantly misses well
Okay, let's go for his buck. Oh
Yeah, oh
That's some say this fire goes like all the way up his backside and I'm like bro
I'm just trying to you know do my thing. Oh
My god, I hate when they hold it cuz I can never predict bro
Did I dodge that? I don't know how I was just spamming
400 oh, yeah
That's right. I bet you feel intimidated knowing that I'm in the battlefield. Oh come on. Oh
Yeah, I'm so intimidating take this
He's mortified
He goes on all big strong he's in the battle with me
Please there's something to help my poor replay. Okay at thousand. I'll take it
Okay, that was good. That was good. I'm gonna get to yank aggro for a second. I'm helping and help
Let's just run. Let's just run. I'm off
Okay, I don't know how it
Was wise enough to dodge that
Oh my god, I just realized when you guys connect to me you have to deal with the ping problem as well
You can't even dodge effectively because when you dodge that the enemy's already done is attack. Oh, hold on. Let me hide you
Oh, okay, if I just stay alive
Let's grab that
I
I'm coming
400 that's right. Mm-hmm a whole
700 damage. I'm
unstoppable
What is this one? Oh, I thought it was the lightning one that chases me. Am I dead? No, there's a chance
Oh
Miss
I missed again, okay, 500 1000
Okay, that probably wasn't worth it and all on a stick
Oh
Right hydrate, okay, I'm gonna heal so
I'm gonna just cheer from the side lane go refling. Oh go refling. Go
I
Mean I could maybe come in and
Do the me just the the ultimate swish attack like like 400
Go see 400 on the nose
Okay, I miss
See, I'm helping
Okay, I have aggro
surely ill
No, I don't
No, my poor replaying. He's trying so hard
The boss is so big in comparison
Okay, I'm helping 400. Oh, it's 500. Oh, I must have done it on his leg
I'ma just see if this refling can do it. I'ma just
Not die and see maybe we think and do it
If he dies I'm going in if he dies I'm going in
Okay, let's just let's help with support
Okay, let's go. Let's go. It's my turn. It's my turn
Do you dad roll into that? I don't know. I think I'm supposed to roll into the fire
I don't really see how else I'm supposed to avoid it
Stony and not getting a hit when everyone else dies
challenge impossible
Blast refund stand and finish the mission
This one's hard
Okay, let's go
One HP I swear if you actually are one HP, you're so done. You're done. You're done
Get one HP. You've not had a chance
Pineapple you're in earlier. Were you the one that? Oh wait, you
Right, yeah, I don't think you've come in
No, you've not come in today
Thank you for letting me try yeah, but you're welcome
We're gonna see except you're welcome. I was in the priest's fate. Are you clutching up?
And before pain apples just gonna carry the entire thing
the paint over
Not only is he good in game. He's also
Pain apples also good for making your ink tasting ready
Okay, you have been blessed. This is the one this is the one
You've been blessed. This is the one come come come come
You have been blessed
Pineapples when everything he's been in he's a champ level. Okay, so you're like an MLG
Elden ring player that
That we don't know of it. Are you hating your true identity?
Their head is the weak point, but it's where their attacks come from
Mmm, okay, I'm gonna help by doing this
Yeah, oh
I'm running
It's not what it looks like it's not what it looks like
It's not what it looks like
Oh
I miss
Okay, hold on
Maybe the crossbow would help with this because he's so tall. I think I'm stuck on his groin again. No, okay, I'm fine
Oh
You're getting ultimate hit what are the rooflings are down already
Reefling we're not even in phase two yet. Oh
No, just go a little harder
You go for a little numb he's gonna be mad at you. Why does this don't go further?
Okay, let me hydrate
Huh
He keeps like rotating around the air I'm helping I don't know if I'm not
Oh
Come I was right on the outskirts
Literally right on the outskirts
I
I'm working on I'm working on it's a team effort
It's a team effort
I did a bit. I actually did a decent
Not to berag or anything, but that was all me if we get to phase two that was all me
It wasn't because that reflin knocked him down and just decimated him
Okay, there
Phase two no still phase one
He's being very respectful
Very very respectful
Uh-huh
Cheeky 800. Uh-huh. I wish I could summon you's inside the battleground
Are we made it to phase two? Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh dear
What you can't just spam dodge everything. Yeah, I will watch me. Oh
I don't maybe I won't dodge at all. I gotta keep you on your toes after all
Sure, let's drink my magic
I'm sure about to do real good damage
I can't even get closer to him
How are you supposed to get closer without losing your stamina? Honestly
I think as soon as you get in the fight the the key goes away again. He's like I'm having a
Oh 800
I
Just wish it wouldn't lock onto his head. I wish it would pick his leg or something. Um, and he goes away
I'm gonna go get a muffin after this fight. I need some food in my tummy
Oh
I have cheese I can eat cheese
Yeah, that's right 500 damage take it. Oh shummed it. Oh shummed it. I can never get out of the blasts on in time
Fuck it, you know what time it is
I
Right, okay, hold the weapon aim at the enemy load the weapon and wait. Oh
Okay, then aim get close to the enemy right
Dodge the enemy
Dodge his magic attack little cheater and then aim at his body
And unleash. Okay. No, I'm not not a clue. What's going on. I'm just having a good time. I'm just happy to be here and I'm gone
I'm getting fucking out game
Running out of strong his blasts on after she's cheese. No
Right, hold on. I'm gonna very quick to get something. I have been awake for a lot longer than it
I
Wake me up
Copium copium copium
I need like sugar wake my ass up. Right. Okay. Who's coming in?
Taken you had a shot recently
I guess
pineapple and then
It's not had a shot recently
Those were the girl
The math you came into
Isn't this it not Alessandro would be nice
I find it hard once once we start like going over like reasons we've had a chance. I'm like, I don't know what to do
A muffin muffin. I wish I was that muffin
I have a weapon for you. You don't need someone to make for the boss if you don't want to
I got a cross for the one that goes
Can you drop weapon if you're an enemy?
Okay
Surely you two will know how to do the bug abuse
And I can just set the corner and cheer for you. Surely that's how it's gonna work
Oh, you've got one too. Oh my god
We're both gonna do it
You can drop it as I read. Oh, I didn't know that
Okay, we do we do this surely cook them right and we'll take a bite. Oh, no, I'm not shit. I should have eaten first. Don't mess
Hold on a minute. I should have eaten first that mistake made mistake made mistake made. Okay
Hard to take damage
Right so far load
Load and then spray
Okay, and then what's
What's this one then? No, that's just a kick off. Whoa. I have aimbot
Oh
No, no, not when he's far away from me. That's a bit much. That's a bit much. Okay, not when he's that far away
Like come closer to him and then spray. There you go. You're getting it now
Oh, uh, fuck it. Just shoot since she was thick off
Like if he's gonna put me under him, I'm shooting his dick off
Okay, I don't think about born I was so much
97 I'm like point blank that he likes I'm
Ah
I don't know if I'm helping or I'm better just taking the my wee sword out
Okay, I mean if it if there's a chance it does flood
Um
Who is it that knows how to do the bug abuse? I need two of yous to come in at the same time
I'm out. Shit. I'm out of ammo. Uh, hold on. I'm putting arrows on keep up keep keep up the good thing
Keep up the good thing
Whatever you're doing keep it up. Hi. Nope. Not red. Uh explosive. Sure. No
Carfumar. Why not? I don't I don't know what any of these are. Fuck it. Just everything everything on
I'm coming in. I'm coming to help
I'm back
Okay, let's do that. Okay, uh-huh
Please don't look at me
Please don't look at me. I'm scared
No
Yes, look at them
Because they're so brave and good and I'm rubbish. Thank you
I got healing right and then spray at the body the body the body. Yes. Yes
No, no
I'm kind of getting it right spray at the body. Yes
Yes, you're doing it
Okay, and then a hydration
Okay, and then get close
And then spray and then back off then back off then back off right spray again. Okay, there we go
Okay, I'm doing like 300 a spray. This must be way more effective than my sword. There's no way it's not
I don't know why they were like blonde though
Okay, come close
Take that
All that damage. Oh me baby
There we go, there we go
Not me. Not me. Not me
I'm a good. I am a good
Elden lord, even though I'm not Elden lord because I've not done the base game for this account
Oh hydration
Hydration hydration hydration
Okay, let's get close. No, let's back off. Let's back off
I think backing off would be the wise thing to do. I don't know about you
Oh, and we're phase two we're phase two phase two phase two
Okay
Okay, I mean I can still spray from here
We're gonna need you at calm down
This is insane
Take that maybe arsehole honestly, where is he?
Little strongy, maybe if you all locked on to him, you'd know. Okay, right and your point
Right, let me read
I might just put on any old ball
I know they're fighting in the background. They're trying their best
Let's get a bit closer. I still have two healing so it's following me
Okay, okay, let's get nice and close
Okay, let's reload. Okay, I got 200 for that. Whoa
Now don't be looking at me
I'm going I'm going I'm going
Where I'm running to no one's no one can I do it from here?
Yeah, it looks like it
What's that one?
300s. Okay, I'll take it
I'll take it
Okay, I'm doing way more of these fights though with this. Okay. I'm sticking to this. I'm doing like way more. No rifling stun
I don't know what to look at
No
I'm a stamina
Ow, I'm a stamina
I'm I wonder why I'm out of stamina also me who just spam spam spam
hydration
Good
Look at the enemy
Great. No, we don't no, we don't no, we don't we're gonna swap to our sword in a second. That's what we're gonna do
That's okay. That's okay. I needed my sword. Okay. I needed my sword. It's not a big deal. I still have a healing flask
I can swing my sword sword you cannot afford
Right and press y press right bumper and then boom two handed just like that
Whoa
500 cheeky stop aiming for the head
So-called CBT experts
Stopping for the head. Whoa
I'm out of heels. I'm out of heels and I'm getting annihilated
Can I get a hit before I go down? Nope
I hate this like every time right? I'm eating my muffin. This this is the muffin gang team. It seems called muffin gang
I
Know we can do this. I'm sorry. I refuse to walk away from this boss. I know we can do it
Don't you guys are getting so close stance breaker
I like I'm sure we can do it
You guys like believe me too, right?
It's getting late rest well sleep well. Sorry. I sleep at sleep stream at such a rubbish time over zero. You've not had a chance
I love muffin. Wait, are you trying to give me something?
Okay, I'm eating my them. No, no, no, no, okay hydration. I need hydrated
Is that what you come in to do?
Are you giving me something to try and help me win?
Okay, I've hydrated.
Oh, no, you are giving me something.
What are you giving me?
Oh, how did you get better talisman than me?
That's cheating.
What?
A golden breed?
Hmm.
Who's holy damage?
Is a dragon holy damage?
Mole, mole.
That's definitely better than what I freaking got.
Thank you.
I assume you can't have that, right?
Forget the jump attacks for now, okay?
Let's defend.
So should I just take this spray and pre-out?
I'll take the spray and pre-out and then I'll just...
Because you guys gave me like tons of freaking bolts.
Like tons of them.
So I'm gonna just pop them on.
Oh, there's more?
A spell drake.
Dragon...
These are big though.
These are like...
Enormously boost physical...
So I could just go full defense on all of these?
Fuck it.
Oh!
Thank you for your sacrifice.
I mean, you can just like, furl out if you want.
Um...
The azure red sign down?
I don't see it.
I don't see any other invading.
I will see a red sign!
The magic one does nothing for this boss?
Oh, I might see you. There you go.
I might...
Okay, the magic one does nothing.
So we'll put on...
A bow range.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Great leap is HP.
What are you then?
Shortens casting speed of sorcery.
But increases damage taken.
I don't want to just jump attack.
Maybe like...
Raises attack power after critical hit.
These are so specific.
I'm like bruh, I'm never gonna use this stuff.
Let's do that one.
What do you got?
A bow!
I don't think I've used the bow.
Is the bow better than what I've got?
It costs magic.
Oh my god! This thing's massive!
This looks like something a monster hunter.
Oh my gosh!
This is a monster hunter bow!
What the fuck?
Oh wait, hold on.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Wait, I don't have...
I do so have arrows.
Wait, what?
I have arrows, they're right there.
Are these the needs?
Oh, maybe because it's a big boy.
What the hell is this?
Oh, that's cool.
Oh no, don't drink that.
Oh no.
Alright, okay, I need big boy stuff.
Two-handed sword talisman?
Sorry, let me explore for just a second.
Enhance this attack with two-handed...
Oh, I need that bad boy, Jesus.
And then raises everything.
Okay, that one seems like a good one.
Are we ready? I have my big bow narrow.
Are you ready?
Thank you for my insane monster hunter thing.
It's so big.
Is this Johnny's birthday already?
Honestly, get treated in, like, news.
If we lose this, I'm munching on
Doritos, okay?
If we lose this.
Okay, let's see this...
Right, let me...
Let him do his wee attack, right?
And then...
No, aim for him.
500, that was it.
No, no, no, no, no, don't go for me!
I'm just the innocent little...
Just the innocent little...
Streamer.
No, what are you talking about?
Wait, hold on, let me hydrate.
Curse you, Bail.
Alright, aim.
Look at him.
No, not his head, like his body.
Dude, his body.
No!
Okay, I hit his tail with that.
Oh, that's why someone was screaming in my ear.
I kept going...
This is, like, really weird.
Hold on.
Okay.
I'm doing 300 ahead?
No, I can't be.
Why would you...
Why would you randomly swap to me? Don't be stinky.
Alright, hold on.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
That is cheating!
Hold down left 2 before firing.
Like this?
I'm helping, I'm helping!
From halfway across the battlefield.
Wait, where's...
Why is nothing coming out?
Did I get shy? No.
What?
That was strange.
Okay, there we go.
Did I need to come over a bit?
I feel like I'm so... Oh, I'm stamina!
It takes stamina to hold a ball!
I didn't...
I didn't know that.
I didn't know it took stamina to hold a ball.
Sorry.
Okay.
No?
Yeah! Oh, I did 100.
I'm better getting closer with my...
Oh, as if.
Okay, and then I need to restore my stamina.
I mean, at least I'm helping.
At least I'm helping.
Okay, now he's going to do this horrible attack.
Yeah, that attack is just...
Absolutely.
I just...
So, if you didn't know, since sister did
like all Elden Ring bosses level 1,
I'm like, why would you even
torture yourself with that?
Like seriously, I don't know why,
or how she even did it.
Did I even hit?
No, that hit.
I saw it.
No!
My reefling's down! Oh my god, take...
No, evasive maneuvers, evasive maneuvers!
Get the sword out!
As soon as it's over, get the sword out.
Get the sword out. No, hold the sword.
There you go.
Oh, no!
Right, who is it that was
abusing the bug? Get back in here.
Get back in here! I'm not...
I literally am not going offline until he's gone.
Like, sorry. I think we can do it!
I just suck. That's the problem.
I just suck.
Okay, I broke the curse of me never getting a hit
when I'm the last one left.
Okay, oh no, I died. Oh no, that's so terrible.
Okay, more reefling!
More cannon fodder!
As soon as an MLG... Bruh.
We were going to do seamless co-op
in Ring collab at some point.
It would just be her
and me cheering from the sideline.
Although, I think I would probably do a magic run with her
because I've never done magic before.
Ellen...
Oh, I don't like who's been in.
I just said that chair in the room though.
No.
Uh, grass you have been in.
Is there anyone here?
Exploit only?
I mean...
I'll check if no one else has had a shot.
But...
If we're doing exploit...
Oh, Rhea, you've not had a shot?
Rhea here?
No, you've not. Right, we'll do an exploit only next time.
I kid you, I'm like, bruh,
we are so close to doing it.
Okay, your punishment
is that I have to eat some Doritos.
Oh, what punishment?
Exploit only looks promising,
honestly.
Alright, I'm going to mute for a second
while I munch my Krispies one sec.
Hmm...
I can't get him?
What?
No, I can't get him, sorry.
Hmm...
I only just got here.
I can definitely take more of a hammering
from his attack, so...
Let's get this party started!
Sorry, I'm mute because I got Marshmallow.
That was like, please don't eat in the make,
it really upsets me.
And I'm like, I don't purposely
try and eat in the make, I'm just eating!
I just don't want to upset anyone.
And I'm going to be honest,
I was inhaling those crisps uh oh my god wait oh my god 2,000 souls I have so many souls
Of course you burn
Not nice. Oh, I just rolled right into that fire
Hmm
Yeah
Should I get the Pew Pew Pew it
My god, he's gonna ham on that reef one
He's had enough of you
Ironically
Almost stamina
Okay, we all got a few good hits and a few good hits and let's not get greedy
Let's not get greedy and when you're feeling a bit hungry a bit peckish, but let's not get hashtag greedy, okay
Let's go for this me nub
We just need to focus on the nub that's all
Okay, well close enough. I'll take it a bearer than nothing. Oh
Reflins down already. Oh, we're not even face to I don't know. I don't know
I don't know if I should put the talisman on for aggro honestly and just run around in circles
Oh
No pressure to the other reflin, but I think it's on you
You don't forget I get a cheeky whacking. Okay there a thousand I did a thousand damage. I did what I had to do here
If I send you a martial scene, please don't eat in the makeup say what do you do? You can't please everyone
Hmm. I
Was inhaling them and it's really low like I don't mean to eat in the muffin. That's not very low
I'm am I doing anything? Oh clearly not. Oh
Oh
The way it switches aggro. You're so cheeky. You're such a cheeky enemy. You are you're naughty boy
Stop it. I need to hide right
He's so naughty take that to your little arm nub
I
Still break oh my god. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. I
Mean we made it to phase two. I'll take that as a victory
I
Reflang a horrid I'm getting reflins to help me in game cuz I suck
Point blank
So we're doing this boss bail, but we can a hundred percent kill him because we got like close three times
I just need to stop messing up and actually help, but I'm not really helping much
And unfortunately the lag doesn't help and
And I have terrible reaction time they've been awake for a while, and I'm I needn't sleep already, honestly
shattered
He's joking
Right hydrate not attack. Why did it that was I never hit attack
That was really not supposed to happen. I don't know what was going on there
I
Okay, a thousand, okay, that's the best I got oh
Exploit refling, please
Please I've called upon you explode. Oh come on
I'm gonna eat a Dorito on the microphone to prove that I love you
I won't hurt I will
Okay, okay, we both
I
Heart running you might as well
And cheat the real it and yummy wait, where did exploit refling go are you here? Did you leave me?
You need to exploit harder
Plop plop plop. Is it you I can't see anyone's name. It won't let me open up anyone's name
I
Am level 211 and I didn't earn any of it
Okay, I can't open up anyone saying to read your name at my game bugger now
The server said enough you're not getting being carried any further
I'm not game broken. Oh
Mm-hmm
Is I heart running did you DC?
I
Not work unable to summon
I heart running I can't seem to connect to you as everyone else had a chance over zero. I had you in dinner. I
Did just a fellow
Okay, I think everyone's had a shot now, so we're gonna go. Oh, no angry. No, I'm sorry
I'm gonna take a little I'm a noblin
Save us exploit only let you how long have I been on this boss and ever now I
Refuse I know we can do it
Okay
Oh
Just pop bail and kill them for a straight rail come stream snipe them
The passwords in that it's already pinned I need my two-handed I
Miss
I
Should I wait hold on shouldn't I be putting this one on?
Honestly, I feel like I was so much more efficient with my aim
My blood build lead build. I feel like my two-handed build is kind of putting the shower. Oh
As if as if as if as if
I
Okay face to I'm loving it. I'm call it McDonald's, but I'm loving it
Mm-hmm, don't let it go to your head
Okay, look cheeky 300 under um. Oh run away run away. Oh, I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I don't know what I'm stuck on
And there's Dorito dust on my analogue stick, please
Well, it's on the end of my finger and it's rubbing my analogue stick really weirdly
Gamer girlfriend sucks the Dorito cheese dust from your fingers a some more when right now, please write that down
I'm writing it down. Sorry. I'm writing it down
Hold on hold on
Hold on. Let me hydrate
gamer
girlfriend sucks
de all re eat it all da us off
fingers
Uh-huh, uh-huh fingers ASMR. Okay. I wrote it down. Thank you. Thank you. I'll be here all week
I know it's of the utmost importance
utmost importance
Is that I wrote that down in the middle of the game
How many syllables was that? I don't know how many it took me to spell it. That's how many it was
Oh, I'm out. Oh sugar. Sorry. I'm out on one side
Okay, oh my god, oh my god, we flings have done it. Oh
My god, they've done it
We did it. Oh my gosh, the heart of bail curse you
We did it. We did well you stood it. You stood it, but I'll take all the credit
You don't have it as I'll take all the credit. Don't you worry? Oh
No, I took my spits brandy on medication. Oh, there's a great site. We did it. We did it
Mm-hmm, make done. I'm sick done. I was chicken fried pizza on a pizza. I don't know worse than that one
Okay
You'll arrest at the site of grace. Maybe there's something we can do. What even is my level?
Let's go, thank you
Let's go
Thank you, Brian. Thank you crazy Jess
What do we even level up so my strength is a cabellion and obviously I still suck so
What are we doing dexterity now?
I mean did I just start doing like faith and intelligence to like swap over I guess they're
I don't endurance for stamina does they even go up maximum equip load goes up
Not even my stamina goes up from that read
just
Maybe big
To 80 is that real?
Why not why not what I'm neat one of me, right? Uh
Use throwable weapons get faith up for range
Mmm, I should I should yes, I should is there even any souls in this? I don't even think
Your sword power has a best held in ring game
Thank you, add on one year a liar to thank you though
Best Elden Ring Gamer me at the side of my we cross the ball like yeah
Let's get a throwable weapons. Well, that's what magic is isn't it where I just kind of like wave my we wander around
Go to
mirth runes
Any mirth runes
Mirth runes
Runes I'm looking for runes any runes runes runes
Mmm
There is actual throwable weapons what I keep going
Since someone's around in game you did beat the boss yourself. Thank you. I'll be here all week. Thank you. Okay
Okay, runes it is I don't know what we're doing at the runs, but I'm a go
Oh
What are you a message from Leda
No, literally I don't open up
Examine
Message left by needle Knight Leda addressing to kindred spirits who pursue Markayla's trail
Dane passed on a message this ceiling tree is in the ancient ruins of
It lies beyond the high bridge leading from the first floor of the storehouse
I will join you there once I finished the task
It's Smith script time I'm gonna let you gave me
I'm gonna let you gave me. I'm gonna be I'm gonna keep it a buck 50. I'm gonna get you. Okay. You finished eating so when you come
I
Anyone who hasn't had a chance yet exploit only
I don't even know how to write your name and
And in the nicest way because of my
Problems of reading and writing it makes it so hard to assign you not just a sign you on
Russian I'm putting in red, but you don't actually count as an evil
Take her to sorry I
Do beg your pardon what bonfire we are we're a
North ruins by dry leaf Dane
Which is somewhere in the DLC and the realm of shower
Um, oh, I forgot be makes you jump back. I don't know why I don't know that
Right you're to take me. I'm okay. Sorry. I'm up
I've been I did a lot of talking like I was talking to the script writer and
I've been talking all you want blessed. Okay. I'll bless you
Can evil refling back away because I don't want the boss music in the background when I do my wee attack I
Don't want to
It'll like start the freaking battle me
Yeah, and then you get a kiss too. Don't think I'll forget about you
Right, what are we doing cuz I don't know
Hey
Well, this is juggity. We might have a problem if there is a fog by the ruins and throwing up to soul the runes
Don't say such things
Southwest to the ruins
Oh my god
What is that?
All right, Southwest Southwest hold on hold on. We're going the wrong way. It's this way. I
Think are you skin beating up over there?
Attack on it
Right, so it's way, so yeah, this is right
I feel a BT over again. I'm useless on my own. I say that I'm useless on my own
Right something down here
Something here something here is it by the cliff thing
Oh
Where the one bust the crustacean what are these how am I their misery?
Oh, I'm getting can jump they jump them. Oh shit. How many is there?
Hold on. I don't have enough stamina for this
Right, let me hydrate. Oh use could strongy
Leap that reason alone
Do you know where to go? Oh, you've got light on so you must know where to go
New location. Oh, okay. Um, I
Guess goodbye already that doesn't really count. Does it?
Do you mind can you not jump scare me that would be great. Oh my god, there's more
Okay, thank you for not abandoning me rooflings. I would have had a heart attack
I would have had a heart attack, right? I think you guys have to go and then I'll activate the stone inside and
Then I can summon you on the other side. I I'm not I'm gonna mark out everyone's name
That did not count you literally took me two seconds around a corner my beloved
You go send like this soon enough
And no, I'm not ovulating before someone asks know someone's gonna thank you for helping me
What's this?
scenario
Let's see what's inside this
car
in this cab
To say cave in French you say something. I don't know what it is
Ruined forge of Starfall path. Oh, there's a thing right now. Hello
By grace I air I see another rock I shall find ramping
Monk
Lost grace discovered tingling oing. Oh
Can I not tingling oing in here
You can't put your saying down I
Hear something though
Well, you want me to actually play the game the way it was intended
What are these? Oh
Sure to go. Oh my god
Don't play the game is the way the devil if it do
Is there anything else or is it just him?
There's the whole thing
I'm not going on my own like this. This is terrifying. At least I can jump him a little bit. Are you gonna jump me?
Okay, we both missed each other. We're both embarrassed. Okay
Right, actually, I say I appear to be rather strong against enemies like this. Okay. Let's let me stand up. What are you?
Pull lever sure pull lever. Why not?
That gate
No, oh
You can leave we'll just drop you the with weapons
You mean I don't have to do this scary part all on my own
Don't have to tell me twice. I'm off. Goodbye. I'm off. It was lovely being here. No, really
I like what you've done with the place the feng shui and everything gorgeous, but I don't have to be here
I'm not being here. Bye
Bye. Thank you. Oh, it's so lovely having you. Don't ever ever do that again. Okay. He he he he he
Is there a reason stony doesn't use a mimic? I don't have one. I never unlocked it. I've went straight into the dlc
I don't have it on
place
Okay, now where did I go?
I'm not going against them
I should have just said piece out. Oh, he's waiting on me. I'm here go to cerulean coast
Okay
I'm here. Do you have the scissors bonfires?
I don't know
Oh, it's the clever place. Okay cerulean coast
Uh, it's the bottom one down here
I marked out everyone's name for that last one because I did that did not count that should did not count
Math have you been in? You just dropped me stuff so you just can. Math
Wait what?
Touch cross
Carved work. I love that. I abandon here my doubts and
Vasillation. I don't even know what vasillation means. Okay, the only vaseline
Okay, I ruined the joke. I'm sorry. My brain was coming up with a punch line and it didn't work. Okay
It didn't work. I admit it
right
Man
I hope you know what you're doing
A smit script dagger. Wait, I'm gonna I'm changing a dick. I'll count. Why can't I wield it?
I need faith and intelligence
Danny you go to that lady with a golden blob
And respect the golden blob let's you respect doesn't she?
Ranna's mum or whatever her name is
I need to see her mohen. Why do you need to talk to my mom with a punch? No, look trust me right where we go
Vasillation going back and forth between
two choices
So front door or back door
Little bit of
Vasillation
Okay, where what we're in how?
A scrims good. I know exactly what it's for. This is clearly for I
Oh, I'll put that on for now actually
You get a throwable weapon like an axe
My axe
Uh, okay, let's shove that on why not and then physical why not? Okay, uh, we're I'm full. I'm a follow
I will follow you
Follow you wherever you may go
Mummy they're boomerang weapons like Thor's hammer from more
Maybe we go back to main game so I can respect and put that on
Oh, there's baddies
Baddies over here reeflings roll out
They did physical damage, but range as well. Oh my god
You mean I can not be useless for my team
Okay, I'll do it whatever it takes. I'll make sure to respect for the reeflings. They're counting on me
And it's the best I got for ash kitchen
Oh away against him or do we not need to go against him the worms are angry. I repeat the worms are angry
There's blue jane
They're really angry. What did you do? I what's that frost? I don't know what that is
Knock it off. Right. We're coming to kill you first. You're annoying us
Stop it. You're killing us
Wait, does he just keep throwing the thing? No
Leave my refland alone. He didn't mean it. It was a mistake. Okay. Yeah, take that you stinker
I had the enemy reflands help then wait, can you do damage to mpc?
I
He was annoying a hefty cracked pot. Whoa. Oh, I like that
Idea for a follow-up for the pregnant and you ASMR your tapeworm and your girlfriend's tummy
Oh, that's really shit post there
I
I'm getting the microphone
Delivered it's just like those apple headphones. I'm just having to record it like that
and
I basically was going to do a youtube version
And it was like in utero ASMR, but no you really are basically
But then there was going to be an alternative twitter version
which was
Um
I'll do something and see if it sounds different when
I ain't basically I'm not sure if it would sound different. Maybe like because it squeezes down maybe them or youtube like
Oh, is that not
Oh, I'm to go down. Okay. I'm to go down
Oh
Bold choice. Thank you refland. You're gonna get teleported you giver. Oh, no, you died. Oh
I don't think I should count the ones where we walk around and you're showing me where to go
I think that's cheat suited on. I'm not gonna. I'm not gonna count your names on the list. That's not really fair
Okay
Oh another platform here. Oh, I never saw it. Okay. I'm gonna apologize. God that's quaint the disc
Don't do that
Don't do that. Don't do that. Don't put enemies
Don't
Oh my god, stop. I can hear them. Don't randomly put enemies
Okay, that looks correct. I'm like trying to very gently make my way down making my way down
And is it out? Oh, I just fall damaged it. Yeah, take that. Yeah, take that fall damage a little slain you
Okay, hold on gently gently ease
We're not winning a race over here. We're not winning a race
What happens if I whack them? I said what happens if I whack them?
Okay, they just splurge a little bit. Sorry. I think they like that. I think they're into that honestly
Oh, look at my refunds already picked me up on the other side. That's so cute
Uh a couple of levels maybe torn if I use torn I feel like I would have been tumbling off the map
Right, when did that? I'm just gonna check with new names here
I don't think you've come in
Unless you have none
I have no idea what's ahead
So you're coming in to protect me on ironic loop
I don't know what's ahead. So you're gonna have to walk me through it
I may level up if I
Isn't it not the golden blob women the mum of my wife
That
Will inspect me because I could just take some stuff off because I have like a cabillion
Like mass that so I have like a 99 strength, which I think is like pointless like really near the end
Okay, now what?
Go this way. I can hardly see get that get that lamp on. Yeah, there we go now. I can see
Into the cave
Charge
Queen Rena. Aye the mum of Rihanna are sorry. Uh, there's too many ours
Someone was like, oh, there's another loading stone
Um, someone was oh, I can't claim it. Oh, it's because you're too close to me. There we go
Hydration check. Okay. I'm hydrating. I'm hydrating plop plop plop plop
I've hydrated so hard. Oh, yeah
Hmm
You can just drop some rooms if you need some more levels. I don't know. I feel like my levels are far too much
I should give me big boy rooms like that
Oh, sorry, sorry
I I didn't know what you were doing. How do you do that? What are you pressing to shuffle?
Are they just moving forward a little bit?
No, why are they pressing to do that?
The only mother I'm familiar with is Queen America spam block
Oh
I
Oh my god, I can give you head pass
This is the most wholesome interaction so far
Oh, there's a gap down there. Don't go that way. Oh, there's a big boy
Oh, right. What are we dealing with? What are we looking at? What kind of?
Oh
Yeah, nice try nice try. Sorry. It had to be this way. Sorry
It's not our fault. Okay
I have stacked 99 because of hero runes. Is there an exploit?
That was a devastating kill. Didn't stand a chance. That's something together
We're so strong, but when I'm on my one, I'm so weak literally
Why would they do that
Why would they
No, I'm actually region
Why would they do that? They give me a fright from the reason I was like, oh, well there goes my runes
I'm gonna have to summon them in all over again
Okay, right. Let's freaking beat up these guys. I've had enough years
You're shitty poise
Get out of here
Get out of here. Wait, what's that blue thing? That's not gross
What's the blue thing? What's the matter with these blizzards?
Jump scare drop one
This game can't get enough of it. They're like, oh scare her. Oh, it's sleep
Thank you. I am rather tired
I
Did you see that edit of all of us playing golf it and then ac went to sleep. It was I'm me. I'm miri. I'm miri
No way you get comfortable with that. Wait, where's my other refund? Oh, there is
You get stuck. Did you ink yourself just playing with me?
Hey
Okay, where we going? I think the other reason oh, he's here. He's moaning over here. Why is that where he is showing us the way?
Show us the way
Oh, okay, okay
This doesn't look dangerous at all and I would never acquire material. Sure
Uh
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Sleep is the weirdest. It's apparently has some use in player versus player
Do any of you actually do player versus player? I feel like
I just didn't have the patience for I'm like you win by I'm out
Ooh
I got a flower. Are we supposed to be here? I'm gonna just pick up
Hmm
It can be fun in region. Aye
Uh, they're too big hp
Are they?
What is wrong with it?
I don't know. It's what's wrong. There's so many
Did we just ignore them? Right? I'm I'm ignoring it. Sorry
I'm ignoring it. I don't think this is worth it. Oh
Oh refling naked refling out of the way, please
Thank you
Sorry, I didn't mean to spank you that hard. It wasn't it wasn't a part of the
I wasn't a part of what you signed up for. Okay
Evil balls
Haunted anal beats what the fuck designed that one. Where did you go?
Oh
Oh, there's an item over there
I just hear you quivering in the distance gayling
He's literally quivering in the distance. Oh, you whoa. Oh, you're over there. Okay
I like yeah, I'll bring the flames have rolled around muck and fell. Mmm
Oh, I don't even want to slam girl. I don't know maybe because it's covered in slam and dirt and stuff
Oh
I was going up or down. There's a birdie up. I like the color scheme on those birds
concept artist get on it
Concepts are skilled at skill that color scheme right now
God they're trying to snake boys. Whoa. Why am I going to the left?
Hey
Well, this is like not letting me where I want to tell on it to go
Please don't tell me my controller has
stick drift
No
Oh my god, we must help this briefing that one
Stop sniping
Uh, I don't remember that other one
That other one's getting snake from what?
I
Leave them alone
Yeah, that's right
Get out of here even though your color scheme is beautiful and it's I'm just getting stolen. I'm taking it for myself
Who is sniping? Stop it. You're so loud
Not at all
Literally why so low?
A stick through
Remember that time I was gonna have a game where each of her called joy con
That's such a good game
But it was felt
Joy as in oh, thank you for the heel
What is good?
Oh, I almost fell off the map. Holy moly. I almost fell off the map
Thank you for the heel again. I'm sorry. Let's have a baby me around the map. Oh, okay
I'm getting attacked but I haven't time to compliment the drip. Sorry you'll weave it too close for me to touch it
Close grace
Solitary mints flash wait what?
What does that mean? What does that even mean? Where did you go?
We go down. Oh, I see you
I'm terrible at hide and seek. Okay
You you win you win at hide and seek mommy can't find you out. You come briefly
I
Excuse me. Who's fucking
Day in that who is that? Was that just a random like c4?
A little claymore at the door on the way in like oh, excuse me
I don't know. We're having tactical. What is this?
Oh my gosh, it is right. I'm running sauce. I'm out
I'm out refluence. Come on
Get move on get move on. Oh, yeah
Oh, there's like we scale in guys now. No, no, I'm out. Oh my god. I'm getting obliterated by bombs. Holy crap. No, I'm out. I'm out
I'm out. I'm out. I'm not playing
I don't want to play anymore. I'm awake. Goodbye. Tee-hee
What the fuck I have to kill this? I don't know. I'm gonna run around it
For safety reasons. I'm running
Is that friendly
Oh, I sure as sure doesn't look like it
Okay, it sure doesn't look like it. I didn't know shadows can have fate in elden ring. Jeez
Multi-layered ring of late. I'll show you my ring
Why yes, of course
Uh, I didn't even know there was a gap there
So that was really lucky that my gamer instinct came in for that jumper else. I would have been raging tea
Although we wouldn't have had to have gone far back because we did unlock a new
location
Is your ring of leg listening? I would spend it funny. I I swear I saw something that was like if you spread your cheeks in the sunlight
Uh, oh no, what?
Uh, this looks really not nice
Are they alive?
They're just sleeping
Like in a trance
Huh
creepy
They're not alive. Oh, they're like statues
Okay, they're strange
What does analize the journey further go that way? Oh, no. Oh, no. I know what the mark of maraketh or whatever it is
They listen to mommy's hypnosis stream. Oh, I'm like, oh no, I'm nervous
Hello, mr. Boss, it is I the not Elden Lord yet for I didn't do the base game
Hi
What are you? I'm scared
Read the message jump ahead required
Oh, please grant me the courage to fly to your feet. My dear stint
Am I actually to jump take a plunge? Are you afraid of heights? Um
Am I actually to jump?
Uh
So where does the enemy come up dragon is it dragon
I'm scared you're not dragon
But where's my reef lens?
I'm speechless. I'm not even up
Um, I didn't even have a chance
Okay, I missed
Oh my gosh
Oh the horse is slain
Oh
He does frostbite damage
I mean, we're all just trying our best to smash into them and I'm out of stamina
Huh
Whoa, I did not like that move
Oh and the horse got me
Whoa, what a unique boss
I hate it, but also like I love it at the same time
I am very uh, what's the word?
Oh
Oh my god, he's doing it again. What? Oh you jump. Oh jump. Okay. Got it jump
Okay, okay, okay
I
Yeah, this one is tricky
Oh, I didn't jump that time did I
No, and then the horse is gonna come in and get another triple hit on me. Oh, please let me hydrate, bro
Please. Oh, thank you reflin. Unfortunately. I'm out of heals now
That's not gonna stop me
I'm sure I'll be as if
Okay, let's oh no, this is the jump one jump bitch jump. No jump now
Shit. Okay. No, that wasn't it. I meant to jump. I'm just jumping
It is it's like hopscotch, but worse. This is like the worst game of jump rope I've ever played
Okay, no, I'm not gonna make it
For the replaying
Okay, that was not bad that was not bad
That was not bad
I'm not mad at that
Um, so we should be at the last one. I'm gonna pinch a few Doritos
Uh
I'm moving my score
Oh, wait, so you died didn't you?
And then Revis you died really quickly. I remember it felt really bad for you
I'm eating away from the microphone, but mommy still loves you
Okay
I was struggling to find any crisps that enjoy
And I'm sure you but cheesy Doritos tastes pretty similar
So I need to do this jump every time
We
I guess this is a loading screen for the boss must be oh my camera just popped
Hmm
If you're in Britain, yeah, make sure you eat chili heat wave Doritos crisps on my behalf
Because those are my all-time favorite. Oh, I got my points back
All right, and then the horse comes running oh
I dodged the horse, but then I got hit by him. Oh and I
Oh
Bro, the reeflings aren't even gonna make it down by the time
I'm literally
Oh my god, this is who
Who would be so cruel to do that?
Who would be so cruel I've literally not got a whack on him. You've got this I'm getting annihilated
Okay
Come on, okay, I've not done one thing to him yet
Okay knows my chance
Okay, I did it. I did one damage the rest is up to you
No pressure
Oh, he doesn't have legs
He's just got we bony things
Heal me hydro
Sorry, I might have to take off my
My pullover in a second because I'm getting really freaking hot in this room
Yeah
I am very amused by this boss, but when he gets into that second phase attack is like baruto
He doesn't seem to take any staggers either
Nor does he take any prisoners
And
Mo
I could see that coming on. Oh no, he's doing the thing jump
Time to play jump rope. I love jump rope. I love playing jump rope. Oh my god jump rope so fun
Yay jumping jumping jumping
I don't know how I did that, but I did
No, Riefenstein you are so
He's mine
No
Stop it
Stop it. I'm gonna stamina for this jump
No
My darlings. Wait, hold on. Let me hydrate
Hold on. Let me hydrate one
two
right
No, come here you are so one
That delayed delayed delayed no messed up delayed
When when's the horse start running or is he already in the is that a different phase now?
Okay, fuck you. No five
normally the kena
one
Big delay on the one though
No, I'm not getting him. I think I'd have to
Oh, well
That I like it. I like this boss. I like him
Yeah, suck. I like him
She's game. I'm just trying to learn like his swings and stuff. He's very delayed. The ones that delay like
completely mess me up because I'm just like, uh
May I help you? Okay. I'll go do it again
Yeah
Hmm
Which one
Hey
He's got the euphoria it's over for that boss enemy refling I can't let you in you goober
euphoria train okay okay let's see what we got there let's see what we're working with
come now reflings let us try oh I can't spin I can spin a little bit oh it's still a little
360 oh that did not work the game did not like that don't try and spin on your way down it
does not like it okay horse comes in I do I would like my souls to be honest but I'll
take the L right he's gonna go I was delayed one two okay that was far too late of a reaction
am I feeling okay I don't know what happened there my brain was not processing yeah do
not worry that does not count holy crap my brain was like yes they're swinging I should not dodge
alcohol I'm not very serious I'm trying to wake up but it's not happening I've been not to be
dramatic or anything but I've hit quite a lot of I've just hit a lot of them fatigue in real
life and I've been using wait should I try and let thing in my boobs back in the last two back
in that just literally got annihilated because I never even had a chance to and yeah I'll let
the last team in yellow Goku if you'd like to show up do you need a break and hide it properly I
just so the last three days I've actually slept really well for the first time I've been like so
the girls have been needing a few bits and bobs from me and and I've been dealing with it right
before stream like I've been trying to give them what they need right before stream I just feel
really bad but it's like the first time where the fuck is yellow Goku whatever your name is
whatever that character is from Dragon Ball Z and just like I woke up at midnight so I've been
up for four hours before stream and I just feel really bad like I'm not like super hyper and
energetic because I love playing games with you I really do I just hate when I don't sound like
I'm in like excited or whatever like I'm excited to play this with you I'm having fun but I feel
like I sound so monotone and miserable right now and I hope the microphones cover in it okay we've
got a blessing and type thing is but no like the past three days I've had more sleep than I've had
in literal months like since debut pre debut and it's just being really nice but I think my
body's like wait a minute do that again and I'm like no I can't I've got work to do and my body
just keeps going like no do it again seriously and I'm like I can't I can't okay right let's focus
right one swing and it's delayed and I went right into it deserved sorry absolutely deserved that
wallet yeah and please I'm so bad are you playing I'm playing PC what I need to take out my I don't
know I feel like sword is for him this does not strike me as a ranged fight I'm being on us
oh right into without a without a hesitation I deserve that hit
oh come on come on oh yeah
hmm I like the two-handed weapon it reminds me of those robots from Star Wars the androids
that have the purple things that are with general grievous that's what I think when I think of like
two-handed weapon well he did not want me he was coming for the rifling booty he was like no I can
absolutely less of a shite I guess oh
I'm no getting at oh hi there I got wallet
general grievous is such a badass design honestly a total connoisseur
magna guards is that their names okay remember it jump let's jump in this party
jump in this party no someone forgot to jump ow I forgot to jump right
I'm like a hundred percent sure we can do this fight if I actually contribute to the team
no okay like see that that's not contributing that's just taking wallops for no reason
it's not even an aggro
okay oh miss so
I can't even make it to him and then I'm out right 800 there we go I'm out of stamina
all right jump time jump bro I was far too late are you serious
oh one rifling's down oh you can just dodge that attack by jumping the jump rope master it's me
no please don't go down don't go down because then it's on me and then everyone's gonna know
how terrible I am at bosses I don't even know how you're avoiding all this god damn
him I spoke too soon I'm sorry I love you please don't be mad at me fucking up
right jump oh my god jump just keep jumping jump in this party I put hands in the body right
that was only one attack that got me oh
oh
no the rifling's down no there's no way I don't have this I don't have this no ah rubbish
I dodged them all for the first time
yamiro yellow goku didn't die like last time yamiro
okay that was a good attempt from my sources now we 100% have this boss
easy peasy lemon school you see
okay let's see who we got uh when was the last time you were in
I don't think I've had is there anyone new that hasn't had a shot let me
utilize the names first actually there's a chance the new rifling's managed to get off the work or
oh you look new kheh kheh arn khorn more like khorn muh
oh you got turtle shell
oh me when I'm the last one left and I have to finish the mission
would you let a streamsnipe a monster hunter apparently it's a good streamsnipe game
I've just never played it before I played it for like 15 minutes and I was like um yes
interesting game concept tea and I was more like carrying on the cab
shlop on mi nob like khorn on the cob then she gave me head right on the bed
um yeah okay okay let's do it surely I'm not gonna get walloped
first hit is always a delayed hit then after that good luck figuring out what freaking attack
pattern he's doing you know at least just he's gonna come trampling in
me right and then it's gonna be a slow swing okay delayed and then whatever attack pattern
comes next I don't know I'm just waiting for the refunds to drop in to be honest that hit
huh I honestly felt like that shouldn't have but hey who that's the way and I walked right into that one
okay I'm getting a bit better oh the fucking horse came back twice he can do the horse please
I didn't know the horse could get it up twice I'm so sorry I didn't know the horse could get it up
twice are you serious I was like oh my god I got it I'm getting so good at his attack pattern dies
spin I am spin I'm gonna mark off the two refunds for the last one because that looks
not an attempt that was just an embarrassment as in I am speed is there any new refunds that
haven't had is it you had a chance to we better go congrats the
who is motherfucking
is there not a new one am I going mental was there not a new reason is it you
no oh you just had it right you just had a chance but it went fucking shade in that
huh okay let's try that again but this time we now know the horse can get it up twice okay
practice a lot and you will do more than to keep damage real
can you do me depends what you mean okay we're getting a blessing I'll take the blessing
the boss goes three times and the horse goes twice okay right horse can
horse can gallop twice I don't know if my brain just like cut out all the other times the horse
gallop twice but I was like I've not seen this attack pattern he went in it twice oh my god he
didn't go back on his horse with these stubborn legs
oh can I rotate you spin me right round baby right round oh my god imagine if I found an exploit
where the boss is himself instantly because he did a little 360 okay this is named sperm stadium
right delete dodge okay that was far too early but it's still working somehow
someplace somewhere okay I'm gonna just keep dodging well well I've done it now
hold on a minute hold on a minute reflins are gonna take aggro hold on a minute
there we go they're gonna take aggro and then I can heal okay and one big swing
and get jumped by the reflins
oh he doesn't seem to take any stagger though all right there are bosses that take stagger
surely it's just a lot to break their poise I think maybe
okay ultimate oh that didn't work um hmm
hmm
can you have like a bio less bio balloon or is just the water okay jump rope time
okay I completely fucked that one up oh right into a kind of maybe I'm not sure oh I forgot about the
I'll get there one day
okay
whoa let me out let me out to heal I'll take a back all right if I take wonders physique
did I put defense on that I really need to put defense on that I would bloody love
he looks right okay horse horse is twice horse oh and whoa and the horse gets me love it
oh no
why is he so hard animus animus stamina well hold on recovering stamina
no way he does that freaking move the moment I walk up to him jumpy so red
a thousand there a whole thousand oh no he's doing the jump jump jump jump jump I don't know when to
jump I'm just jumping I'm moonwalking I'm just jumping about no you've changed pick on me
pick on someone your own size just kidding oh what no no no no no like this no like this no like this
oh I wish
he moves around so much to even justify bringing out my wee crossbow
uh right okay steady easy does it no I missed I like how I get swept up in the attack of the
reef and then not like actually when the enemy's going for me that's kind of funny
oh okay what does naming what is what does the horse naming okay ultimate time second horse
horse number one and you come oh the agro changed the agro is going for him oh yeah yeah let me heal
oh no I'm it I'm suck jump jump rope jump rope moonwalk and I got caught up in it
okay last hydration check oh last hydration check
need to whoa okay need to actually do some damage can you stop running away so I use all my
freaking endurance to get closer to you that'd be greatly appreciated knock it off
oh yeah oh oh we did it we did it oh my god we did it thank you reeflings
jump in this body we go bump in this body thank you oh oh that comes later tonight
I should make an I should make an uh an alternative twitter audio and I'm just like
thank you Elden Lord plop plop plop ah thank you for blessing me Elden Lord ah
basically mommy got the last uh you did great I feel like I'm terrible at the management okay
I can't spawn you in in the cavern secret oh I can't I can't oh no what's ahead here again
try death and then try death there's more
I'm scared to go around the corner because there's no refill with me
what was that noise I heard that
I hear that
wait am I looking at an enemy that thing in front of me
is that an enemy
try death
talk and babel nectar leave drink it consumer
go
oh I just died
wait really
it tastes like purple stone coffin fissure wait it'll kill me every time
drink enough times and she will no do it do it again no joke oh
I have to pick up my ruins every time okay
I guess I'll just keep going
and she get fed up she's like can you stop drinking my nectar bro this is getting weird the
fuck you have to do it six or seven times okay I'll take it wait doesn't that no ruin like deathless
runs in Elden Ring
because you know how people do those challenges are like I did it deathless this count is there
it's optional okay I want to see the flower lady okay I want to see them teeny when she pops open
she's like hocus pocus there's a pizza on my cookbook sure I'll take a cookbook by now
hello
I would like more please I'm not done yet
she's like you're not very smart are you but I like the death animation but I like her
insta kill as well that's like some that's some very good poison
um
this is optional she might as well see yeah why not I want to see the flower lady talk to me
hello missus flower lady as your wife okay
oh my soul's now spawned right next to her that's interesting
okay what's this number five
hmm lovely titty flower juice
I wonder how someone discovered this the first time probably just brute force in it honestly
I don't get why the bloodstones are piled up in the corner maybe if you attack her she like
blossoms out
we come back to her
do we come back to her once we've killed the god
I assume that's all she does for now but as you come back after you kill the god and she talks to
you I'll bless you pop pop pop I'll bless you right how did you start be honest
who or what were you fighting oh maybe the poison didn't set in right
he bit something to kill himself okay he's their fucking mother's she has more dialogue
her voice sounds like stroney didn't impression of Azura
hello my bleeding heart don't let her become a god
keep drinking you don't think you'd have to tell me why I keep drinking that sweet
she
and they're probably trolling
okay
divinity is beyond saving
oh yeah there's an fm boy or something
there's an npc called throller pillar pathways if you're telling me fencing thinking he'll teleport
here okay once I've got all the words that would keep repeating the same death message okay
I'm sure why my souls are over here but sure give me them give me the souls
just humbly sleeping all peaceful and stuff
that voice while I was fighting the night almost
only two lanes of dialogue
that's okay
huh another one that was near
you think this I mean we could just do it one more time to be safe and then we'll go get
the guy one more time but let's just make sure one more time but take a little bit
a little pain to me
he's not the main character so you can't hear I was like this everyone's Skyrim
okay okay okay wrap it up wrap it up
I'm gonna grab my souls so if I do throw hello um
I said if he figured out how to jump down here I wouldn't have freaking figured out how to jump off
the skull so should we do throller or not we should forgive makilla with murder
and imagine if I was an npc in this game oh I then he came up to do an extra pop off go find
someone can she summon yeah actually yeah can he's completely off he would he would have had
a summon same for this boss too oh well as a flower and a weapon he'll join you as a helper at the end
hmm a weapon and a talisman
so what should I do Nick he's also a really bad summon oh no sorry there's a good guy though
hmm
metra time so for medra we should start at recluses river upstream
unlike the great i go and master of all throller is a terrible summon
metra I don't know who metra is do da do da I don't know who metra is all the duty all the duty
wait oops sorry oh wait I'm supposed to do this one
what one this one castle warren hole
metra is your favorite oh I'm about to see a new boss everyone likes
feels so out of the loop not that one and to go down the grace under the bridge
oh downstream downstream downstream no no stream up stream up the stream is up
uh I summon you guys here
are you winning mommy I don't know I was already an enemy refland
enemy refland gave me gave me through the hardships have I killed any hippos no
oh
is there can wholesome reflands come in here at recluses river downstream oh my oh my are we
bit of are we bit of downstream it's an enemy refland time to head back head back head back oh no
sorry I meant to do this one sorry I didn't mean to jump scare you I almost hurt you
oh can no wholesome reflands gave me that's strange
nope yeah I don't think you guys can come here but only an enemy you may not be okay I'm following
enemy refland surely you will not lead me to my grave you would never do such a thing oh okay you
don't know where to go
oh I'm sorry it wasn't I'm sorry I'm a bit heavier than I originally thought okay sorry sorry
I never did figure out what my weight was
I don't know if the skills were wrong
oh
I'm gonna down the down the river that seems dangerous I did a grandpand literally oh
oopsies oh I guess you're not allowed any further
something down here what is down here have I been down here before
sauce have I been down here before
I'm not interested in getting my butt lamented you know
it's hard to go down this way
uh so I can't come like I can't have you
I'm not hurting the turtles what left or right it's time for a catacomb to the left
to the left looks like it's to the left
to the left to the left there's a catacomb apparently somewhere here
I need to go down the cliff jumpies by the waterfall
you need to find another way down on my own what do I look like a big girl
figure out oh there is
I'll let I'll do the fight later yeah yeah totally I'll do the fight later don't you don't worry about
it okay let's now Torrin I know how much you love to like random yeah like that don't do that
Torrin I love you darling don't do that thing you're doing okay you're so eager to please I know
but don't do that you're like there will be a dungeon door at the bottom along the wall
heading eastward this is the east to me okay let's go east
come down
get me in get me in get me in oh my god sorry that shadow scared me there's something coming after
me there's something behind me get away get away you fell beast oh oh there's a reef one here already
faith bitch okay how did you snipe that oh my god somebody somebody's really fucking quick on the
ball right faith bitch
there's little men in the fog Torrin's the filial guru someone is at the bottom of the elevator
yes
look at your golden toes hi you've golden toes they didn't know that you're you're dripped out
when it comes to Elden Ring you're a dripped out right okay what's going on
replaying oh there's so many it makes me so happy seeing all my reef limbs thank you for
who's not had the shot in that Russian have you been an ally I actually don't think you've been
oh rune you've not been in for a whole second right rune's not been in rune resource not been
in the ages rune a reef limb and then
it doesn't count because you're a bad a lot okay not to be dramatic I've already filled out my
like little page okay this should work I load this boss what am I getting shibis fight with
Georgie was rough oh is she be done this bit is she finished the dlc she's been doing really well
honestly hold on let me put this on my head um she's been doing really well honestly uh
these guys
she hasn't finished it yet
this is a what kind of boss are we about to go up again
I'm getting nervous
oh my god it's on a pogo stick
okay uh
careful the enemies
whoa it's a
okay thank gosh it can stagger I was like oh that's the end of me if it's got a little
lero oh
ah okay gentle gracious oh that scares me when you do that
there's an enemy in the hallway there's an enemy in the hallway
thank you there's an enemy in the hallway just so you should know I'm scared okay
I thought somehow went really well I don't know how that could have gone so much worse
okay all reflins are here all accounted for let me do the honor check out the drip we got like a
got a fire bender I'm the earth bender got the air bender that you slice through air and then
you would see the water because you're nice and relaxed like water slept on a reflin
and literally too much ink
like a cartoon like banana peel you know how they do those whoa okay
oh I said hey
okay
fucking oh fucking oh
oh there's a claiming thing back here
how long did you sleep so I actually got seven hours but I had to wake up way earlier than usual
um but if you're a pin pal a snippet or uh
uh hear them then there's an update on patreon if you're a snowberry or a bleeding heart then
you'll get an update in 24 hours and if you're a reflin then rip us uh wheels get shoved to the
back of the bucket list but I will have it uploaded hopefully within 48 hours oh there's an item here
whoa oh new drip hold on let me check if it's better than what I got I think this is new drip
equipment oh was it that what one was it this
sure why not shove it on shove it on oh no it's rubbish death armor night is like worse than what
I've got everything's worse get that baby shit off and I'll shove that back on okay let's go
death night reflins have to sit in the chair at the hood no I need to edit uh it's just
fucking it's passing on work to someone as well I didn't realize how hard it was to like explain
what I do and be like okay so you need to do this and you need to do this and you need to
do this and you need to do this but don't forget to do this but you can't do this because there's
a special thing in place that is a requirement and that this girl can't do this but this girl can
do this and it's all in my head and to type it out and be like this this this this is like oh
it's actually really like difficult to try like say what's in my brain and give it to someone to
be like this is your job now um dress for fashion not stats I'm here for stats I don't I would have
the ugliest outfit combo ever I'm here for like highest defense most mobility
okay
uh um
how do we what
ah
can you even hurt him what's I'm gonna just I'm gonna trust it to you I'm gonna trust it to the
refland okay well yeah I mean that could have been a lot worth because there's something over here
I have to do much of the laser beam
ooh a lever I better pill it
I pulled the lever crunk wrong lever oh it's bright in here I can actually see
is this a fake wall this is like a fake wall read something incredible ahead are you lying
I've been trolled I'm being trolled again they're lying to me
and there's something in the air
I'm not sure how I get it but I'll get it I'll get I'll get you one day
this little community is fine it's all true
hello mr chess I like you can stand on top of it
big mouth and ashes oh they're just called big mouth
wow I can't believe it over a physical attribute as long as you don't get hit you can dress however
you like that you're not wrong you're not wrong
the base cannon with the base cannon cookie
I'm pretty sure there's just one like that
following the refling the refling the refling the refling the follow how on earth do you know
where you're going this just looks like the same place we've been on this platform three times now
what you bubbling up for where did other refland just go
um
are we about to do a fight is this how long it takes to get here
oh no okay okay okay okay I'm traversing I'm traversing I'm traversing what is this
jury well he did not what is this okay analyzing I've already lost my buff that's fine
you make stuff appear at your arse crack okay I can do that with a good curry on a Saturday night
so I'm not really sure what's so specific about that
okay I'm analyzing we've got a critical
analyzing I do like his battle dome oh I've got a critical apparently I've accidentally got a crit
oh another crit another crit this is what happens when you're poison zero bro it's your fault
whoa whoa he teleport
whoa whoa what is this
fuck you bitch I'm going for the boss not whoa hold on let me hydrate
okay ah teleport again right okay he makes up tons of summons wait how
hold on I can't even get custom hold on knock off knock knock it off knock it off knock it off
enough
okay I'll yep critical hit I like it I love
okay okay Ailden Inquisition it's up it's not ours it's not ours I don't I don't think that was ours
I don't think that was ours that's okay
oh I'm on fire this girl is on fire
I don't think this is ours I need back out of that I don't know
very hard to I'm very how you say low IQ okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
give fuck give fuck give fuck one hp in a dream give fuck
yeah that's what I thought that's what I thought um that's what I thought
that's what I thought that's what I thought make him quiver
make him quiver make him quiver my beloved make him quiver easy peasy that was all the refunds
all fucking me gone paged okay are we in a new location oh we are in a new location
Oh my god
Okay, I can't come I can't get you in so I guess I go a little bit further
Okay much better much better much better much better love the hammer build
I'm gonna check with anyone
Russian
You've been enemy. You've not been friendly
You're rushing and rushing around cuz somebody told me
That looked like a girlfriend, I don't know what those lyrics meant that you had a boyfriend that looked like a girlfriend
Of February of last year
Thank you from so you've been away for a while. Thank you
Everything just goes flat literally. Oh, no the enemy okay
You are the enemy refling
Who's got their golden parrot
I'm splashing in the river I'm
Splashing in the river
Are you ready for exploring
Why aren't you allowed to go back right?
There's an enemy ahead again
We're not allowed to explore a little bit
Strange
There's also writing on the floor
Monstrosity fortnight, oh
Okay
Okay, I see you a little Elden Ring players. Oh, they can be brave
Yeah, and your horse won't me. I mean I could just write a refund cuz that's the same thing, right?
Are you showing me something
Abyssal woods
Okay, where's oh, there is there is I see it. I see it. I see it
Nays and whinnies. Oh
Wait, these are lower ones. These aren't don't let it see you once you are seen. There's no escape
It cannot even be touched. Oh
What is this
Reeflings measure up to horses if I remember correct me near 30 centimeters tall. Oh
Don't hurt the wild life you goober
Do you remember the basics of CQC, what's that?
Down these fucking hammering
Madding hand
Oh, I got an item
Quality caring compassion close quarters combat
As a means when I learned you could fight the winter London
I'm on my high replay
Stony's patreon
Wait, what about my patreon? What happens nothing should wait did something something should have uploaded
something on it
Now we fight in a head
He'll from my heart have from afar has a deceptively big aura
Should be like Lucio is healing
Oh, sorry, I just pulled my headset wire
Tee he I can still hear them. It's something that can't be unseen
What does that mean?
Madness you can't unsee madness
Okay, we've got map a new area fan what?
Abandoned church, okay
I
Grace discovered and then I'm what a crimson tear. No, it's literally a fragment
Can I go into this while you guys are here?
Something that can't be seen perfume of our lady
What hey
Sorry
Okay, there's big trees
We love nature out here
Hmm
I don't like this I don't like where we're going
I'm nervous
I'm only smiling because I have you
It
No, there's a rat coming after me
Hold on
Is that not a bit delayed for the this
This
We're doing no, no
Over
Who's mornin
Who's mornin you're confusing me where to go after that
We're not to be seen by the madness
Whoa what have you done?
Oh
What do I do
Does it know I'm here that run run that just run past okay, I run past. Oh my god. Oh
My god, you got it
Oh
What was that that was terrifying holy shit
That was I was covering behind a tree was that recently just got annihilated
You parried that
Yeah on this connection as well
Is there more ahead or something?
There is there's another one ahead
How can I call in
I need reinforcements right enemy refland you trigger them so don't go all up in their face I
Don't I don't know what to do. I'm just coughing them
Well that guy died that shadow outline I don't know what to do
That go around
No, if he attacks that refland, I'm running ahead for
I
Don't I don't
Don't know what I mean
Oh
That's insane
Yeah, oh, thank you for the healing and I'm
what
You can also use assassin gambit and just run by them if you don't want to fight fuck up Paris once killed their pyramid dead though
Dad I used you guys as fodder to get past
Teleport back to the woodland trail
Why here
Woodland trail, okay woodland trail I
Think I'm gonna have to use these as cannon fodder against these. I'm not like good. I thought I did all right, but I
Guess I'll err is him and he didn't like it
That was scary. I didn't like
I
Paragots rise up literally well you're saying if they never come back once they're killed once I'll take that like that's a dog
Hydration check
Who's grass you're my enemy
Pineapple, you've not been in for a hot second, but pineapple is my enemy
Can't wait to do hypnosis advertising you
Oh
I'm pretty similar to you. Okay. We're oh my god. I like your tummy
I
Might be right in an architect audio. I don't think I'm gonna count it
As a patron audio like I think I'm gonna get an altar
Oh
My game crash. No, don't do that
Don't be selfish. Why did my game crash?
Don't be selfish Elden ring
Don't be selfish come back up right now
Selfish
Okay, I'll take out everyone's name that I just wrote down because I don't count
Selfish selfish selfish selfish
We parried her game to crash literally I don't know why it would crash it's handled everything else so far
I'll do it. I'll put up to a connection thing. See oh
My god, you blew up my IP
You blew up my IP
It was that shocked by your architect strip suggestion. I do anyway. All right, so
and I
Was writing a script with the script writer showing them how I do it
and and they went like oh
Put your belly on my back or something like that and they were laughing
But I was like, oh, no, like I'm actually gonna write something like that
It was something like if it was like doggy style
You'd have to put your tummy on my back or something and I was like no no that's good
I was like I like that and but they really fucking beamin around
Holy shit, whoa
Whoa, my PC does not like this area. I
Don't know. I don't know if I need to turn it down or something
My PC's taking off right now, holy shit
None of your names counted for the ones who were in before
Are you here?
Is it came came he's not had a shot. I
Need enemy refland
The fog in the area is really bad. Can I like tell you to like turn this back down?
No quality sense new like just
New just go late. I
Think I'm gonna tell it to go low for this area because literally my PC is ready to explore
Um, I don't know why I don't know. How do you dragon Russian death bitch?
I'm so sorry right dragon. You're my enemy
Dragon man, man, I
Mean I've heard it on low quality. Does it look that bad? I mean does it even look that worse?
Am I going crazy? Does that even apply?
My PC's quiet though
It did
Maybe my eyes are just bad it doesn't even look that much different to me
You need restart the game for it to take effect. Oh, whoops. Hi. Are you ready? Oh
Right you need to kill the sunflowers on the way so I don't have to wait. Where's my weapon?
Who the fuck is my sword? What I took my sword for take your sword out. What are you doing?
Hello sword
Am I glitched out
Oh
Right on the deep up
Sorry, sorry, right. Okay. What were we going right? We need to be quiet though. You quiet
The sunflower things are gonna gas
Or is it safer a bit I
Could not imagine how much of an exercise it would be to be like crouched walking
Well, I'm just guessing
Miss goes
Miss goes. Oh, right. Okay
He's chasing me
Then not letting up
Okay
Any muscle soreness I'm sore all over how is this one
My shoulders are surprisingly sore
I'm not really sure how because I didn't do any arm stuff. I like purposely ignored it all
But I've got new butt muscles. I've got new thigh muscles
I've got new calf muscles like my legs are all sore. Thankfully my tummy isn't so
Oh my god, that reasons just go for it, right, I'm gonna just stay over here and
Then I can just keep summoning news in in case it's cannon fodder. Okay. It's cannon fodder
Okay, one refunds then that's okay. I
Think I'm gonna party no way you did that no way you're parrying right now. Oh
No, he got grabbed no you've got half health though. Oh
That thing is going for him
Oh
No, oh dear well, who's ready wait, why is it locked on to me?
Okay, that's the fan. Oh, no, no, I was gonna say oh, why did they randomly have a fucking
Reflin's mom you died. I can't get I can't get I'm gonna have to fade out. I'm gonna have to fade it
Right come here you twat. Oh
I did it. I
Don't know. I mean you must have had a really weak. I'm not gonna lie that it must have been so weak. Hold on
Let me get more reflins then
No, wait, I was like, ah, ha ha ha ha. He's stuck on a wall. He's stuck on a wall
I'm brave strongy
As long as you beat him well, right, okay new new new cannon fodder and you come
sorry
Sorry
Easy as if that reflin didn't get him down to like one shot
That should not have worked what the fuck no no no that other reflin a literally got him down
So
Dizzy and came I'm not including you because you guys just got walloped by him
So I've taken your names off of us. You can't it's like I'm not played
Mm-hmm. Elden ring is a horror game training after all bro. Let's just have fun
Where's the enemy reflin are you here are you hating enemy reflin are you showing me where it go next?
Okay, you're he's having a carry on down there look as long as he's happy. Why are you spawning in?
What is that it looks like a rat are you spawning these in
Oh, it's a dragon head
Is it glitched on that screen
You're gonna break my PC you're gonna break the game you goober
Break my
You say to watch me play subnautica. I'm gonna see if the heart rate monitor is gonna work for that
We'd message try parrying no
I'll give him a big me wallet is there something up ahead I
Heard it's scary
I don't know if I'm gonna I don't know how to finish it or anything like that
Like I don't know enough about the game about subnautica, but we'll find out we'll find out
Where's the sunflower are they gonna pop up from the ground I
Don't see him I'm getting suspicious. Oh, he's up ahead. I see him. I see him. He's up ahead
Yes madness approach behold madness
How many deaths so far zero yeah, obviously you think I would die in this game what you're talking about
Literally just killed the sunflower
Why did I get included when they get spotted
No, that's what you in it must be a wee or something. Oh
My god
killer
It teleport away
That's so creepy
Oh
There's two oh my god, I must help my reeflings I need to help I need to help oh my god
I need to help fuck you. Oh my god. Why are you locking on to the wrong one?
Shit shit. I
Thought I was helping. I made everything like ten times worse. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I made it ten times worse
I thought I was helping
Wait, what was last?
Stake of Marica did we walk past one of these?
Did we walk past one of them? I don't know the stake of Marica sure if I can load me now
It's not a good for me. Oh
I'm gonna stash power. What about cheeks in front of me? Oh
No, no one's here. Oh god, I never even spotted this. Okay, we're right like at the bomb bit here
I
Am helping everyone dies
classics run
These are the last two in this area
You can only damage them if you parry them first the way you're meant to play the section is sneaking through the tall grass
Like a silk in
Why give me big sword to not swing
Why ya?
Then you to go back to the other I think I might need to go back to the other great site. Oh
Oh, no, we filmed that me
Okay, let's see my
Another reflin and then an evil reflin
I'll put that
Never
There be the last two
Well, yeah, are these susceptible to rot me me I something like that. I hear you
Just
And then I don't think we have an evil reflin here, I don't think it won't let me
Stealth or fate oh
Fates so I can get past
And I'll come in and I go watch out
And that's my job done. Oh evil refling who's not being evil
Okay, and then
Wait, should I put that jump talisman on enhanced attack with 200 weapons boosts
Holy
I could do that jump one
Because all I do is go wha bam
So I feel like it'd be really why is your sword longer than mine
You guys always have bigger swords in
Okay, I think we're going in guns ablaze in maybe
so you guys need to
Go fight and then dodge and then attack and
Or else you won't be able to hurt them at all. So make sure you parry them
Surely this will go well
Okay, we've been spotted. That's okay. Oh
One of them is like behind there we must dodge
Oh my gosh, I
Can't
My gosh
Leave it to the reef flings
They don't give up
They do not care these we do not care music, please
Sword envy minds me
Oh
Where we're going I'm a fellow roll out recently. Yes, sir. No, it's safe to go through this madness infested area
I
Touch it. No, what what happens after I touch it
I'm just falling. There's a sac-a-dew fairing fragment we missed in this area
Do you need them all there I put that animal of his misery
And it's got madness and that's not it should be free
What the other reason go people sauce is he disconnected
I'm helping
It helps you hit harder and take better hits. Oh, maybe I should go for a little bit
Did you know scatoos just the old English spelling of shadow?
scato
I can lead the way there. Oh, is this you in game?
Hold on read I think red roof one is this you in game. Oh, right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
One-second enemy reflin. We're just going to get a
Scadoo
We're gonna get a scadoo real quick, okay
The wooshie finger hold we need to watch constant and I've not seen two or three apparently is the third one
I want to grab it. Oh
It's a notification thing. Oops. That's supposed to trip you up with the sunflowers
Do you like kung fu panda because he's chubby?
I'm not gonna shag a fucking panda. What no, I don't
Do you mean like the character pole? I
Just I just think it's a good character
Wait, I'm 15 minutes behind now in game in stream
God we really missed that this is a trek and I have we'll come back radar refling. I promise. Are you behind me?
Is there a radar reflin active I
Feel like that you get teleported the further we go from here. What was that?
Monka
Mmm
Climbing up the hill, okay got a few things to be up
Okay, okay, okay
You madness some madness some badness combination
I
Guess I'll say to everyone refresh just in case you're streaming will be me
being a stinky boo winky
Little lay behind
Whoa, why is it you're your weapons are so much color than mine?
my just
My did the reasons have killer stuff than me
Oh, this is it. Okay. Okay. Oh, there's the enemy
We did it. We did okay next time. I need to call in the refunds
I will remember to put my defense and attack up because I keep forgetting to do it
Your sword is cool for some time that also happens
Cuz Johnny they went out and farmed for them. What do you mean? I'm farming so hard right now
I'm telling the soil. I'm watering the crops. I'm putting a little bit fertilizer down, but not too much
you know that most and
Things that like destroy wheat. Oh a bit of football and
Those things that destroy
Like weeds in that, you know what they actually do they tell the plant to overgrow past its resources
You know how it gets like yellowy and long and stringy
When you put weed killer down, that's because it tells it to
Do it to itself and it grows out of control like that's how weed killers work. It's pretty fast
I
Wonder if you could do it to a human body. I
Suppose that would be too much steroids. They say steroids are really bad for you over time
Like you get an enlarged heart and perish
So I guess that would be the equivalent of on a large enlarged heart in a human
Am I going the right way? Sorry. I'm just rambling
All right, I'm standing
This boss is one of the easier one
We films work in the field when mommy's sipping on tea on the porch
I get to read my books while watching over you
You tend into the chicken and you get the fresh eggs and then we'll have
I'm not made omelet. I can make myself scrambled egg. Have a scrambled egg with like bacon and stuff in it
That's neat, but that's also how cancer work that goes for the sake of growth. Okay. Yeah. No, that's not just no
That's true. That's true. That's definitely true
Wait, how am I getting mad? Oh, I'm getting bitten. Oopsies the rats are winning. I'm not paying attention
Uh, who am I following? User splitting up. No, all right
It seemed to have a consensus of this location
Hmm, hmm studying analizing pointing we're pointing
We're pointing we're pointing. Okay, we're pointing. We're pointing so hard right now
Don't send us back to the farm. No, the farm's a good thing for us. It's not a bad thing. I promise the farm's a good thing for us. Oh
The farm is where we am
Get milk. Well, I milk you
Can you milk me?
No, you don't milk me. What do you do to me? You slain me. You made me slain so hard
at the far
Okay, what's up ahead?
Make a scrambled egg with bacon, please. We'll maybe finish him. Yeah, I'll do like those pick and mix bars
What does that mean halt go no further
I don't
get poses
um
I did one of those like pick your own things like I'll make the scrambled egg and I'll make the bacon in advance and I'll do like
Grilled tomato you can add or pan fried tomato pan fried peppers
There's something I do not like this
Oh, I don't like that. Oh
Yeah, something's got me
Something's got me. I'm getting shagged. Oh, you never freaking warned me
I'm dead. I'm about to get madness incarnated unless unless
Unless
Um, I'm mad. I've got madness. What does it mean? What does it mean?
I got inflicted with it. What happens now?
I've heard these reeflings taking it. I don't know it just joined my manner rude
Ah
Deals damage over time and lowers magic
Okay
No, I mean we're out of the fog so that's the good news, right? Surely
I
The other refunds coming to
It's often
Is it in trouble?
Do you need help? Do you need mommy's help?
No, you're okay
You're just stressing me up because you can we are going in circles. We should head back
What are we actually going in circles? I can't open up my map
Fuck it. I'll actually alone blending
Do you like breakfast burritos like the kind of scrambled egg bacon?
I wish there was some takeaway place that would do that. I would love that kind of stuff
I want to do like home made
I heard you can freeze burritos
Um, because my soup went really well
And I wanted to try and freeze burritos for myself and then like I can just microwave them and then they're ready to go
How did we go the wrong way? I'm so confused
You took a wrong turn at some point. You shouldn't count another of those things
Try g y g if you have one near you, you'll get meant to know
Joe agi Joe agi
I don't think I've heard of this one Joe agi
Starbucks makes good ones. There is no starbucks in Australia
I mean there is
but
There is something about the quality of starbucks when I entered Australia that no one went to it
Like they don't like the coffee because it's low quality and stuff like that
So there's like me starbucks other than in tourist
locations
for familiarity
Guzman and Gomez there are Mexican chains
Oh
I've not tried them
Maybe I should
And before I discover it and I end up
Of that mummy's not losing weight no more. She gaining okay
She gaining it's all gonna matter. Well, I hope it would go in my ass if I was gaining weight, but
Considering I do no exercise
Although my only exercise is literally
Have you up bro anyway?
You just keep your candle blowing antics to yourself. Okay
I'm out of stamina for these fights
Yeah, you just you do just relax me. You just calm down mate
You just calm down. Ooh healing stone. Oh, I'm being healed so much right now
Head pat head pat. Oh, I've keep forgetting to head pat. No wrong one. Sorry. This is the head pat one
pat pat pat pat pat
When you get you an exercise bike
Well, I was gonna do a treadmill stream where it was just pointed at my butt and I was like
I think that's a bit outrageous to be honest
A little bit outrageous
Might be able to get away with it though
If it's like a small part of the stream and the rest is my vtuber model. Oh, no. Is this
Open
I've seen worse on twitch point at your feet and say I was gonna do a feet cam stream
But the problem is I never have my feet on the floor like it's literally against my penini right now
Sorry, I said I said I have it. Can enemy refling come in? You can
Close
I wonder if there's something with this painting. Hmm
Let me talk to this guy. Does he say anything?
I welcome you. Oh uninvited guests
But first I warn as you venture and heed the words of our great master mitra
Approach not the madness least yeasts are come
Come
Say no more. I'm going in
Penini cam stream. Yeah, you wait. I'm not freaking doing a penini
I'll do a blue stream and you can hear my penini if you want
Oh, my dog bulls arrived, I mean we're eating dishes arrived
I were custom made eating dishes arrived wink wink. Oh my god
Leave him alone. Don't do that. That's my reason
Um starbucks is america coffee australian melbourne particular strong selling culture
Dog bull you be yeah, so when I take those pictures, I can also include the dog bulls
Which I think it won't be I mean the eating dishes
Yeah, so you love a good eating dish wink wink
Wait, what what happens?
Am I going great? Oh, I opened this passage right?
They're just bulls for my dogs. Why yes. Oh, look at the pose hitting the pose
I discovered the existence of human sized dog bears
Could I I'm at that
I might be I don't know. I I wouldn't rule it out. I honestly wouldn't rule it out
For me personally, I'm not okay. I'm just having hallucination
The pose and the lean
There's an item across there. Oh, there is an item across. Hold on one second. I'm just getting an item
Um, uh, surging frenzy flame
Shibi has a human sized dog, but it says it's really comfy
Papertae of reeflings. Oh, that's very cute. What the fuck that's so whole that's too wholesome for the implications of why I
Like it. I think it's too wholesome
Um
I can make it across this safely, right? Yeah in both
Why are all the domes
Uh, what?
Why are all the domes ceiling and now I'm both I can go both ways I can fuck you up
And you can fuck me up best both way you get the
The
Well, I don't know what was moaning, but it was me me a promise. Are we go down?
Okay
Mitra's having a moment. Is it okay? Oh, that's Mitra. Hello
Read message hidden path ahead or this one. Oh this one too. Oh, is this a shortcut?
Oh
Oh, yeah, yeah, this is a shortcut. Okay, okay
Uh, where's the other reefling have I lost them?
Well, he's killing something in the distance
him with the pool
That'll be the reeflings morning in November
You already opened the passage. I'm sorry passage open my my apologies
I get very turned around in this game. It's not like anything against Elden ring. I'm just I'm really dumb
Let me grab that golden horn tender
Because yeah, is your golden horn tender? I bet it is. Good boy
November is gonna be awful this year. Oh, no, I'm excited for it
So I need to start planning my doughnathon now to make sure I can still do it
um
And do the project as well. So I'll be very interested to see
Time for a head excuse you
What was that?
Time for a head. Are you serious? Elden ring players got nothing but fucking jokes
Yeah, you're excited for it. Literally. Well, as I said, this manager comes into play. I'm getting a second manager
I'm like, so then what do I have to be stressed about it's going to be non-stop inking for me
Not for you
You understand you could be a well-behaved boy and you're not allowed to ink
Hey
Oh, is this it
Is this it monkaS? I think this is it because I see the steak America
Are you okay? Are you being tortured?
What do you mean? Is he coming for me? Wait, he's not is he
He's not a fighter
Okay, thank you again
Oh
Oops
It's elden ring. Of course it wasn't done. I was like, oh, he's like super easy
I didn't realize how leveled up we were sorry
I have endured more than enough
Oh, is it gonna pillow his head?
Oh
Nope, that was not actually
You could have actually just put your hand in between them
Ah
Uh
Oh
I already have a plan
My god, what the fuck
We're supposed to kill this
My madness is already going on what I do I'm just hitting I'm just hitting
I'm tippin I'm tapping it. Thank you sadist refling. Okay very accurate name though for that real
Okay, I need to watch my stamina bar because it goes down way faster. I assume if he hits me I'm like
Let's find out
Mmm, maybe this fight is one of those ones that are easier when we're together
Oh, he's got scarlet rotissie. What does that do?
Why did that kill me but not you
Why did that kill me but not you guys
Am I gonna mental
Uh
Wait, can I not summon you here?
Obliet leave me alone you weirdo. Oh my god. Leave me alone. Oh my god. Stop. I don't have a refill with me. Stop. Leave me alone
I don't have a refill with me. Leave me alone
I need an adult. I need a refund
I need a little squiddle like in milk
Oh my god, they're attacking me. Oh, wait, where'd that go?
Oh my god, can you guys like can you guys come here to the the yellow body? That'd be great
Can there's a grace closer to the boss room?
Mithra's hall
The hall
I add this one
I
Second floor library. I don't have that. I'll have I have library not second floor library
Didn't you activate the grace lights of the boss? I think I got oh, I missed it
Um, so what one did I go on library and then
You missed a bomb
I leave the rest of the reason. Thank you for helping
Go right. Okay library first and then come library and then
Take me refilling. Take me
I think you're someone who's tickles possibly I might have been I'll do this one
Okay, here we go
Uh, I'm gonna eat one second. I'm gonna do that
Mm-hmm hydration and e.m
I want someone in that needle reclin just because we're so close
You just have to be so close to the boss
Oh no, I won't pop up
Hmm
Mithra doesn't deserve to get jumped why
Oh
A few more
I'm hungry today. I think because I've been sleeping so much
My one meal a day
Oh
You're sorry all my
I didn't know like if you if you're doing all my diet for real, which is short for one meal a day
Isn't that not
Um, like you have a two hour window to eat everything
Where we going across this way?
Okay, I was heading the right way. I thought I was heading the right way. I just got scared right at the end. Okay
I'm a scaredy baby
and
I think you're like get given a you can have as much water as you want
But you're not like any anything calorie or sugary wise or else it doesn't like kick your body into
Doing the objective
Intermittent fasting. Yeah, I've basically been doing it by accident
Um
I'm not gonna come down this way
Whoa, what is this guy?
Oh
Whoa, okay good stagger god damn who's about to kill us knock it off
My oh i'm at stamina. Thank you. Sorry. I was at a stamina. I was like my sword doesn't swing swinging
Are you getting all the calories and nutrition I need uh
something
Okay
I just don't like I'll have one meal and I'm like, okay, I'm done. Okay. This is what I missed. I thought this was the same grace
Okay, I I did it. Oopsie poopsie whoopsie and thought it was the same grace. It was not okay
Right. He's skinny melinky long legs and then phase two fucking run
Oh
I feel so bad. I don't know his lore seems a bit sad to be honest. I don't think he wants to be
I don't think he wants to attack us
I don't think he wants to transform
Okay
Wait, I'm skipping it so
I don't understand why I got Kablamo though
Um, okay keep my keep my stamina
Um
Whoa
Okay, we're gonna do that big attack. Oh no
Oh, we got a critical
Oh, we're oh, we're having him
We're having his little
Flame. Oh, I'm getting mad
Ness. I'm getting madness. Sorry. I'm not actually getting mad. I'm really enjoying myself
I don't get mad at games like that. Okay. I need to oh, right. I need to start being a bit less careless
Okay
You did it. Oh my god, you enrolled him remembrance of the lord of frenzy flame
Oh
Gee motherfucking gee beat him up. Please don't disappear
If you love me you won't disappear
It doesn't have to be this way. I guess we're heading to romania
No, you didn't say that romania romania. No the country
Romina
Okay
Oh, I can level up my defense twice and my attack
Once, okay. I'm
Not romania
Okay, we're good
The saint the big what about brazil?
Oh my god, my poor brazillian reef lens on twitter
Do you guys see what happened with that?
Uh home of
Oh
Say that word then bring you know loud say that would you?
Shadow keep first floor shadow keep first flower
Hmm. I don't know where the shadow keep this way. Yes. It's this one right here shadow keep black gate shadow keep first shadow keep first
shadow keep
Shadow keep first floor first
Shadow keep first that's the storehouse
Shadow keep first school main gate
First floor
Hello
Get the map in the area first the map is found elsewhere. I thought you were going to sleep reefland
Sorry is the storehouse the map isn't so the map is there isn't here
I don't even know where I am on the hood. I already forgot
What's the brazillian drama uh brazil's twitter has been banned. It's like any brazillian
Dreamer and stuff are getting it
You need to go to mirth runes
Uh
And there's a cave and mirth runes. I don't know where that is
Of course, I know where mirth runes are
Oh there I am
Mm-hmm, but where's mirth runes
Brazilians
It's been probably my life like
I don't know what the fuck
mirth runes
right
You better show yourself
I'm gonna squirt right now
mirth
Press Y
Oh that was really quick what the how did you do that?
How did you know
There's oh my tears
Then he talked to him he's like in such a creepy location
Hello
Oh, well, it's fucking excuse me then
Summon, okay, we fling sure the way to the map
We got any oh, I've just sat on you. Sorry
Sorry, wasn't my intention
a lot of clothes
If you're dragging your man
Nobody wants to be a piece of cheese
Oh, oh wait. No
dumbass
Not that
Sorry
It looks like you're saying sorry to me. Sorry, mommy. I don't need hunter you're new
Yeah, he's or a mat
He can you can drill with him with an emote. Mm using that me the best win a mot
How much time do we have seven hours we might finish today or really
Are you guys carrying me that hard? Thank you. I love you
But no, you're beautiful
Thank you for carrying me through the game because otherwise this game would be inaccessible to me and I'm really thankful
I know I keep saying thank you
But I mean it this game genuinely wouldn't be accessible to me if I didn't have you carrying me through it
And I'm really appreciative and I understand especially if you're really into the souls games that this is basically
A complete insult to the developer
Development team
But the truth of the matter is I couldn't play this game without you and it makes me happy that I get to experience it
and give off and
Muck about and
Cheer for you
Whilst you kill all the enemies for me because I don't know how to do it and I would never do it
And I'm like you need that. I love you and I thank you and I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I keep saying thank you
I mean it
The evil wormies look at them
You know
That I said it there. You're stuck with me. You're stuck with watching a bad gamer at work
Ooh
Oh, no, she's headless. She's a Dullahan
Dullahan for gen 2 confirmed
Elden ring wormy for gen 2 confirmed
Oh
I
Think those people also perished for the item without realizing those look creepy
I miss
Oh, wait, I'm out. I'm out. I'm out. Give me over here. Oh, something's hitting me with madness
Hold on. Let's get out of here. Let's go here
I'm getting charred by magna
A Dullahan chicken nugget. Could you imagine? No, how would you even?
I mean, it'd probably be the ultimate chicken nugget like oh, she doesn't have a head on her neck. Okay
Oh, no, I'm taking poison damage and oh can we go around?
Okay, I'm running I'm running
Did you get it didn't you know that was your reefing Vader?
Well, that did the madness
Surely the reefing invader wouldn't do such a thing to me. Not sure why I spoke
A quote would be as a feature me to be able to look at it, but if it doesn't like it
Hmm. I remember people being like, oh
Oh
The game shouldn't be the game should be played this way not this way and it's like so then why did they put spirit ashes in bro?
And they're like, no
No, my spirit ashes my spirit mimic. No, I wonder if I got a spirit mimic
If it would just do like 10 times better and then me like actually, I don't know. They're good stuff
Probably
You didn't beat the game
Doll hands and dolls are the least messed up chicken
Okay, and what do you feel about the kind of chicken nugget where you can take away the attachments for no particular reason at all
You could in theory take away the attachments of this chicken nugget and leave her bed in her bed as she wiggles about
How do we feel about that? Do we feel it is morally terrible or
What's the uh, how do we feel about that particular?
Asking for a friend
I feel intrigued. Okay
So
Dung ear and the dragon priestess are the only ashes that would take over me. Wait, you can summon in dung ear
If you kill him
Don't believe the nugget. I'm not sure how I feel about this. I wonder how you feel about it
I
Have a douser and sweet and sour sauce and take a bite. Oh, I mean, I guess if she
Oh, I am shine
neutralize and
There are so many words that I can never say wait, why are you thinking in? Oh, are we in trouble?
Is your footwork you're leaking again, but I was looking a second ago. How do you know?
Red flesh mushroom. Show me that mushroom tip
No, you have to jog him and give him body to creepy
Oh
It's one of them guys
How do you even find a tree to craft into an arrow that big?
Do you knock it off you
You stinker tin you're hurting my reflins
Is he aiming for me? No
The arrow was not even pointing there I get that they can't like accurately do the arrow
It was not there. Hold on to me
Get my endurance back second
Yeah, don't hurt my refunds mine
Golem's great arrow
Oh my gosh. Oh, yeah, just smithingstone as well
Did it make it easier to do smithingstone? Please don't die reflins. I really need you right now
Can we pretend like arrow flames in the night sky like shooting stars?
I could you really use all the strength now
I
The aim is super. Oh, we didn't get him. Sorry. I wasn't paying attention. Sorry
Sorry, I didn't really want to kill him. Jeez how much HP does this one have?
It excuse me most like that he got him. Whoa. No, they still got like 10%
Oh my gosh, why did he have so much?
A nice cheeky bit of HP
There's a lot of smithingstones in the DLC. They finally give like a farming option
I think they should yeah. Oh, hold on. Hold on. I need to get comfy in my chair
I need to make sure my foot is in a very specific location
It makes for the gaming experience very enjoyable
He
But I would never do anything like that. I don't know what you're thinking right now, but I've never
Where am I going?
You went a little bit
That's my secret I age every stream that wouldn't actually be entirely inaccurate
The rumble no my controller doesn't have a rumble
I take off the vibration on the controller because oh my gosh, right finally we can see what's in this part of the map
Okay, are we unlocked the whole map?
No, we didn't I I call BS. We have not unlocked the whole map
I call be it. I don't believe it for a second
I don't believe that this is the end of the the map for a second. Why are we crouching?
Yeah, we can be scared. Why are we crouching? Where are we going?
I've got blood on my butt. Can you see it?
Do you not trust them?
I do with my life. That's why I'm here because I trust you
Have you seen the Wiimo? What's that buzzin fan the Wiimo?
Okay, we're at a castle. It's pretty
We
Did you know you can buy all churches in Scotland for really cheap if you wanted to get a house in Scotland?
You can buy a church
Because churches are no longer really popular
They're crying but they're angry enough to attack us
Oh brother
This guy stinks
Ah
I saw it
Naughty go back to the shadow realm
You'll be safe there. Oh, no, that's a human. Sorry. Sorry. I didn't I didn't you weren't attacking me. I didn't mean to hurt you. I'm sorry
Jesus things good at dodging
I feel bad when I kill something that doesn't mean me any harm
I'm just so sorry
It was not my intention
I just have really bad aim
Okay
Wait, the nugget's gonna get a Nintendo remote. No
The leading to a talisman that fits my build. Oh, yeah 200 heavy. Mm-hmm. I'm totally not gonna do magic next time
Dear main that refling belongs to me not you
No, I can't break his stance. Thank you refling
Main whoa, you scared me
Okay talisman in here. Hello talisman. How's your wife and kids?
Oh, wait, I can double step. Do you mind I can double stack
Oh, you can double stack talismans. Who coded that in
Who thought about that? I can't believe it. They thought about stacking talisman abuse
Man game devs ruin all the fun
If I have two talisman, let me put on my two talisman. It doesn't matter where I put them on or what part of my body
Let me put them on
Now this game's targeted against me. How did you even have the first one? I refling gifted it to me
Oh
I
I was I may have been given like everything you see here
And uh, I may have sped around my stats even though I haven't done any of anything to earn it
Can I is this mine? Have I claimed this one before?
Is the enemy refling too close or am I going crazy? Did I claim this one?
It won't let me claim it. I think you need to go further away or is it already claimed? I don't know. I don't know
Wait, those are like new guys. We've not gone against those hold on. Let me claim this
Ah, it's bugged out, right? Okay
I'm a fart on it
Wow, they're so kind. Wait, why are you heartbroken? I get carried thinking
I'm to go up
You already got it. I don't remember those red guys
Oh
My god, they're terrifying. Hold on. Let me help. I'm helping. I'm helping kind of
Oh, I don't know like the noise they make
I'll get you keel
I'm teabagging it. It's mine
Mmm, let's just be embraced by the warmth of the gemstone
Heels delicious not nutrition
Okay, is everyone healed up? No, not yet. We're still healing almost there almost there so close
Oh, no, we'll never get the satisfaction of your health bar being filled
They're recolored by his lore so you can't hate
I mean they did add to the other guys the stone guy. Oh my gosh, there's so many of them
The master skywalker, what are we going to do? There's too many of them
Be yours
Execute order
Anyway, that's my recreation of what happened in star wars. I've just saved you like so much time. Is that one real?
I knew that was real
I'm looking at them all sauce
Okay age the heal
Oh, oh my god, am I gonna look is it better than what I've got?
Yes, or no
No, that one another one. There should be something new
Hold on. I'm getting shocked. Oh, I said no more bird girl for gen three. Fuck you
No
No, there's no talisman double stacking. I promise sir. Oh, no, but I mean you can go ahead and uh inspect away
Please be my guest
Thank you anon
I've always wanted to write a rule play like that because I feel like it's so silly
But it's like my perfect kind of silliness
Like, oh no, what do you mean? You have to do a cavity search
And then it's like okay after like 20 seconds it's like, okay, that's it done
We're satisfied with our results and I'm just like no, no, no, no, no you need to check do two fingers this
I was like, no, no, you need to make sure you're doing your job properly
Whoa, those things are getting me. Ow
I'm not gonna eat out
Okay, I think we're at a range
The rubber gob snap and everything oh no reflin inspector
Oh, I missed
These look like
Uh, what is it called?
Whoa
Holy
I'm just trying to enjoy the environment. Okay. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I can't do anything. Holy holy moly
What was that ash of war? I couldn't even read it. I was too busy getting killed by a shrimp
Oh my god, a shrimp vtuber. What a crazy concept
I wonder if I'm going to love a shrimp vtuber in the future
Oh
He's gonna cause me blood loss
Oh, okay
I can't reach him
Oh, okay. He'll time he'll time
Everyone group together more here shrimp. Oh posture check. How do you
Fuck you hydration checks you more like roaches with lots of human hand
Is she fucking with us or leaking gen two I've leaked so much of gen two
I've told you that we're not having certain
characters
and we are and
I've told you that we're not having this and we are and I've told you we're definitely having this but we aren't
Uh, it's just kind of fun now just to say anything
Because when it does get revealed, I get to go remember that time I said this. Do you remember that time I said this?
Oh, and do you remember that time I made a passive comment about this?
surprise
Basically is how it's gonna go
I have touched the grace
Last grace discovered she's playing with us
Gen two drops in the sixth line. Yeah, you fucking wish. No, that's I draw the line at slim girls
Sorry, I actually do and as much as I like to meme. I draw the fucking line at slim girls
Here here's the most versatile
Concept, uh, what can she do nothing versatile because of each of her models cost money. Ah, okay. Got it
Like no, no, it's not happening. There's no happening
Reach out reach out and touch grace
What song is that reach out and touch face
Is that american? Is that green day reach out?
The president
Reach over models cost money. Unfortunately. I'm terrible
Oh
Didn't he like that?
Oh, oh, I'm not sure about that. I'm not sure about that. Um
I'm not sure about this one
Did sin finish her playthrough of the dlc? Oh my god, what does it mean?
Oh, I don't oh, this is very
In sick to say and oh my gosh
Okay, they're weak. That's what I'm happy to see
I'm just glad they're weak because that is horrifying
I'm glad. I'm glad. Okay now one more
One more
Oh, yeah, they're like super weak. They can not take a whack
I'm happy with that. Please don't ever get back up. Thank you
Oh, I got in flask returned for that
He don't like this just an average day in Australia. Oh, no, it's the roly-poly sheep that hurt me. No, you're not taking my hp
Vtuber models are government mandated. Whoa, he's having a rough time. He did not like blocking on you
Okay, we both gone
Uh, I don't they're just shooting from the rocks. I just want to run past
I don't recall if sin got here. Mm
Oh
Oh, you return to your world. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, Piggy stop it. You didn't have to die
Whoa, there's like we guys in here
Oh
No, it's these horrible freaking blood guys. Oh, and they cause freaking poison
Hold on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Uh, how'd I get another leaflin in we're doing a leaflin. Oh, he'll sorry he'll
Uh
The bacon feels
Feel like she jumped back to her level one run possibly she did all bosses level one. Was that where they're going?
Oh, there's a new place. Okay. Oh, I can't
How does that not hurt me? Oh, it's put me to sleep
Uh leaflin. What are you into?
What are you into leaflin?
Oh, no, what are you into? Are you uh, are you into one of them roleplays? Fiona?
Go, okay, I'll go in I'll go in I'll go in
A little sleepy roleplay
I can't go in with it with you guys here. I get I get shy. I can't pee with you looking at me
Okay, and I can't open doors with you looking at me. Okay. You need to you gotta go
You gotta go
You can't because Lou phantom's
Thank you. Thank you for your service for taking me halfway across the map. What you're honestly does
Okay, let me open this
It's creaky door sound effect or mp3. Oh leaflin's already on the other side
Uh, here we go. Oh
really and
Oh really and all
And then we've got taco is anyone new russian you know how to be short
Say fish. How do you change your looks so quickly?
Uh
I'm looking at who's not is it tacum my nobule? I think it may be
Hold on
Rush
You're beautiful
And your pressure what you're gonna do about it, huh?
Russian you've not played in a book. I guess it's Russian. Did you just go down that left before I'm ready?
Reflin I need that
Better send it back up when you're finished reflin. Yeah that mm-hmm
Uh-huh. That's right. Go into the corner and think about what you've done
Go into the corner
Uh-huh guess you're gonna get spanked
You get spanked go into the corner. You're getting spanked
Like oh, no that one's not that one this one. You're getting this one. You're getting spanked
Don't use the left without mummy's permission. You could have got hurt
I was worried about you. I do this because I love you. I do this because I love you
I do it because I love
You're beautiful isn't struggling to logis and
I don't think the game wants to logis and
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Yeah, that's right. You're sorry. Oh, oh your weapon. I don't think I can load the other refunds
My beloved are you ready?
Uh
Uh, I guess we need to read oh my game just broke
My game just broke as soon as you came in
I couldn't handle you
You couldn't handle you. Okay. Let's try that again. Let's try that again
I wonder if it's going to be a pixel now because it's on lower. It's like
a
Band for reflin to be as could you imagine? I better not be steams fucking update day either
I'm not tolerating it. No in my stream snake days. I'm not tall. I tolerate this
Don't be a stinky doodoo head
You're stinky
Uh
Bear you crash
Bandicam I did not read that name at all
At the end of the previous session might not have been selected
Please use either of these options if you want to end your play session. Uh, excuse me. It was your game that broke on me
Uh
Is it gonna load
Oh my messes
It says I'm in the scorpion river catacombs. Did I remember? Well, why? Oh, there you go. You can see me
Okay, I think I go down. No
Oh my god
Whoa, I almost broke again
I assume there's uh grave site ahead uh save site
Oh, it spec is your pc a pc mlg pro southern wise item. I just about broke there again. I don't know if you saw that
Okay, now I call you in. Okay. I'm taking the names off the list unless I can find
The dish
Hold on
I can't
Oh, no, don't sit down. Well, actually, you know what? Uh, I guess we'll level up
Um, what did I need was it intelligence like a living or something?
One level off is like a cabillion rune
intelligence
Eleven
Intelligence eleven face. Okay, hold on. Wait, let me pop all of my wee things because I have tons of my insentors
Where is it?
This a reflin gave me 16 how much is that?
A million I have a million so
Oh
Rock in the low IQ build. I mean, it's very realistic
Okay, uh
intelligence
And then face was it?
Eleven intelligence eleven face. Okay. We're a couple but that'll do don't keep up
And then did I have any other bigger ones we can drop you more
Uh
See this is what I'm like. Oh, is he gonna start hating on uh, I don't like development team
Why am I struggling to find that I just found that a moment ago
Oh, I can't even tell the difference between the inventory, honestly this one
Smash
That's a hundred. Okay. I actually don't have enough right. Okay. Uh, who
Is the other reef one here? No, stop sending on the reef
Hacks yeah uber hacks or
I'm just so mlg right. Okay. You were in last time and who was with you
It was russian. Are you here?
Russian
Russian no, you're not here. I can't see you
I've an enemy reefland picked out evil dragon
Evil evil dragon so evil
You're a bad we need spanking
Uh, well you're new so we kind of get in real wait. Uh, what a name barf drinker
As in the reeflands barf are you named after reeflands?
So this is apparently
Let's get to it. This is apparently
Low graphics, but am I going crazy insane? It doesn't even look that low
Relative of the loads them dung eater. I just dropped items similar to save no hacks required
I don't know you could do it that way
One more once the reefland comes in point forward pointing. Oh no, it lagged out. You didn't come in
Paladin looser, you know
Maybe your barf drinkers means
Oh my god, are you fingering my butt? Thank you
Oh my god, thank you so much so that feels please. No, hold the pause hold the bow. Please hold it
I need I need I need fill access
Full access. Hi
Oh, that was really loud
Take the weapon out. Are we ready? Are we ready?
Finally someone that enjoys cleaning out the fiendish fecal feast right now. We're not alliterating that
Right. What's the store? Oh, I saw him drop down right cannon
Behold cannon
Two shot
Oh, he's dropped me something. Sorry reefland. You're probably sweating watching me run off. Oh, no, you picked it up. I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry. You would have been like damn this bitch. Fuck. I never noticed this shit. I put them
I'm sorry. Oh, I got lords room. Mm-hmm heroes room. Mm-hmm
He run of the unsung here's run
Newman's run
No, man, no, man, no, man. He's a place. You're a
Now um, oh
Is this better than what I have?
No, everything's rubbish or
That really I did not have the best armor set in the game. I refuse
Okay, what's going on here? Oh, I am
Behold Newman's room. No, man. No, man. No, man. No, man
Someone accused me of not knowing them another day and she took that personally. Isn't that like a massive meme song?
I remember the guy singing in his room to it. My
Oh, I have the debt the the plague on me death plague on me
Is it
Uh, I might need to calm down on the the death butthole symbol on my screen
I literally oh my god, let's count the see this is what you guys would be doing
If you got a 3d print of my butthole, you'd be counting the motherfucking wrinkles on that shirt. I know you would
It's death play. Okay, my apologies
I'm being death played so hard right now
I know wasn't there a company that you could get your chocolate
You could get chocolate made of your
Is that real? I'll do that for the donathon. Don't think I'm not mental enough not to I will literally do that for the donathon right now
Is that a thing? How would I do that?
It's real stop
Stop is it eat her what what are the steps read the steps out right now read the steps out right now
I need to eat mommy's chocolate store. I think you may be able to what are the steps infinite money glitch. No, no, no just for the donathon
Oh
I wondered what got you oh my goodness. Oh that scared me
Okay, we're okay. We're okay. Let's see
She'd be out of hell of a time here
Imagine if you don't have someone here on you
Right. Okay. I think he's gone for it. Oh
Oh, did you are we are we supposed to be will go in that little knob?
Oh, oh, it's a ladder. Sorry
Uh, I could have sworn. Yeah, there was like some internet meme and it was like
Oh, um
You can like get this company to make
Chocolates of your ring. Wait, why am I going? Why am I dying?
Why am I dead?
What was getting me the darkness?
I don't want to go any further in case my butthole gets done
I don't know what was getting me something was getting me anywhere the eyes the eyes of
Oh
They are frogs that act as medusa
Rejuvenating bulbuses
Alleviates build up
Okay
Thank you for your offering. I like the poses. They entertain me quite well
Okay, so medusa statues. Okay. Okay medusa medusa medusa
Oh
What does it mean?
Oh, they just keep going back and forth
I mean, this is gonna be an audio warning
Yeah, that was that. Oh, you mean those eyes right there. You mean these ones right here. Yeah
Did we kill the statue to kill it?
Find out in the next one again. Whoa. Why? That was some rage. You're not supposed to jump here
Big boy big boy
I deserved that
I deserved that hold on if he's looking at okay, there we go. Oh reefland almost got you there
Danger danger when I started swinging the sword. I don't know who's gonna get hit. Okay
Very unnoticed we need to see them truly
I don't uh, I hate the alt way
Push it under. Oh, I hear them
Oh, I can't reach that. There's like a wizard up there
You're a wizard diary that we've fun. Okay. It's getting his ass kicked
I believe I'm alone. He works very hard for me. Okay
Oh, there's a re-stair case here if you guys want to get on that
Healing stone. Oh something's getting me. I don't know what's getting me. Oh
Down question mark
Okay, we need to wait for that other reefland to get back here
There's a wall here that can fall through and it's an instacle reef laying. Are you okay?
The others they're coming
Oh
Wait, did he die
Can I not beat the fuck out of this stupid statue and kill these fucking things?
Oh, right. Okay. Do we have to go on?
We must go on without the reef link. Did he die or am I going mental and he didn't die
Wait, no, he's killing stuff. He's coming. Am I to follow you?
Am I to follow the enemy reefland?
I'm following you. What was this? I'm supposed to follow or am I being really dumb?
Well, he says go down so I'm going down. Oh, sorry. Sorry. I didn't mean that. Sorry
I'm a bit heavier on my feet than I originally expected. Sorry
The eyes are so creepy bug eyes
That's an edible ear seems like they would use a plastic as far this way
I can hear those ears add those eyes with my ears
Be a weebam
Okay, no more leave him alone
Ow, I never saw him
Yeah, two of us can swing our freaking big swords around
Another yin
How do you know where you're going?
This all looks the same
Wait, so then where's the other reef link?
Huh, we're still reefing list. Hold on. I need my weeb. Is he chilling?
How have we lost you so badly? Reef link? Are you here?
Reef them, baby. I've lost my child
I lost my son. I miss my son
Uh
Oh, isn't I am here? Hello
Oh, the eyes are here. A cookbook. I don't I've never used a cookbook once in the game
Where are you reef link and you're still alive
Need the leashes now. I honestly do
Where is the
Mother of three loses to her kids and the death blade scorpion catacombs honestly. I got lost. I know
We can't find you darling
We've cleared the way where did you go exactly? Did you go down here?
No, wait, you're at the boss. Okay. I don't know how you did that, but we'll come to the boss. We'll come to you
We'll come to you that's hilarious. I don't know how you did that, but that's honestly hilarious
Oh, there you are. What? How did you do that? We were here waiting for you
Okay, now where's my other reflin bruh
Please tell me my other reflin's there. No way. We have lost the other reflin. Are you trolling?
Reef Lin other reflin, are you there?
Please be there
He's not kept maybe this tried to kill the eyes
Other reflin. Do you know where to go?
No, no, this was the one that was at the boss this one right here
But he's not at the boss anymore. He's with us
I never have lost the one that was started exploring with us
This is worse than a mother in a supermarket. I don't know how we've managed that
This is impossible. Are you are you there? He's not there. Oh, I'm gonna die. Sorry. I'm gonna die because I'm an idiot
Please report to the counter your mother is worried
There you are. Oh my god, it took us long enough to come together. Okay. I'm ready
I'm ready. Okay. Let's go. We did it. We're safe
Mummy has all her
Did you I think you just dropped me an item
Uh one moment. Yeah, you just dropped me an item. I saw it in the corner. See you just needed an instant
Check with the cat. Come secure one second. Okay, there we go. I got it
You can't see it because I'm covering it up this refling gifted me one bar of soap in game
Aren't you the one that wants me a pheromone max all the time? Hmm
I'll hear oh mommy. Mommy. I want to taste that after three days of not washing. Oh, mommy, please
Mommy, please. Oh, oh, mommy. I want to smell your bio
No, that's all I hear then you give me soap in game. No, I'm on to you
Oh, oh, but mommy, please. I want to taste of your your cuttlefish broth after five days of not washing mommy, please
No, you're in trouble. You're actually it
Okay, you can redeem yourself if you kill this boss in one
Oh
Is it free hits on me?
Oh don't mind if I do
I think that was friendly
On no way
So we can break his poise at least
Yeah, he gets staggered rather easily and compares
What these looks like disco. Oh, sorry. I just broke them out of that. I think that was a crit there
May just bolt that one off a little bit. Sorry
I'm out of stamina
Whoa
Oh
We did it. Oh my god take that. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. That's right
If you love me, you won't leave
If you love me, you won't disappear
Shambles. I'm in shambles. Truly
I'm in shambles. Please. Please come back
It's so dark inside me
The lost kids at the supermarket. I mean, they honestly did pretty damn good at today. Oh, it's a face
Is that alive?
kind of feels
Rather alive with the blood coming out of it. That must be Godwin
more like
Melted ha ha because he melted
They hate moment. Return to entrance
Where do we go now?
We're steamrolling all the way. Go to Ravarine North
Yes, please return to the entrance touch
It's Godwin the gold now the prince of death
I
Love
Ravirino Ravirino
Ravini
Me. Hi. Me. Hi. Me. Hi. Me. Hi
Me joy. Me joy. Me joy. Me joy. Me plan
It's time
Time to be a gate. Time to be a gate
I've got evil evil chicken
Chicken you're so evil. What makes you so evil?
Did you watch your
Your daddy chicken get taken away because he wasn't allowed to meet with mommy chicken
Or did you discover what happens to boy chickens at farms and that made you an evil chicken?
You don't want to know what happens to boy chickens at a farm
He
They end up dog food
Sorry, you've not gave me a humble merchant. You're new
Humble merchant
And then sorry
Set it are written. Oh, you're a very recent story. Oh, that was not I shouldn't have done you
But I'll clap you again. Why not?
What is this build my
Miyazaki did not put feet nailed and ring for this that is hilarious
Just for that common off the pop that is hilarious. Oh my god. I look so naked
What oh, okay
Oh, oh, thank you
Oh, what you only came
You only came to drop me runes
Oh my god
A base in red pills recently what? Oh my gosh
Uh, I thought they got milk
Wait only
We're in
Now
Ravine north
But anyone he wants to join
Uh
I'm like super sleepy too
Wow
Broken ring again. Damn. Don't he kick you though?
So I can like see what level I'm with this
Is
This is called the simp bill
Everything is good for five euros
I don't refunds let me play the game because without the refunds
I wouldn't be able to play this game would be kind of blocked off from me in all honesty
So I get loads of help
I have to go now. Have a good night rest well sleepyhead and rest well to anyone who needs to go get some
Uh stuff and things
um
To do unable to summon
Oh no, are we having a glitch?
Mass think 16 18. Thank you for the 50 gifted membership. What the heck? You didn't have to do that. Thank you
Congrats to those. Oh, I've never checked if I have a new emoteslot. Hold on. We can do that live
I might have a new emoteslot
I did not expect all those freaking gifted memberships at the end of my my fake asmr stream
That was insane honestly
What does it say?
Emojis obviously it's not going to register that holy crap. It asks for a lot of freaking gifted memberships. Are you serious?
That's a big number
Matt, what the did you mean? Do you need a refund? That's twice you put that through
Did you mean that was that a mistake?
Oh
Was that a mistake?
Thank you. No, that's correct. What the fuck. Thank you for a hundred gifted memberships
What?
Congrats to everyone who caught them with your face
Maths is good at maths. Obviously. Yeah, you better have all your bills repaid
You're got no debt to your name. You've been treating yourself with takeaway and steak
You've been looking after yourself. Thank you. Oh my gosh
Gigas had a refund. I nailed to the math
Congrats everyone get in a membership as well. Oh my god
Maths, what the fuck put the card away? Put it down put it put it down put it down. No more
Thank you. No more
Thank you so much math for the 150 gifted memberships put the card down. No more. I'm sure I'm sure I'm I'm satisfied
I'm done. I'm happy. Okay. No more
No more. We're good. Oh, you've broken my controller apparently
I don't know how that happened
Oh, you got you on your knees for me
Oh
Wow, bounty hunter. It does not like you
Math, thank you. My birthday was a few days ago. Can I get switch? Happy birthday, guru. Hit lurking in the doorbell
Okay, happy birthday, Bob. Thank you for the tip
Maths decided to rapid-fire gifted subs. Holy moly
Holy moly
Uh, I think it's broken. I don't know why it only shows bounty hunter. Is anyone else trying to stream snipe here?
Or are we stuck at the riverine?
The simple fact is I can't contribute directly to the donor funds. I'm giving an early birthday gift. Oh, well
That's certainly fucking counts as a gift. I assure you I've been gifted enough you can
You can no more gifts because uh, that's that's that's good
That's good. That's that's enough slices
That's enough slices. I don't I think this is broken. It only shows bounty hunter. Oh, it's it. I was trying now
150 gifts is the membership only literally only
Thank you, math. That was very kind. The other really things we'll have to carry you through the donor song
I assure you, uh, the goal of 69 dollars for generation to production
Begins, uh, I believe it's obtainable controversial. I believe it's holy
Mummy's chat is filled with people coming members
They didn't got enough emotes slots or three literally should we give her better fashion? No, no, don't give me the drip
I like my wee armoury
Um
Was it it's a bounty hunter did man should I don't have?
I
Still processing all the gifted memberships. Look, can you see it as well? You see it the way it displays for me
It's like process. It's like having to process who is assigning to
It's still going. It's still processing
Okay, it's what yeah, I was gonna say I would respect your request not continue. Thank you. Yes, please make sure you're spoiling yourself
I assure you you've spoiled me and other reeflings more than enough because everyone gets the wee emotes now
Thank you. That was very kind
Um
Yeah, I think I'm gonna go out on a limb and say yeah once that registers. We're probably got another emotes slot unlocked. Yeah
Anyone who ever watched mummy is now officially a member. I wonder if you get notified like even if you're not live and watching
Whoa
Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. We're under attack. I don't mean to alarm you
There's a bear. There's a dadda. There's a dadda repeat. There's a freaking dadda
Do we need to I don't want to hurt them
Okay, is it okay? Okay
I'm out of stamina. I'm out of stamina you get an email. Okay, so
I walked away for a minute with the fuck there's like six billions. I literally
Are you whipping us in vaderling?
It's a rogue dadda. He's not had enough of ice to getting steaming on our dj extreme
Okay, we're good. We're good. We're safe
You do get a notification. It's happened to me a couple of times. Okay. Thank you. Thank you to the icons in
It's an email. Good night, man
Mummy the snowberries have brain worms again. Oh, no, why?
And she don't just do that
dj stream
Something's coming. I hear it. Something's approaching me. You know what? You know what? Yeah, think twice
I saw the notification
Congrats and catching a gifted sub with your faith. Oh, no membership is not sub
Do I smell bacon?
Change the drip now. There are over a hundred armor sets in Eldering and you made a travesty. This is a full set
What are you on about a travesty? This is a full set. This is this is how it was supposed to be worn
No train. I guess like I was with no mummy
Well almost said the word
I almost said the word that I'm not supposed to see because you're not allowed to see yet
Because it's a bad word
I sense a fight up ahead and it looks like that's him over there
Okay, can't wait to watch the final two bosses. I don't have no idea how close I'm getting to the end
I thought they said the
Okay, let's do this
This is the boss
Please stop locking onto the refling. No lock onto the wait. That's not the boss. No it is
But it will not stop
I'm already out of stamina
It is dad has gone rogue
I can't believe it
Oh
Wait, why
I think I have a blessing on I think my health went up a little bit there. I must do
I don't know how that hurt me, but sure
Oh, you let him on fire
I suppose
Come on, come on
Take that spank in snowberries spank spank
Release him off his brain worms at once take him to the principal's office and
The great red bear I am the great red bear
We did it
Hydration enemy fell. Oh, no, you're gonna disappear. How did I get you back when where's the next point point to the next station?
Where do I go?
Oh god, they're clapping. I don't know what direction to go. No, I don't know where to go
I don't know
Uh, we appear to maybe be a site up to the left to the right
And the brain worms are eradicated. Hi, mom. Hi, everyone
Not the matey poop. I already I'm playing conquer. There's no way I'm completing it
I have I have no idea how to actually win at the game. We're just gonna do a little visit down there
I think he's pissed. I think he knows I'm here
Hmm, okay, let's get over here. Come on, Torrin
We seem to be unwelcome here Black Ops 6 beta is free. I thought it ended
I thought the beta closed
Where am I heading? Where are we going?
Well, you're still down there in this area is a fragment you missed in the small floor
Near the map
Yeah, I was gonna play it with you, but it ended too soon
I think I'm done in this area right where we're going. Oh god, my PC's taking off. Please don't
Are you playing the beta right now? We're watching the stream. Did you grab someone from behind?
I want to grab the reflins and be like I'm gonna fucking
I can't say it, but you know what I mean, um
Store host first floor, okay
Hydration check, darling
Thank you for playing with me again. I know I keep saying thank you and I know my voice is broken
My voice is very broken right now, but that's okay
My voice to break for you my love
And one day
How is only enemy reflins short ticking did you manage to connect or did you disconnect?
I think you may have disconnected
Want to
No, I think he was managed and then pain apples the enemy
Pain apple and red come on brain pain apple and red
And say pineapple and literally any other language, I don't know
You beat the boss so there's no co-op here. I can only be guided by a reflin an enemy reflin
I hope you know where you're taking me, right? You you don't know. Okay. You don't know. Okay. You've got a light out. Okay, right
Let's be super safe
Oh
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Okay a bit of a problem
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm get my ass fucking wallet
Literally, I don't have a reflin with me for five seconds and I'm already dead. I'm off by this isn't even my fight. Sorry
Can you please hurry? Oh, it's coming down
Uh, right, okay
Uh
The guys are gay. Yeah, I get reflins in to be
Oh, thank fucking god, I've never been so much relief in my life and you come and you come and you freaking come
I ain't doing this. I ain't doing this alone. You're coming with me if I'm dying you're coming with me
I ain't doing this I'm too scared
I'm far too scared
What would mommy do without us not be playing this game?
You're gonna head to bed. Good night refling. Thank you for staying up low forehead kiss
You guys are too sweet carrying me around
Okay, paint up you can come if you like got a millisecond
It may be p-time soon. I've got p-chair. Have a
It's been six hours already
What did you oh
You're stealing all my time. How's it been six hours already? I'm unable to summon adversary
Banished knight armor. Are you giving me drip? Is it better than what I have?
Oh
How did you know how did you know it's gonna be better?
Oh my god, check the drip. I just need a better helmet. I think oh you like checking out like that
Oh, thank you for the drip. I pray I pray the I pray these the drip is banging
You have a clap tomorrow in the morning
Yes, I do
Uh, I get I get to wake up stupid. I don't know why I couldn't get you in
I must score your Nina
Summoning adversary banished knight helmet altered
Where is it?
What it does better than me
How do you know
I'm pretty sure it's a rare drop refling kind of
Are you just you can give me all the good stuff
Right and then drill is Aurelian
Isn't that a city in pokemon? Okay, it's Aurelian. Oh, it's Aurelian city. It's pokemon. I think it's something else
Uh
I'm not allowed to go for a ttp
And a cup of tea
Oh my god, have I been here before they're all like
Aurelian was the woman I've like 800 hours. I've never seen that armor before
See the secret all along was you had to become a vtuber. Oh my god
I don't like it
What the fuck I don't like it. I'm gonna just hug the wall and let the rooflings do it. I do not like that
No sir, I do not enjoy that at all. I don't want to see it. I don't want to imagine how squishy it is
I'm pleased to go and beg and you don't hold it so long
Will you look at right? Okay. I'm gonna hug this wall. I'm gonna very quickly go for a p and get a cup of tea
Is that a light is that okay?
Is that allowed
I'm gonna hide over here. Okay. I'm sure I'll be safe and nothing's gonna very slowly sneak up and kill me
surely
okay
Give me a moment. I'll be like four minutes. Okay, because I need my tea. Okay
I make a little cup of tea everyone get up and stretch and go for a p because I didn't realize how long we've been playing for
That was my mistake. Okay. I'll be back. Well cup of tea. Okay. I'll be I'll give me four minutes
Okay, and then you guys can do stuff and stuff and things, okay?
So
What do you think you're playing at
What do you think you're playing at Amy? What the fuck?
Is that actually Amy or someone fucking larping is my little sister right now? Are you trolling?
What are you doing?
How long have you been at that for sorry?
That is her
But I have to scroll down. Thank you
ABI isarian
Aren't we supposed to send you a dollar when you pay? No, you're not just no
The reasons start that I don't know why they call it like p-tax or something
And they just send me a dollar every time I go peer like take a big fat fucking job
And I'm like, oh my god. Why are you giving me money for bodily functions?
Wizardry kuma stash power crazy jesse mommolo nebulosity fennec's producer
Dine in for two for ten quid evanes
Sleepy fennec's wink wink nine thousand tea. Yes. Capsicum dot car
Tyran shine refling calls. M. A. B. Zou at freaking veal. Why are you giving me your money?
Don't give me your money
You keep it in me so you can buy a c
Do you know what I told emmy to do is disgusting?
Dragon karma. Thank you. Would all his refunds be her maidens if you want. Um
You know what I told emmy to do so emmy showed her room tour
Um and
She had like a four-year-old pepper
So I was just doing work in the background and like I got my marshmallows open. I keep my marshmallows open
and and I reflin's like
emmy has got
Um, I'll be hiding behind each other. Are you ready? Are you in a pile of junk? Um
So and reflin was like
Suspend emmy until she bins this fucking pepper that's been in her freezer for four years and I'm like what so I obviously
I sent it to her and I was like you're done. You're done
And then she sent me a screenshot back of it already in the bin and I was like the world's
a
Faster suspension and unsuspension
Unsuspension out of each of our agency, but I said to her I was like, you know, it'd be a funny stream
If you got pepper
And painted it and then put it in your fridge like a time capsule
Oh, those are better than what I've got. Are these supposed to be sexy?
These are a bit better than what I've got. Um
Yeah
I had pin pal donated a hundred quid so you hurt get rid of it. That's all bra. I need to clip that. Sorry. Sorry
I need to clip that reflin's clipping. Send me the link so I can send it to our shorts editor reflin's pin pals
Send me clips of your wife
Not the only cherry I took of emus. Thank you stash power. Okay, there's a little thank you. Thank you
Sorry, you probably had to listen to the fate music on repeat
10 pounds of riffless. Honestly if you get a really funny moment
Just link it to me in my marshmallow and I'll get it turned into a short because that's hilarious
Hey, oh this door
Oh, it's a door
It's adorable. What's behind it? Is it buried? Can you guys come through?
I open it on this side
Huh
I can't open it. Okay. Well, that's fine
Our is good
You take the small baby door for my little baby hand. Okay. I guess we just go straight ahead
The bridges in this game always make me nervous
Always don't I don't trust the bridges. What are you casting someone's casting?
You know the worst part some pimples want to pair another
A hundred to take it from the trash and return it to the freezer
Well, I said to I was like, why not paint it like a tank capsule and paint like put the date on it and draw the
Pin pal on it like in paint and then put it back in the freezer and see what it's like
Like in a year's time to see how it looks and all of that just the shits and giggles
But she was like I've traumatized the pin pals enough of that freezer. I'm like a hot blouse though
This is a bad bridge
What even
It's like spewing fire as
Bridges are totally safe not for streamers
It's like spraying on you reflins. I'm so sorry. Is that because of her?
Is she the one that's spraying on you only I'm allowed to score it on you. What the fuck?
Knock it off
Whoa, I'm out of the thingy. Oh, I miss. Okay, there we go. Was that all because of her?
I heard oh rain of fire it was
Is that a PewDiePie reference right here? I don't know it might be
New drip for you should it it's not gonna be stronger than what like literally. Oh, yeah
You like that you like that you can't that is awful. What even get off
Get off. I'm upset
Behold go no further go no further. I will I will go further come come enemy refling you you're wanted even if you're bad
Go down
Uh, oh no press down surely meant stand down. No, I'm sorry. I'll beat you up. Hold on. Yeah, it's this one. I'll beat you up
head pat pat pat pat
Okay, I touch
The furnace golem here is extreme her is extreme here is extremely simple
Whoa ancient ruins of raw
Whoa, I like the dlc is very purdy and compares like there actually appears to be life in the dlc
Whereas like in the base game is like there's no life. It just can't exist
Um, wait, you need the horse to advance later. How is she gonna manage? Oh, no
Brian
Yes, they did thank you typical nation, um
We're doing more bosses on the dlc. I'm not entirely sure where we're going
They're literally it's like I I have my my caller and my leash on right now. They just take me where I need to go
I'm just here for a good time
Hey, okay, I guess we're going on a platform
This goodness is so hard. We just have to kill golem for I'm getting nervous
Who is this golem we speak of because it doesn't sound like the golem. I know that that's not golem
Oh critical wait, we both got critical
Is that a load
Is a double critical a load or is that because of lag we got away with that
Is that because okay
You damn
Then be spawned
Rather fruit. Thank you for your offering. You are forgiven. I give you head pat pat pat pat
You're forgiven for being an evil wrestling deep down inside
But you can be what is that noise? There's like a noise out here. Is it you? No
Hey
I can hear like scratching in my ears. I'm going to get sprain it
It's the literal brain worms are getting to me. Oh my god. I can't believe it
Are we gonna be okay
Is there like a safe station a grease site? Sorry
Okay, okay, we're going for it
All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right
I don't lose all my stamina walking up to him
Okay, I did a whole two damage there
Oh my gosh
Oh, he's got him. Can you do the ultimate?
You did it
Beat him up
Enemy fell. Oh, yeah
Beat him up. Beat him up. Beat him up. Beat him up. Oh, I got a secretary
Oh, no, how did you even change your look so quickly?
You're in game with me. Oh wait. Are you gonna disappear?
No, you're not gonna disappear. I didn't count
15 hours of sleep is good until you sleep that long
Uh
What how many technicals would I suck for 15 hours of sleep?
I would satisfy so many technicals
That I would
15 hours of peace slumber
There's an enemy reefing coming
Is he lost?
Wait, did the enemy reefing despawn?
I can hear the others
I'm gonna go back up
Wait fire here comes
That's scary
Sleeping that long is bad for you. I remember when I told my doctor
So this is when I was in the process of getting a blood test
uh, just in general to see what my like health is like
and
When I got the blood results back, I was like, oh
Is that why I sleep like 12 hours in the look on her face?
She was like strawney i'ma hold your hand when I say this you dumbass
I was like, oh, can you afford it? Obviously my doctor didn't say that but um
She I was just like, oh is that why I can sleep for a really long time and still feel tired and she's like strawney
You're literally about to be anemic rub get some iron in you
um
She said it with her eyes. Literally the look was like you
Um wait 12 hours is normal for pretty girls though
Yes, uh, it is definitely a feminine trait. You need more iron
If you sleep and you're still tired a lot embers
I'm sending you a little pill bottle of iron supplements unironically
And she was like basically all
It's like so common to be iron decision and I was like, oh, I don't even like eating red meat that much
Um, like I have a steak and a wee fried egg
Guys you heard mommy she needs iron again. Oh, we never wrote that script. Oh my god
I was checking. Oh my god. Sorry. I need help to scream fun. Oh
no, no, no, no, no, um
It looks like in november
is when
My
Scripts start running a little bit dry, which means we can write more stuff together, which I'm really excited about
Um, like I know most creators feel. Oh my god. My scripts are running dry. I'm not prepared after november at me
Fuck yeah, I get to make more plots together with you
Fuck yeah, I can't read
Here
I mean they're gonna kill them
I need some iron pills for but
Gonna head to bed. Good night. Rest well. Thank you for hanging
Oh, I'm back on the runway. Hello. Sorry, I got the wrong way
Uh, those 12 scripts from another life are all wholesome though
Uh, they're all like I hear
Is it a fire crackling in here? Oh, I'm to open the door. Sorry. Sorry
Open system. Okay. I'm gonna check if my tea's ready to be drank or if it's still piping hot
It's all wholesome stuff
I was gonna recreate the foot one. Um, because I never recorded it under my usual recording
Oh my gosh, we got a Molotov cocktail going on
Dang um, save some souls for the rest of us. Please don't know
Oh, they like okay, there's no way sin can play this section of the game
There's hi, uh, there is
Sin, hi
Fake wall
Hey
Ems will hold sin's hand through this. I think so
I don't know when she's gonna. Oh, there's like a mushroom back here. It's way
Oh, hi cute
Hello cute little mushroom pit
You're summon I enjoy wholesome. Oh, you mean patreon scripts. Yes patreon content
Actually, I need to start asking what kind of youtube milestone stuff you would like to hear not yet
I'm not ready for it yet, but soon I will be ready
And once the manager for audios is in place and then the general manager is in place, uh
Everyone's getting ignored
Uh, and I get to work on content. Is he gonna bite me?
I don't I don't want to hurt him
Hey, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi
The bigger the spider's the safer I feel
Hey
Back on the wrong way
Am I not to go that way?
I'm a bit scared. Maybe I shouldn't have done that
I'm not sure. I'm not sure if I should have done that
Uh
Also, I ordered takeaway when I was on the toilet. So if you hear my door go
Please tell me so I can fucking get it
I've got my phone on so I can see but
Please tell me if you hear my door ring or I'm gonna miss the time delivery
Or it's gonna be left out and be cold and I'll be like, oh, the delivery's taken so long. Why is it taken so long?
It's gonna be freezing cold
What we eating chicken
What oh that must be for you
Whoa, oh my leave him alone
You can't just scare us like that that is game Danny turned on the in-game volume or I'm a
My microphone actually keeps saying I'm peeking just talking into I don't know if I need to turn my microphone down
We things get a nibble. Yeah, you're in a nibble on my yicking. Oh, I got a fragment. I got the fragments
No, it's good
If you want to have us here, you need to make the game lower sounds fine. Your volume's good. You aren't peeking
Don't get one guide. No, no, I literally is going red every time I talk
Uh, it's like you're you're so red
You're beautiful
I've seen you're peeking because you have peak call. Oh, yeah
You're gonna make me blush we flinch right what the other here
I
Need to go get that I am
Get one guy from on software. I just keep speaking red. I'm like, I'm not actually peeking the mic
I don't feel like I'm getting that excited. I go red every time you talk, but
What am I going this way?
I'm trusting you
I
Don't know which way I'm going
I'm just whoa. Sorry
That wasn't me, but I apologize on behalf of the reason I will give you a voice when you have none
No longer will you feel shame for needing to ink and no longer will you feel shame for needing the a
What's the word um
The flipping a sense of belonging no long
No longer shall you feel shame for a sense of longing?
No more it ends here. I've had enough. I'm sick of it
Can we just be nice to each other and make each other feel good with her bodies? I mean, I'm actually really simple as that
I'm starting a new religion you want in
I
Feel like the shitposting comp on some of me helps the riskills
Cult of my mess
Crazy beaches for any
I don't know
Real one of the cult
Think ink before you think
Because how can you think properly without inking?
Exactly. Thank you. I'll be here all day. Um, no really. How about some endurance room?
Okay, let's beat this person up. Hello. It's time for you to perish
Hold on. Let me get to you
Enemy reeflings
Well, I missed
Oh, they have a bit of why is their hammer so big?
I like how all of us are just jumping them. I haven't had enough yet
Yeah
I'll hydrate I'll cheers after that. Okay. I've got a hammer a helmet
Okay, I'm asleep my cup of tea is now the correct temperature
That's fucking roasting. Yeah, right. I think I can drink it though
You need the horse for the bridge you got to do it without the reef ones. Don't say such things
Don't say such things out loud surely that can't be true
That I actually need the horse to do this
Is it true
Calm down calm down. I don't know. He's going for it. He's the fuck I'm always go that way this way
Calm down you sit here and level up
What and who is that?
Are you are you the way to go kill a boss for me? Are they?
Oh my god, I've not defeated one of those yet. Uh dad just let the reeflings do it
I don't what are you celebrating them dying? I don't know
Are we cheering from the sidelines go reeflings? Yeah, yeah, hi. What's it come pie?
Oh, no, let me cheers. No, just beat the attack on one side then run the opposite side
I don't are they going for it
Good luck from way over here come back
I mean they may be able to roll and smoke them. I don't I don't know how he does it
Oh
For mommy you got wi patch for your battles
Join them be the leader they need
Their secret behind the waterfall no
Oh my gosh, what what are we even supposed to do against that? I'm not being funny. What are we supposed to do against that?
Um
You can trust them those golems have a lot of nasty aoe really
Hit his legs knock it over. I don't know how small like I'm I'm rather small
It's a shame that you had to learn this way that I'm like tiny but
Uh
In the wise words of Scottish. I'm literally totally how did you even get over there? What? Oh, you have to jump down
Hydration right. I'm enjoying my cup of tea while watching them fight. How about that? What about you enemy reefling are you jumping down?
Um, oh are you watching? Oh my god, he's watching with a wee telescope. I don't have the
Wait, do I have a telescope? I don't think so
Are we telescope?
Are we telescope? I didn't have one
No
No, I didn't have one. I just trust they're doing fine from afar. I'm finishing my tea. Okay
How much extra damage if you throw it into the hole of the head? Oh, you give me it?
Oh, you give me a boiled crab. Wait, isn't that? Hey, that's my cousin. What the fuck?
Yeah, no, why don't you give me boiled crab? Oh, is this snacks to watch them? Okay, I'll eat the boiled crab
Greatly boost physical negation. Okay
Oh, you got lights and everything
Whilst we watch the poor reeflings in the distance fight their hearts out
It jumps. Oh my god
It jumps
Should I sit down for this?
Let me sit down. I'm sitting for this one
Okay, facebish is healing over to the right just to fail a reefland
He's getting put on fire
Glowing stones for I just brightness
Hi, I almost finished my tea. I'll come help after my tea surely
Look we're boosty. This is what say character sees a protagonist fights a giant monster in the distance. Honestly though
They just like oh, yeah, no, you're doing great. Keep it up
Mmm
Curious how many lights do you have? Oh
My god, the entire map is getting lit up by him. What's his health bar? I can't make it out
Uh, I think we may need to help
This is the part of the anime where you both discuss your power levels with flashy back stories. Okay, so I suck
Here's the genuine question does the host DLC level and effect damage given
I don't think my level affects that. I think you come in and it takes a percentage off of you no matter what you are
Does that make sense?
Got it reeflings
I mean, they're really doing good
I'm gonna go stomp, but
I want to go stomp, but
I'm guessing I need to go back through to the like I need to go past
Piss thread spear shred these enemies
Uh
Oh, no one reeflings down. I need to go past the enemy
Oh, no, it's up to just the fail. I'm getting nervous. Oh my god
Not me and the reefling fucking standing up at the same time because we're like we got a bad feeling about this
I got a bad feeling. I got a bad feeling about this. I don't know you
Yeah, I got a bad feeling too. No, I'm not gonna spank you with the fuck
Oh, sorry. Thank goodness. I'm sorry wrong one. I'm just supposed to be that one
No, oh my god. Sorry wrong one. It's this one. It's this one. I forget. This is the block. I'm sorry. This is the block
I always forget. There's a bonfire behind the giant, but do you have to kill the giant?
He's raging can you right enemy reefling you stay there. I'm gonna call in reinforcements. Okay, I'll call in reinforcements. I've got this, okay
Damn run out of heal. Yeah, I've got it
The giant is optional. You can avoid it. They're both dead
You stay there
Oh
No
Oh, no
Uh, how is he aggro to me?
Uh, does anyone want to be cannon fodder?
Anyone feel like being cannon fodder you perfect gorgeous come in now
Cannon fodder cannon fodder and you come
I'm gonna try and aggro it this way. I guess
And you come
Oh my gosh, that is terrifying
This is the part of the anime where the biggest bad guy kills everyone including the old bad guy that got turned into a good guy
Or we need reinforcements yesterday. That is his dire
He's picking on me. I'm not even near him. Are you even gonna make it?
Across the bridge
Are you get you going with it go go kill go? I urge you to go kill it
I his HP must still be lower. Oh, he's coming on the bridge
Oh, he got stuck. He got stuck get rekt get rekt right. I'm coming over
For emotional support, of course. Why is of course? Why is of course? Oh
Hold on drip check. Sorry very important. Oh
Oh my god, very important drip check
Oh
Oh, you can see my eyes as well
Playing dressed it in press
But in Elden Ring instead
You can summon us on the bridge
I hope so
They're attacking him is his health full again
I'll put you at your misery, sir. Please enjoy
Kai you I oh, I'm not saying that right at all. Thank you for the 10 gifted membership. Q. I ki
K
Kai
Ket you AI qi
It's like qi, right?
Thank you for the 10 gifted memberships and congrats to those who caught it with the face
qi
qa
Ke you AI like that. Is his health bar full again?
Fuck it
Fuck it. I cannot watch anymore. It pains me to watch my poor reeflings
Get stomped by this guy
Follow you
Monkey have I gone the wrong way?
This summons
It heals up when I summon new reeflings. That's so rude
You guys you guys are doing great. Keep it up. Sweetie. You're doing fantastic
Where we going?
I swear if there's enemies down here, you're gonna get me freaked out
Is this how to get to the
Uh
Where did you go? I look away for a millisecond and you're gone
Oh
Sorry, I have a really slow
Framerate for my eyeballs. You have to go easy on me
You like blend in so much
Try jumping are you trolling?
With the horse right don't go you mean with the horse. No that means no don't go
What does that mean?
Yes, yes, what does it mean?
Uh
Don't you dare jump he's two-posing
Right, I need to get the station behind we've got to go back to the gulp. Yeah, I need to get there's apparently a station behind him
How are you even supposed I have so many?
Oh my gosh, where is the I?
I
I'm going. I don't know where I'm going. I'm just sending it. Surely this is safe over here
Do I need horsey-worsey?
I think I might need horsey-worsey to go where I need to go Torren
Not that way it's not safe here. Oh jeez you scared me
I thought you were an enemy go that way instead. Do you know where?
You can you can sneak past as the reeflings distract it
Oh my gosh, okay. Thank you so much reefling for letting me sneak past. I'm a I'm an assassin. I'm a ninja. I'm one with the dark
I
I'm so impossible to see on the map
This golem such a billy he is I don't even know how we take them down
I'll take it. I'm so sorry to the reefling back there. Can you come with us reefling from back there?
Can you make it over or are you like insta dead?
There's an area you can attack from above. Yeah
Okay, we got a new one over zero
Oh, you're leaving. Wait, why leave me? Don't leave me. Don't leave me. Don't leave me. Wait, why did why do you
Am I not supposed to continue?
I
Might be in a dum-dum
Oh, he pissed am I supposed to be in the horse?
Am I supposed to be on torrent?
I'm starting to feel like I'm supposed to be on torrent build a bailey. Why are you called build a bailey?
Wow, you can get us from here
Oh
Reefland, uh, I think we need to move. I think he's coated so he can come over here
Uh
I'm sorry. I'm on the move. He can come here
Oh my god, oh my god reefland. What do I do?
Why even is these
Oh, I don't feel like I'm the one that's lagging aren't out of the horse or is this not like called lobbies
On xbox where someone's the horse
Did you trigger the uh, but he hopes so
Can you knock that off, please sir? Oh jeez the fucking breaking a pot in my head
Out come on as if as if as if
Okay, we're going up the stairs
They just bounce and balls around the place
Just randomly in hopes that an enemy one day will come across it like they just do this day in day out
Any difference? Any nothing?
They don't care
Oh go away
Enough I'm mad enough. I only have one reefland to help me
And I have no stamina
Ah, he's gonna give me blood loss
Ah
Take that. Yeah, you stink stinky boy musical
Good dodges why it's spamming the b button very good dodges indeed, right? Let's progress somehow lose an item here
Excuse me my good sir. Oh god the fragment. I'm getting so strong
Uh, okay, let me go through here
These guys attack
Oh, they attack over it
You know like freaking turn to look at him leave him
Pick up I am
red flesh mushroom
third story
Hmm, I like so empty when there's only
Just the three of us
We can make it if we try just the three of us
Uh
New reefling come come come. Yes
The name is McCree
I didn't know it could reach me there. I don't think the golem liked me distract in it for so literally it was like, how dare you let her pass
I've passed the safety
Let me check me. Let me check me order
Oh my god, sorry. I was listening to the doctor disrespect
Um
Did you did you right? Sorry? I don't I don't know if you care about any
I was watching the doctor disrespect thinking about bobber
Um, because he streamed yesterday
um
And he was so what so apparently what happened was like
uh
There was a gag order on both parties
and
We're on earth. Are we going?
But because one side was broken he could talk about uh, um, and obviously everyone went
To the left. Yo, can I not come around?
The real chest
I know
It's high noon mummy, but he brian. Do you want to give that another one you want to give that another try brian?
Are you squinting me right now?
It's high here
I know it's mummy. No mummy
Thank you the real jesse mccree for the tip
No, it's mccree. They were carefully
I apparently called Cassidy new
actual
Down here
That's quite the drop. Are you sure?
Look i'm edging look i'm edging. Oh, I see that. Yeah, you're good at edging aren't you? Yeah, you would be wouldn't you?
Oh
I took a bit damage there
I'll show you how a real edger does it
Yeah, you ready for this? Oh
Slow and steady wins the race slow and fucking steady. You ready?
Oh, yeah
You can feel how slowly I'm touching it. Yeah
And just like that just like that no damage
Are we good in the edge
I'd stand up and do a random pause. My body is so sore from the ring fit
No more ring fit. Well, yes ring fit. I want to do a monthly ring fit just to you know, check that i'm still the strongest fastest
MLGist uh viola, you don't have to make sure I have to make sure
And I still hold my tail if the girls like play ring fit on stream i'm getting them to add me on the switch so I can
um
Beat all their high scores and stuff. I will not rest until I have like perfect. I don't care. I will not rest
I know of a way of increasing ring fit and squat gains
So I played hard the first time I played a bad really overdid it whereas that time
Like I gave myself a rest and I didn't end up feeling sick
I felt a wee bit sticky at one point, but I like took a break and it was perfectly fine
I can't believe it. I can't believe if
you
If you listen to your body and don't overdo it. It actually works. I can't believe
I took a big nap. We're still we still play and we're doing the the same. I still got the reflins carrying me through the game
You have to defend your wrestling tail. Honestly that. Oh, do you think's the strongest? Obviously me. I'm the fat
I'm faster than you. I'm stronger than you talisman of all the crucibles. Show me
I have curiosity. Show me grants effects of all
Crucible crucible
Crookable madness and the vicinity increases your tact power. That's the whale talisman. Yeah, what one this one?
Truly this one
I meet tacos. Are they ching? They're ching
I'm ready when you are
I think azure would pin you down in the ring without breaking a sweat
Do you mean lore wise or actually in person wise?
Lore wise no, I don't win
Um, emmy actually. Well, it would go zero and then emmy unless you want to get technical
When it comes to gods and demons and stuff then maybe emmy
But it wouldn't be her actual physical strength and prowess
Strongest thought I'm stronger. I'm smart. I'm not smarter now. They can keep the smart title this way
Okay
Oh, there's enemies they're hiding
Oh
Lollipop domines oh my whoa, we're getting sniped. I don't know where I can't see them. Oh, I see them
Okay
Yeah, that's right hit that staircase. We're gonna. Oh materials
How do we get to him?
Whoa
There's a dog biting at my ankles. Get your dog
I don't even know how to reach him. I can't
I assume this is wrong
Oh, yeah
scaring me
I mean we can't get hit from here. Oh again another
Are
That attracted them all he don't bite. Yes, he do gets a dog miss
Oh, we go up and beat him like this way. Okay. Yeah, let's beam up
You think you can just throw arrows at us and we're not gonna retaliate
Fuck you beach
Had to make them fall over hold on
Yeah, get his ankles twist his balls counterclockwise make it hard
Yeah, that's what I thought. That's what I thought you didn't oh healing healing. Oh only I need healing
There is a boss ahead. Did I get a grace site? Uh, not that I do all not that I see
Not to be confused with
Did he has to the bomb wait, you're supposed to jump on from here
Or am I supposed to just bow and arrow him from here?
Just trying to cast this particular person
Where are we going?
I don't know. Oh follow the reflin with the light
Follow the light
now my ankle
You wouldn't be able to reach him. Don't try and jump. Oh, yeah, watch me
There's a separate spot to jump the golem prank. I'm John
Prank I'm strongy
I should make that
Um, my voice is starting to hurt. I don't know what to do
Oh lord, I don't know what to do
All I do is sing
Oh, you mean this grace site that's really obvious
You mean this one right here that I walked right past. Oh, yeah that grace site got it this one. Okay
Now we'll go back down again
Yeah, my voice is hurting. I don't know what to do
I don't know how many like bosses or what's coming up ahead or anything like that
I wanted to see if we could wrap up
The dlc. I mean if you guys carry me this hard
You know
I'll eat and take a oh my god. I have bio. I just got waft of it. Bruh that always forget to put the order in on
Oh, wait, what?
I don't smell like bio to me. Hold on a minute
I'm colliding this one. There's only three left. No, don't lick the bio. Don't lick that
Final boss of k no hard though
Oh
You guys have to do sport. Okay. You have to do spawn and then we can go next
Mom only means less than 100 sub from 50
And she oh my god, please go sub right now if you're not already subbed to your little sister
Okay, go sub. No, you don't have to jump off the mat. You can just
Thank you crazy jc for the super chat and oh my god
And me
You know what she actually am allowed to say something now. This is super insider knowledge up via lure. Okay
So, you know how we were doing those milestone celebration posts
And me specifically said please stop. Uh, you guys have to despawn too. I'm so sorry
a
Brain really or Brian stumbled over mommy and me wait, what did Brian say Brian say that again?
Oh
She already told about it. Yeah
Okay. Okay. Emmy leaked it. It's fine. Emmy leaked it. No, where do you die? You can just use the pearl. Yeah
She's like, uh, can you not do that right at the moment?
Holy jimmy's almost at 58. Yeah, her shorts have been popping off. Are you not seeing them?
Yeah, have you have you seen her shorts?
Ow
Yeah, I'm no surprised. I needed a bit. Uh, hold on. Let me hydrate
Uh
Oh, you're like literally you can literally be right here. Okay. This is better this I prefer this
Sir bonk more like sir and you come
Am I still online hello
Hello
Okay
Is my internet just on it?
Oh
You're still live
It's the bug. Are you sure?
It better be
It breaks occasionally. Okay. It better be the bug
I was like, oh my god, I'm offline
Now you put my light on first and first
I can't summon here. I said I could summon a second ago
Oh my god, the boss fight is here
The summoning pool is now functioning
I don't see any function
You're in offline mode we launched the game. Oh get this get this beta shit off me right now
Quick game how many hours level
217 oh i'm called fondola. Okay, that's funny. Uh, I forgot about that quick game
No, no, no return to desktop like quit the game
Quit the game
You know like quit it quit it and hit it
Okay, it says it's running. No Elden Ring is not running close
Oh, I just closed steam
No, I need that hold on open up again. I'm sorry open open your legs, baby girl. I'm sorry. Hey, mama. Let me whisper
Do you drink a lot of caffeine to make your heart explode? No
I'm gonna taste gamers up for the first time actually uh in a membership
I'm I'm snacking before my takeaway gets here because I'm hungry
Mummy's wait
Yeah
I've always been wait. Wait. What am I missing? Wait, hold on a minute. What did I say?
Oh, I'm a green flash way. Okay, sorry. I've always been wait
Oh people used to think I was Asian
Okay, now I'm on online mode
I'm won't eat in the microphone
Oh, okay
Oh
Oh my god, my game just started there. Don't do that. All right, sir. Bonk's not had a shot
Who else hasn't had a shot?
I'm just going to check names in case someone hasn't had a shot
Khaled and
You were a while ago
Oh, no, you were technically recently you're actually
Build a belly. Fuck it
I don't think you had a shot. I think you died or I left you behind or something
Okay, sir bonk
Sorry, I'm choking right now. Why the fuck are Doritos such health hazards? Honestly
Right, sir bonk and build a belly
What a good name build a belly. This isn't build a belly workshop
Actually, is your little beanpole get over here? Time to order some sigma
Hey
Someone I read too. No, we're about to go into a fight because it's got a mark of middle of that which means a fight
Um
Are you ready?
So she'll serve a Chinese auntie what she uses her voice acting feels to fake things. I can't believe it
Wait, you want me to summon the red?
What do you want me to do you point it down on the floor
I mean summon
It's an open world fight. You can still get invaders. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
This is a lazy comprend
Red can still heal during the battle
No else can heal heal during the battle
Good luck in the fight with it. Oh my god, what am I up against you're making me nervous
I mean, I'll put your name down in red and angry. No, but I really can
You know that's not
I almost spelled known with a k. That's not even how english works. Right. Uh, I guess we go forward question mark
Oh, oh my god
Did you just give me your fucking shit ain't happy?
I'm no your mum. I'm your mummy
Is you just giving your shi fucking nappy?
I'm no here to wipe your arse. I'm here at the milky. What the fuck? No, it's not mum. It's it's not mum. It's mummy mume
Fucking soiled loincloth wait, you can wear that as well
Oh my god, that way your asses would have technically touched
Why why did they even specify spoils?
Wait, that wasn't was that my drip already for one woman drip was uh
Okay, I have to do this. Okay, I'm falling
You wouldn't change as they hate us
What wipe your wipe your dirty arse
Wipe your dirty arse
I'd get you a wee a wee japanese toilet because apparently this is your butt and I want it
I want my butt skushed. Okay. I said it. That's why I want a japanese toilet
Oh, this is the boss
What is it?
No, why is it picking on me?
Divine beast dragon
Oh my god, I've completely forgotten how this fight goes. I have completely in wholeheartedly forgotten how this fight goes
Please stop tagging that reef link. That'd be great
Oh my gosh
Oh see that spew attack that completely gets me
Can I use my ultimate against that? No, I can
Yeah for something that moves around that much
Oh, we missed the ultimate. Whoops, honestly
What does that do? Oh basilisks. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah
Oh my god
Trampoline trampoline
Okay, hold on. Can I defeat these wee guys first? Yep
Uh, why would it spawn bath wee things?
No, go and spew on someone else because it's no me
It's no me. I missed that's embarrassing
Hold on. I'm doing my own boss fight over here guys. Don't worry
You guys just focus on the real boss. I've got the I've got this down
I've got this down. I'm shite. Holy fuck
I've got this
I've got it. I'm in the butthole
Okay, hold on. I'm doing the real fight. I'm surely copy. Um, this is gonna go fine, bro
Can you just not hide behind that? That'd be great
Okay, thank you. I got it. I did it. I did it. Okay, right. How's the boss fight going?
How's the going I'm coming I'm helping I'm helping
I was like you guys are out of range of the battlefield as well
Nope
Have I picked up aggro? Oh no, he has the magic stage
Uh, sure, let's just let's do that. I'm helping
Okay
Oh, I missed. Oh, I'm even at the reef land. I was like, why did you do that?
P magic the worst came true. Ow
You have to hydrate
Ah
That's a rubbish one. I mean it's really good, but rubbish to go again
Oh, I got frostbitten
Somehow I'm in this I'm in his cock. I'm in his cock. I'm in the foreskin. Get me out. Okay. We're fine. We're good
Enemy fell
We did it. We did
Divine beast tornado
Yeah, we feel and really said put down. Thank you
Thank you for your help refland. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay now. Now I'm all alone
There's no one here
Beside me
easy
What'll we have to finish him? Uh
Now where do I go?
Cotton Nigel
Good job, baby
Thanks for taking my laundry, honestly
Where are we heading
That was an optional boss. So go back the way you came. Okay
I will totally remember where I came from
Um
A ancient mung beans
East
Where
Where oh where?
No
Ah, wait got it
Yeah
I'm so smart
I'm so MLG pro. We only have three bosses left. Yeah, and there is all me I carried us through the game
I carried us all the way through this
Okay, who we got
We've got dexterity. Yeah, wait, I'm just gonna check
Uh
Russian you feel to connect that other time
And then
Tarot in the back, I reckon
You were just
The collab I have tomorrow is a visible my channel. No, it's not on my channel. It's on katharina's only
Um
It doesn't get streamed from map. You'll be uh, I have no idea what she's gonna ask me
I wanted to come up with some questions for her because I feel like she has to come up with all the questions on the like chat
And that and I'm gonna be like
I don't recognize that weapon
I'm just curvy and mine's not
The collab she had with emu as well. I listened to the start of it and they were talking about makeup and I was like, oh, yes
I'm actually learning about makeup
Uh
Over zero
Russian you cannot seem to connect to me like at all
Genuinely, right? Who's last on the list?
Hmm
I'm just your recent
Aren't you not being in for a hot season?
I don't think I don't think any
I don't know what's happening
Over zero and then
For my naughty wieflings build a belly. We're just
And angry
Well, I guess you're both just and I guess we'll make you the enemy the same
We starting to compete in there. I don't know why it doesn't like it
Russian
Somebody told
Hi, uh
I want what he's having
Oh my god. Okay. Now we are now we're show me. Show me. Show me. Show me
Yeah
Good luck fighting him. Oh
Please carry our mama to victory
A reef ones look at they've carried. They've done me very well. Thank you wink wink nine thousand
I'll congrats on completing the game. I'm about to copy you. Okay
I'm about to do all the bloodhound. Forget the bloodhound gang. We got the bloodhound
Gang fang. Wait, I said it wrong. You know what I meant. Okay. You know what I meant. Oh, we're going this way
Okay
And the last boss is clean
Okay, let's be careful
Oh, hold on I ain't got much I ain't got my two handed on
I was like, huh? Wait, what's going on here?
Okay, let's attack
I'm gonna have to pick new streams this
week
Maybe I can go get my nails if I finish early
I'll go get my nails done and then we can do the lake will build in hand cam stream
That's if we finish early though
Oh, we go around
I'm just following the light uh to be honest. I'm just following the light
Are we fighting? I don't know if we're fighting or not. Oh, okay. Let me be a little faint
Reefland, do you need to do you require assistance? I think you require assistance. Hold on. I'm coming. Mummy's coming
Oh
Hold on. Let me hydrate
He he he I like when he gets stuck in the wall
It's very satisfying. I'm helping. I'm helping. Okay, there we go. Ta-da
Oh, what Legos I got my lego hobbit set it arrived. I didn't get scum ass. It's real
Um
I'm gonna show you what box got delivered though
Just so you can see what was sent to me
Um, like I'll show both boxes, but the first one was like a scam
But I got a full refund so please don't worry
Um, and then I got my lego hobbit set and it was a big treatee
Because I was talking about it and then anonymous just gave me $500 and I was like, what the fuck
Because I was looking up the prices because it's an it's a hobbit set. So it's not like I recently produced like it's only
snipers the
Is it called sniping when it comes to uh things like that?
um
So it was oh resellers that's what it's called not sniper a sniper is like if you get a good deal or not you pay for it
Okay, I think this is a lag we can both do that. I don't know
I'll take it
divine bird feathers
What do you think scalpers that's the word
That's the word see how I said the word snake my brain was getting there
um
Yeah, I was just talking about wanting it and I looked up the price it was 500 and then
If you didn't know two minutes later anonymous gave me a $500 don't know and I was like, oh shit. Well
Fuck
Fucking me. I'll I'll build lego. I'll be happy building that
Ow ow ow ow ow. Oh my god, botulism. I'm getting botulism on the floor. Hold on. Hold on. I'm actually gonna die
Okay, let me
Let's restart. Okay, let me just wait. Why is it going up?
Why is it going up? Right?
It's still going up. Hello
Am I missing a creed am I glitched out right now?
I'm not in the fight anymore. Why is it going up?
What I am doing
I scarlet rot
You rolled into it. Oh wow it stopped like right at the end
These things are rare
Here's the rock
Hold on. Let me wash down in the stream. Is it gonna go down if I wash in the water?
No, that would be too convenient of a mechanic if you're gonna freaking put the rolling mechanic
At least let me roll out of it if I hit water
Remember the soap you got gifted earlier. Oh wait actually
How
Removes filth and accumulations on the fine. I'll wash myself. Oh, it didn't work
Oh
Hmm
Okay, let's try that again
All right, I'm ready when you are don't roll in it. What are you doing over there right stand on that? Okay
All right, don't roll in it no rolling
Hmm
Haha, I guess can wash yourself or nothing no more sweaty mommy the fair one
Oh new grove site
Hello, I would like to oh, sorry evil beefling
I
Just stops it from going further if you're covered in something that causes the status effect. Ah, um, can I?
I don't okay. Okay. Fuck it. Fuck it. Fuck it. Are you ready? Are you ready? Let's see what's behind door number one?
I have no idea
Oh
Do not let sin play this she's gonna freak out. Do not let sin play this
Is she even gonna be able to handle this?
Oh my gosh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. I'm trying to like analize
I can fly it flies now
They fly now
Like one
Jeez Louise got that design is so good though. Sorry. I said it
They're like two tails working in unison with one another good design. Whoa, it does a rollie pullie
Ah, you're not the only one that can do a rollie pullie. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah get plop
Get plop get plop
Get plop
Whoa, whoa, whoa scarlet rock scarlet rock scarlet rock scarlet rock. I know what those butterflies mean. I know what those butterflies mean
I know. Oh, they're gonna break my pc apparently. I just lagged out there
Oh, no
All right, just because you're pretty it doesn't mean you get to kill my reeflings. Do you understand?
Oh
My god, I could not imagine going on her
Oh god, stop stop. I'm getting scared
Get away. Hold on. Let me do that
Let me do this because I'm just kind of staring
All right, and then do this one. Nope scarlet puss puss puss
That is a beautiful move though. I'll give you that one
How can you tell if she's like looking at you? Is it the front pincer one?
I
I honestly couldn't tell you
You don't fuck it
No, she's got a reefling in a grip hold
Only I'm allowed to do that. No, okay, we're to see we're to see
Uh, that certainly seemed a little faster than last time
No, no, no, whatever this is. Nope. I don't like it
Oh, oh
Oh
Oh, yeah, hold on hydrate
All right, stop scurrying about the map
Okay, stop scurrying about the map
Oh, oh my god. No hydrate hydrate hydrate hydrate someone take aggro someone take aggro
No refunds down. Oh my god, please don't leave me alone
Okay, you did it. Oh
Oh my god, she was beautiful
remembrance. Oh my yeah
Oh my god
Easy easy. I totally did so much work. I did so so much work. I did I did all the work
I'm just so good. Thank you reefland
My right, okay, let me level up
Uh, what was it this one? Oh, there you go
So what I can build that weapon now. What was it? What was the weapon?
Uh
What's the dagger this
What I do is that right if I press B on the d-pad right, what I do is that?
Oh, that's it
Okay
Oh
Okay, I like that I'm here for it
Week four head uh tingling. Oh no
Got to burn the tree this tree. I can't go on
Mommy the final area might take a long time. You might want to take a break here. No my food's coming. Let me check. Hold on
I don't know if you guys whenever you order food. It always says driver has been assigned for like ever
I just constantly says drivers been assigned and then that's when I know I'm getting nice lukewarm cold food
You can wield to it once
I'll only have one on my person
Read message do it try fire and then ah, it's like a dream
Examine ceiling tree burn the tree
Burn the tree
Okay burning tree
Man fuck nature. It's me. I'm nature
Give me what I want
I'm gonna flash back to when we burnt the other tree
Now the little graphics quality sentence coming in on that shader on the tree
It's having a little moment. It's flickering
It's stuttering
Hmm watch it all burn
Oh
We have access to another part of the map question mark what was hiding behind these thorns
It's like a mirage effect
Mm-hmm
Curious
Curious indeed, what does it mean?
Sure, but the ball should take away
That's a lot of stairs. I hope you guys have been squatting along with me
We're gonna make it like I'll do it do
Everybody
Whoa, they kidnapped me they jumping me
The way it's making you so bright
Am I lagging a bit my pc might be struggling
Oh
Right, let me two wield this by pressing y rate bumper
The ultimate
I'll put it up you reflin if you don't start behaving I'll put it up you
Some difference, okay touch touchy touchy la pointe touchy la, uh, grass you lost. I don't know how to say lost in french
The grass you lost
A shalom please
She'll
And then we are in a place called inner
Liam ever wall inner-ever wall, okay gonna
Jess and then evil reflin
Painful
Oh
Can I open this door no
I kneel to this
Don't insult my new
I just wish we were laying at the end. I'm like we play
Okay, this is gonna be very interesting using these weapons. So please don't expect me to do anything in the fight
I'm just gonna panic swap to my other weapon
I'll see how this goes. Oh the old trees leaking madness
What was our quest again? Are we to stop the tree from leaking madness?
Are we to stop madness overall?
You really trying to scare me?
The naves have a really short range. Oh dear. Well, we're about to find out
Give me him
I mean if it's a fate honestly
Oh, he flies they fly now, sorry
The star wars brain rot's too real
I
Why are you going for me? I'm doing the least damage against you. I'm just mucking up over these naves honestly
Curious
Are the names upgraded at all? Ah
I'm glad you beat the rot centipede. I may have a
Yes, I may have had some help. This is true. Okay. I think I might have to swap back to my two handers because I believe I've levelled this up
Even if they're upgraded their damage is pretty poor overall. Hmm thinking thinking thinking
We can always muck about and do bosses after
Touch grace, okay, touchy the point
J'arrive
Don't do the point. Yeah, I arrive in the point. No j'arrive on the point
This someone says go out but you're saying going up. I go up
Bonsoir
You
That's the best French again, I'm sorry
And that's the best French again, there's no more senses. I tried to see I'm playing with my friends. I love my reeflings
Let's jump on
Can you speak Aussie next?
Uh, I used to be able to and what does it Australian people sound like?
And
Today on the news we are reporting that the reeflings are fixing the game now with these
accusations
Elden ring is being played in unison with the streamer known as strony cuddles
however, there is something controversial she is doing for the
Development team for this game did not intend for it to be played in such a way
The only Aussie accent I can mimic is the news. I can't actually do a casual Aussie accent like it just doesn't happen
I don't know what Australia you're living in the house, right? Well, it's from the news and I'm trying okay
I'm I spawned in Scotland. Okay. Here's the facts. I spawned in Scotland. I saw I've got
Yeah, hard is
To mimic an accent that's not yours
Now Aussie news anchor sound like that. Yes, they kind of have some sort of nasal capacity
Oh, it appears I have walked into the enemy's damage
These enemies do not oh, where did my reefling go?
Where did my enemy reefling go? Did you jump off the map by accident? Are you there?
Oh
He's alive
I didn't look where I was walking. Uh, if we get invaded it's ogre
Take me
Take me where we need to go because I don't know where we need to go. I'm just here from Idaho
Idaho mentioned
Ohio mentioned
Ohio imagine your state you're like you're um
You know like your state in America finally like getting mentioned and stuff
And what is it that gets mentioned fucking scuba de ohio mean is like the best you get
This doesn't look like an easy fight
Now hold on a minute
Okay, I take it back. Sorry we overwhelmed
Literally edging riz scuba de ohio. I was like, oh fuck. Oh finally my state gets gets put on the news
What does it get put on for or a brain mean a brain roll mean was it okay?
That's what they better than what they used to say about how wait, what's wrong with Ohio?
Is there actually something wrong?
Oh
Twisting my balls here. Stop it. No more balls looking for you
Wait what we're still getting attacked. Hold on. Let me open the doors. I don't know what it's attacking us. I need you hydrate
You got time to hear it. Can you do a bogeynax in?
No, I'm sorry
Can't
That's literally the best I got. It's the best I got. I don't know
Oh, how's it going mate? God, it's been a long one. How's it ever made? Fuck me
It's uh
Yeah, playing some elden ring with the bros
It's really something's going on above me not got a clue what it is
I'm so sorry. I don't know how to do it. It's really an accent. We'll forgive you
I'd ask you to do kiwi accent the last time you did it. Oh, here's the guy mate
Um, I'm kiwi. I'm super big, but I'm really friendly. My voice sounds really friendly
Even though I actually have the ability to fucking crush you with uh, just just my pinky. Yes, mate
That's me. I'm kiwi
de irish
Dear father, we're gathered here today for their funeral of our beloved rifling
He might have been a bad rifling. It might have been bright red to symbolize how naughty he was
Uh, I'm kind of losing out of it. Whoa, skip into Ohio. I'm dying
I'm getting absolutely mollet
When I can focus I can kind of do a bit of Irish
Uh, that kind of did too much honestly my answers should be spitting in there. It's spitting on me right now for sounding like that
Not bad. I do try my best. It's not easy. I kind of sound more like a
Not like the try hard type of thing. What's here?
Invaded by the drip inspector
Um help
Help
Help am I gonna die? Am I gonna die if I don't have good drip? Oh my god
Uh, uh, uh look like a woman now put women's clothes on fucking now. Oh my god
I'm going to be in so much trouble. Help that look like a woman
Oh my god. No, this is even worse. Put put cover up your face. Oh my god cover up your face you whore
Oh my god, what'd I do?
Okay, no, oh my god, this is not this is not scabrio. Hi, I was um
I don't know
Okay, okay sex go for sex appeal
Anga bunga go for sex
Sex you want to have sex with me?
Okay, there we go. We're fine. We've got the drip inspector. We are clearly rocking with the
um
The like I'm here for the sex appeal clearly. This is what I'm here for
Okay, where is he? I'm so scared. Is he here?
Where is he?
Where's oh he's here. Oh fuck
Oh fuck. I'm I'm in so much trouble. I stick out like a sore thumb
Um
Okay, what does that what does that mean?
Uh
What does it mean?
Whoa, what does that mean? Am I gonna die? Can I set this one out? Oh my god. I'm scared
Oh
Oh my god. We have to like pose and shit. Hold on. Let me pose
Uh
This is this is what I want to embody with my pose. I want you to see all of me. Okay
Okay, they're inspecting they're inspecting the reefing wait that reefing stole my drip. Oh fuck
Okay, they came is that good good good. Okay. Okay
Okay, that reefing survived I think
I think he survived
Uh, what about the next reefing?
Oh, they're they're judging it's not finished
Reefing's beautiful. Oh, they dropped something. Okay next reefing
Okay, let's get to it. Okay, they're being inspected
Okay
Inspecting the back. Holy shit. Don't you stand up for this? I think I need to stand up
Can I put my weapon away? Oh my god. I don't want it. Can I put this away?
Can I put this away? Hold on. How do I put it away?
Okay, let's do two-handed knives. No, two-handed knives. Two-handed knives. How do you fucking?
Is it Y rate bumper? Okay, there we go. Two-handed knives. Gorgeous
Okay, oh no, oh no
I'm scared. I'm fucking scared. I'm about to get a blood red
Okay, gorgeous
Okay
Did they get to kill me if it's bad? Come on sex appeal you see my stomach
Come on, you see those thighs you see the feet you see the soles of my feet as well
Aha
You see the headband showing off come on the long hair shows that I'm fertile come on
Come on inspect inspect
The hands are out the wrists are out. You can see elbows check it from the back. What do you see?
You get tasteful back. You can see the arch you can imagine the arch
The tuckus is covered
What's the rating?
Are you came?
I go down lower. I lower myself for you
Have fun at work griefling. I'm lowered. What does it mean? I've never been drip inspected before
Pick up item
Ankle guards ankle guards, okay
Yeah, I can do that anything for you even more sex appeal
Yes
Oh, yeah. Oh, oh put that look together
Forget dressing
I'm not worthy
I'm not worthy. I'm not worthy. I'm not worthy. Thank you. Thank you. I'm not worthy. Thank you. Thank you
It's a pleasure. It's a pleasure. Oh
What do I get?
Starlight shards. Oh, thank you. Thank you
Raw sex
Oh my god, we've done. No, thank you. The pleasure has been ours truly. Thank you
Oh
We did it reeflings we passed
We passed the drip inspection. Oh my god. We're so cool
See this is what I'm talking about raw sex appeal. Come on. Look at that
I see a little butt cheek see that little butt fang right there. Yeah, I know you see what I see
Okay
That I don't know how we made that forget dressed in press on roblox dress
Roblox roblox. I don't know what is
Dressed in press on elden ring is like 10 times more at stake. Seriously. It's not clean. It's not clean raw armor
It's not that armor either. What armor was it?
You know this one?
Banished knight
Oh, that was stressful. I don't know about you, but I got my heart rate going. Okay, how
Oh, goodness golly. I can't remember what I had on my persons
Okay, that one I think
Oh
stress
Dressed in press I have to
Have to take out the fucking jewel wield knives and everything drip to impress the exposed tummy
Like I understood that you could see the back arch you can imagine
Bending over all that jazz. I can't even believe that just happened. Is it rare?
Whoa, oh, oh, I thought you're an invader. I was like, oh, that's me done
Oh, whoa
Nice nice
Make it hard make a more great coming here
You have cometh to the wrong location
We go this way
You know
Did your food show up yet? Hold on. Let me check the it says
Yeah, no shit, they're fucking trying to reassign a new delivery driver
I hope I don't know what the oh dad jump. I don't know. I really hope I'm supposed to jump
Uh
Oh, I'm scared me a wee bit a wee bit scary
A wee bit tender horned
Signing a new driver. I don't know how long like it can sit before they have to remake it, but they better remake it
I'm gonna cry
Um
Okay item
Oh lots of I am horned warrior ashes neutralizing bulbuses. Um
Are we about to go to a place that gives us
poison?
Cuz you're
Jump no not jump surely not no pick up I am
Um
You gotta turn that into a clip that whole sequence was made to go viral wait actually
You gotta keep on I can't believe that just happened
Drip inspector is a meme in the community. He's the let her solo her of elden ring inspection. Oh
That encounter was too long for a short but if you want to make a compilation of your elden ring adventure
You should certainly put in
What do we do tomorrow? Uh, I'll figure it. Don't you worry. I'll figure what we do tomorrow. That's my responsibility
Uh, I think uh, I may be too late to get my nails done. So I couldn't do the hand cam tomorrow. I'd have to do the day after
Is it the real drift inspector if I would I could turn it into a short
Clip that goes on my channel in general
I feel like scrawny was
Drip inspected on elden ring and it's just me freaking out and being like, oh, oh, I'll take that
I'll take that enemy refland. How did you know to be there? You guys
Know these maps so well
Space to space ring to stream after elden ring. I'm not sure if it's supposed to be three days of um
Oh, there's a thing down here. I'm not to go down or up what we did the response to
Hey, hi
There's a thing down there. I'll get it later
There's always the chase stream. Oh, no, that's for that and that's uh, wait
Hold on on it
Wait, I'm to go up. Do we go here?
You
Hmm
Head pat pat pat pat first head pat pat pat pat pat. Oh looks like I'm getting you to give me a gobby
I'll try bend over
You will please mommy's tentacle and you will like it
Grace's up the stairs down as items oops
I maybe should have grabbed that grace but I'm sure it'll be fine do we need to go back
What like that
Do I need to go back up the stairs again?
Okay
Huh
Wait a minute
Hold on a minute. Hold on. I think what the fuck?
Give me one second
You
I
I just went out saving my fucking fanny out. I don't know how it's gone for you. It's gone for free
Mm-hmm
Freakin forgot to put any sort of resemblance of pants on
So I'm wearing this like comfy hoodie thing
Because I never took it off even though it's roasting actually many take oh sorry
I just jumped in sorry that's the takeaway box almost
Well, I'm gonna take it off now
But I don't have any
Boxers or any leggings
And I just want to say no like he said to that and he looked down at my legs and I was like
I poor thing you I
Got chicken and chippies. I'm yum yum yum the driver just no no he like looked out of my legs
And I was like excuse you and I was like oh wait. I'm not wearing anything on my leg
It go no, I'm covered up. No one saw sure. Yeah, I sure you he did not see anyone
Are you guys okay if I eat I read marshmallows and eat is that okay? I'm very hungry
I've got lettuce
I
See a gripper. Yeah, I'm only wearing not to do I don't let me open up my mouth
Oh
Mummy because of you I
Now have a type that Scottish women please serenade me in Scottish dial-out
My idea like that the way I'm eating my fish my fish. I'm not eating fish
I'm eating my chip
It's just something so sensual about the way I'm munching reflands are going to turn in the background
Hmm
I eat it with me in the background
I'll be as quick as I can I'm literally in here and then
I didn't even wet me
How much lobster do you have?
Oh
She be fake the driver's death and turned him into a gym
I
I'm inhaling. I'm in here. I'm telling you as fast as I can okay
Hello everyone, my name is Johnny calls and this is a mukbang today. We're eating and drinking cola
I were drinking juice as well. There's no way Elden you can role play so easily in Elden
I thought we're at the end of the game almost
Dependent on what happens we're either finishing off Elden ring tomorrow
Oh
And I'm somewhere in the sky I burnt the thorns at the tree. I
Don't know where exactly I'm
For them. Oh, yeah, I can't open up my map
Why are you flashing red?
I'm trying to eat so but you haven't spaghetti either cooking mom. Oh for delicious
So in Australia they have a thing called chicken salt which isn't around the world
But I think I'm gonna send the girls chicken salt like a wee packet of it
And well, it's not enough. I didn't come in a packet comes in like a wee cylindrical pub
I
Chicken salt is literally only oceanic
Like Australia and New Zealand Perry Perry, so yeah, Perry poor souls really good. I agree
I'm eating them stuff in my face
I've almost done a promise. I'm not well, I am taken by
I
Will me I'm checking on you. I'm eating this is my first meal
I woke up at midnight and it's now noon. So it's 12 hours and a slept like eight or seven hours
So first meal in 17 hours. I'm breaking. Oh, no, wait. No, I had a muffin. I tell a lie. I had a muffin
I'm getting fluffed by
Whoa
Need my food to be salty or to replenish my sweat a lot yesterday. I was breaking a sweat doing the ring fit stream
I
Actually
This is a fantasy I have about you relating to being tired read it to yourself if it pushes the limit I
Want to pick you up and put you in bed and kiss you on the forehead while you talk about
Me saving you an Elden ring. Love you. Oh, that's so cute. I love me there. I thought we're gonna be bad
That wasn't bad. Oh
That was romantic
Oh
The Elden Ring stream has been tons of fun even if I was feeling too shy to play today. Oh, don't worry. Don't be shy
I don't bite hard
Get job surviving the drip inspector so the drip inspector kills you I
Don't know that take your time and enjoy your food. Yes. Yes. I'm taking my time
What do you mean I'm swallowing so fast loads of ears getting trapped I promise I'm taking my time to eat my food
What are you on about? I'm not rushing rushing me. No, I'm taking my time
Ten a 10
I'm eating so fast all the ears getting trapped
All yours all for you
Oh
Okay, I'm almost finished I promise actually I'm getting close to finish
The flavor profile at Bart was Barry come play. Oh, no, do you have one of those things in your head where you can like taste and hear stuff or something I?
Swear
There's a thing where if someone sees a number it tastes like yours like something. Oh my god. Is that weird? I'm so sorry
You can smell the tickle
There's dragons everywhere
This is good, this is what I needed to finish the DLC. That's right here
Mm-hmm
Hello, welcome to my mukbang channel today. I'm gonna eat those bad food. It's gonna be delicious
I'm done
After I have finished my bad food, I'll put the leftovers in the fridge and then I won't beat the fuck out of these deals
Okay, this male leaves hoping to death here, but that's okay
I'm making you want to see you
Controversial but the best part about the chicken burger is the lettuce on it because it's so nice and crunchy and like
If the chicken is still like fried really well, I'll still be crunchy
But that is the best part
Mm-hmm
No, that doesn't count as a ha ha I got him
I love this is Opie
Yeah, delicious
I'm eating my green. Oh, uh, let's get onion good
I'm that I need to get more of my fruit drink
Okay
I've been healing as fast as I can right now
I had to do both court buckets keep talking dirty to me refund
Okay, I'm gonna play
Okay, I'm putting in the fridge and put my life doers away. Okay, I'll be the fucking
I
Okay, but controversial
Can I just see how much I love being a VTuber and buck-ass naked literally just flashed my ass to the fucking camera
And it's like safe
I love being a VTuber
Wow
Well, let's see if I can wiggle a big burp out for you. Oh
Oh, that was pathetic that was pathetic. No, no, don't look at me. I'm embarrassed. Don't look at me. I'm
Embarrassed, okay
I'm embarrassed don't don't rate that don't I'm embarrassed. That was awful a
Frickin baby coughing up spittle would have done better than that. That was terrible on my controller. Oh
Yeah, oh my god. Oh, it's stuck stuck in my throat
It's
Hold a man, but
You need to do a plate pain the delivery boy with your body audio now. Oh, you like that
Mummy ideas for November. Maybe bounce these off the reef ones personnel is
Like teasing at work whispering in your ear. Oh, I'm gonna fuck you up in the teeth and for work one. Okay
I'll read. Oh a
Loin cloth. Oh my oh my god. Look at you thinking of the reef ones do share a brain cell clearly I
Want how did you even figure that out like genuinely? How did you figure out how to do that?
Impassable barrier. I'm stuck door stuck
Okay, here you go. You burp made me have a sympathetic burp like when you see someone you on
Is there so smart is there so smart that was a much better one
Dubstep burp. Oh, do you think I could pay someone to make a edit of my burps surely?
Okay, where are we going? I literally cannot see because you put all this stuff down
Dear largest right into her ears already. I cannot wait until the warning is off my YouTube channel. I
Have so much a smart upload
Okay, let's go. I
Like the red dress. It's pretty
Burp completion. Let's go. Oh sugar. I saw it. Mmm. I
Understand refling I understand I understand hold on. I completely understand I
Understand oh
Right, where do we go from here? Woo-hoo. Oh, you break where do we go from here?
On the platform again, okay, sorry, I'm not that smart. Uh-huh. I
Can't it looks like we jumped down here just a little bit
Okay, there you go
Don't wait for the lift to come back down
You start stream when I'm at work the Ring Fit stream was bad enough
I got so many nice compliments about the Ring Fit stream. I was so proud of myself
Did you like the part where I was panting like a dog?
Like the part where I proved I wasn't wearing any armor
I
The bowling ball up here are we say whoa, no not the reflin the enemy
What the fuck I'm getting obliterated
Well, I almost died to that not to get political I almost died fuck you don't do that again. Oh
Oh
Careful refund you're gonna go
Did I just get all it on I
Don't want you to die. I got a great sword for it. Oh, maybe I
Like the closure range in stream. I almost died to an ultimate there bridge
Who over dancing?
It's so pretty
I
Need bowling balls. I always every time I see stairs that my brain just goes that bowling ball. It's gonna come for me
He did the tail porch behind your attack and me and the boys come into fuck up the bosses
Cuz Johnny got thrown around like she wants to be thrown around for one
So violent
What are you? Oh another sir
God, it's key shadow free fragment a shadow free
What
The clashing
Uh-huh
Run me through excuse me only the refunds have a pass for that
Only the refunds are a little run
Madam, I hope you hope the fresa. Oh
Oh
We can't progress
Where we go sir straight ahead
Is this a boss fight you're scaring me refunds can you come?
Are they stuck in here? Oh
Oh, no, my babies have to go. I'm sorry
My babies, I can't progress without you. I can't progress with you actually for once
The red summit sings a mini boss
Be summoned to challenge needle knight ledder and her allies I
Get to keep the refunds, right?
They get to be with me during this surely
Surely the reason it's good to be with me during this like if she gets allies, why don't I get out like?
No, no, no, we're not starting this we're not standing
You're no allowed to have just what you want just cuz you want it like I want it to all right
So either fairs fair and we both have summons or only I get summons. That's how it works. All right
It's like right. Okay, my reasons with me
Needle knight ledder dryly dame and our ally will never allow
Well, they better start alone it. I'm not having this attitude
I'm not having this attitude didn't bother right. He's bleed clearly
Then he bothered getting his attitude
Oh my god, fuck him up fuck him up show him how you really feel refunds
Redeem our clan now your shite didn't bother
The only clan is the refling gang you come to the wrong urge tree
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he's not rising anything actually he's a fanboy he might rise a few things
But you know what me
Yeah, yeah, shut up
Oh, yeah, yeah, you know what's gentle mean the refunds we fucking this place up first and then we'll make it gentle, okay
You come to the wrong trios man, this is a reef gang territory led in our team should invest in poise honestly
This is what invading feels like
I like how the fight and punishes
completionist
This fight punishes completionist. I guess it was one
That was easier than I thought
With the reeflings anything is possible. That's what you need to take away from this
Right, so now there's corpses not to get political, but
Okay, and we're gonna pillage the court
Is it I
Does I it was your shitty fucking nappy. Did you know when you die you shut yourself?
Danes sit work. I sure hope it works
Or else, how's he walking? Oh
Dany tingling no, I can't tingling right now. Oh, there's another dead corpse. Okay, hello
Lydia's armor. Yeah, but it's a better than mine. I don't think not shite get out of here
What shite armor you should think twice about using that stuff. No wonder you died. You can summon more in here. I
Says there's no tingling available. I know I'm calling it tingling. Yes. I'm a child it goes tingling
It goes tingling when I use it. Okay, so tingling a link. I
Don't want to hear none. I want to hear none. Oh
Oh
My god, is it lagging out? Okay, is there any other refunds able to tingling a link?
Yes, all muscles relax and so do your intestines rather fails. I mean when you pop your clogs
you look like
the Oogida bees from Star Wars the
the traders and Star Wars and this and and on
Tatooine, I call them Oogida bees because that's what I call them as a child. I
They trade
He's not being in last over zero or just a fellow just a fellow. You've not been in
You should unsummon the refland Jawa's are the raiders. No, they
Them guys they're called the Oogida bees. I don't know why
the
Guys are the Sun stroke or they know
Jawa's no wrong. It's Oogida bees. I called them that when I was young and the name will never change
Okay, and then we got enemy. No enemy
Oh
Our Tuscan readers
Star Wars watch along when May 4. Oh, no, I'm playing Lego Star Wars on May 4
I guess no refland raiders work here
Oogida bees. Yeah, I think cuz I'm misheard them as a child and
They said the word Oogida bees or it sounded like they said Oogida bees and then that was just their name like and
Ball bowling ball
What did I do
Wait war
You wait you warned me about war
I
Wait, I the but they bought that was the boss fight
You just finished the game no
What kind of game ending bug is this
Wait, that's a bit dramatic for that's a bit dramatic for a freaking bug
What
Can I not like ask the game to replay a fight or something
I
Wait
How do I respawn it isn't it not like the Ender Dragon and Minecraft
You could summon me into the Fae
I
Mean your game plus so is there no way for me to respawn that
Get a refland to summon you into the fight. Okay, right. What's the password? What's the password reflands? Let me in?
Put your golden sign down outside here
I
Literally have never been summoned in before I know how to do this hold on
Add a finger create creates a common sign sure why not
That is it mine, okay, I'm called Fondola, okay, I
I
Mean mommy made the final what a bizarre glitch truly wholeheartedly. What a bizarre glitch. I I cannot even
Put into words how bizarre that was we found a quicker shot than you honestly
Make sure whoever summons her isn't on new game plus you're being summoned. Oh my god a refland picked me up already go on then
Let me see the cutscene and everything because I don't know what's actually here. Oh my god
Hmm
That is the most
Okay
Okay, right. Are you getting more refland than two?
Surely you're gonna pick up another refland, right? Surely
Surely
Okay
There should be another
Um, surely summoning another co-op. Okay. Okay
Thank you for saving the stream. I'm really appreciative what a bizarre glitch I
So when you said unsummon the reflands obviously in the most respectful way, I'll say this brutally honest way
There's no way I could have predicted that the result of going up the elevator on co-op was it would kill the boss
And you have to be honest with me and agree with me. Oh that like no, there's no way I could have thought that was going to be the result
Okay
Oh god, this is not gonna go well
Aren't I like super like bad as well like worldwide?
Okay, I'm gonna just eat a lobster. Okay. I'm yeah, I'm ready for the fight. Okay. They're like really hammering themselves up
I'm like, yeah, let's go
Okay, what happened
No cutscene shit
What the fuck
Uh, is this how you guys fight?
I've only got five potions. Is this how you guys fight?
Uh
Uh, uh-huh. It's not redone. It is
He's back. He said round two bitches. Uh, he said I'm not done
I'm helping I'm helping
Oh
Did you know people in the uh
Up north Scotland have rosy cheeks because the wind scars their cheeks red
Oh, he's got a wee eyeball. Oh, he's got two eyeballs
There you see
Lord brother
Are you?
Oh, I know it's a fanboy don't care
Oh, you're in the cutscene with your big heads
Move your head out of the way. I'm trying to admire the cutscene
Oh, you have four arms is
What
My promised consort we're done
Can I go back to the flower in that cave by the way? I'm really I just want to talk to the flower. Oh, sorry. It's good for any
uh
No, no, no
Oh, come on. We were just getting to the good part. No, let me in. I want to feed the freaking fanboy
Let me feed the fanboy
Let me feed the fanboy right now. Let me feed the fanboy. We're the fanboy
Let me beat him in his little booty. All right, hold on. Let me let me spend my wait
Yeah, I have a million runes. Let me spend them. I don't want to waste them in this fight. Hold on
I guess I'll fuck it's best at the same degree
Okay, uh, sure. Let's level up these as well. Why not? I have picked up quite a few
And level up what's that level or not? Oh name life
Uh, okay, right, uh go over here and then get summoned outside
We can complete the base game. I mean we would fucking roll it if you want to
Complete the base game. Shit. I don't know. I don't see why not. I don't see why not
I'm not going anything in my schedule today. I don't know about you, but uh, I don't have anything to do
Um, what did uh, the the furled finger? Okay, scrawny. Sorry, fondal abuzum
Oh, man, it was like fondal
Okay
Are you winning? Oh, yeah, we might be winning a little too hard controversial
Might have won a little too hard by accident, but that's okay
Hey, I think the disconnect was why it changed the player to me never had that before
Okay, hey my way. Hi
Get another reflin in as well and then it'll be three of us
Hey, hi, thank you for giving me stream content. I bow I kneel
I kneel
Oh mother night mother night mother send your child onto go go go go go
Okay, gang's all here. All right, we're ready
Surely this won't go as bad this time surely
Surely, uh, I won't be randomly kicked out
Okay, grabbing my crab. Okay. I'm ready. Yeah
This is the only thing I did to prepare for the battle a bit crab
That's redan on mog's body being controlled by mckayla, so you know
We go to loyal blade
And okay, this is the first cut scene
Champion of your deeds will ever be praised in song
Wait, I'm the champion of the festival. Hold on a minute. That's me
the vow will be honored
And my lord brother soul will return
So that he may be my console
Oh
Hey, those are mashers so let me in the cutscene this time
Remember when millennia millennia
Whispered something to redan's ear before she exploded into a flourish told redan this was gonna happen
Oh, so he had to be scarlet rod
Clown shoes. Oh leave my clown. Okay. I can no challenge
Okay
Mm-hmm
I mean I could get my little we sort out if you want like I'm helping I'm helping
They're not even reaching him
My little three inch daggers and I know you heard it here folks. I'm getting shamed
I'm getting shamed. Oh wow it takes stamina to throw it. I mean I guess
Is that even hitting him?
It's not even him
Bro get my two handed sordid right now. Hold on. Whoa
How did you do that much damage? Hold on. I ain't got my double sordid
Redan was trying to avoid being his brother's console or understandable literally, how can I say?
Holy damn it literally
Okay, do not get ejected. I'll try my best. Please don't eject me
And bled the hell over much more
So then the fem boy appears
At the long last you are returned
Is that boys voice or a girl voice?
I think that's a girl voice actually tarnished one
Aspiring lord of the old order
If you have no sin if you agree for this world
Hmm
Then yield the path forward to us
Do I
And my promised consort we're done
Okay, I believe me. Okay. I'm too handed. Whoa
Oh
Can you leave him alone? What does this mean? I don't like it
Uh, can you leave me alone? Ow, please leave me alone
Well, I'm already a freaking healing practically. I'm just going to start with a damn fight
It's the best I can do my little
Oh my god, you're hugging my wiefling only. I'm allowed to do the struggle snuggle. Let him go
What the heck are you doing to him?
Stop it that's the main he belongs to me
Ow my pintas
I don't have anything
I don't want to get too close in case I die
Don't let him hug again. He's being
Michael listed. Okay. That's actually really funny
Don't make me laugh at that
Okay, I don't know if I should go in for the fight or let them try it. Yeah, I'm gonna die. I'm so sorry
I'm like, I'm just gonna have to root for you from you can do it. I believe in you
I'm so proud of you
Oh
I'm so happy you can do it. I'm helping. I'm helping. I promise I'm helping. No, seriously, I am
The fuck is this boat? Jeez
Look, watch this. You ready? I need to hand it and then I'll spray
Oh, yeah, look all that damage. Oh, yeah
Oh, oh, oh shit. Okay. Sorry. I wasn't paying attention right now. I'm going to the other side of the map. This isn't my problem
This isn't my problem
Oh, wait, no, I got a bow and arrow. Didn't I? Uh, right, hold on. Let me pop on
Enough with the lightning
He really likes that move
Oh, yeah, look at that. Oh the way I'm killing the enemy is all me baby all me
That's right. Oh, yeah, look at that hundred damage. That's totally me and not the reefing at all
Oh my god, are you getting hugged again? Please stop hugging my reeflings. Why is that not going? Please go
Please stop molesting them. That's my job
Oh my god, I I'm gonna die
I don't even know if these are hitting
Oh, you did it
You did it. You did it. You're so good. Thank you reeflings. Oh my god, you did it
I am the best moral support DLC actually complete this time wink wink though wink wink
I wink wink actually complete
Oh my god, we're just so good
The way I was completely carried through the entire segment. I love it. I too. Right put this bow away
Put this bow there right now
Right, so is there anything in particular? It was like that
I got to experience the final bow
What is this? Hello? What are you touch memory?
Touch my body
What's the memory?
Okay, knock it off for the wait
Ooh a memory
Oh
Uh-huh
Then what happens?
So they wouldn't have become a god if they didn't shark their brother interest or more
Honestly me
Thanks
Uh circle circle of like let us go together
Oh, that's a cool one. I like that one. We'll just go together
Hold on. Wait, hit up it on start
Yeah, I never use wave. So let's switch out wave. Let us go together
What's that one? Let us go together
Is there anything at the top of these stairs here?
Basically, Michaela tried to main control everyone into ending the violence
They can okay controversial kind of sounds like the best ending for elvin ring
Considering how messed up this world is
Right, where's that one that's in the hole?
Mmm
In a form something at fair take
Uh-huh
Free me wait a damn minute. Thank you. I'm not wait a damn minute
All the way down for centrina
done
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're right. You're right
centrina
Thank you, annan for the tip upgraded from sour milk to cream
I was absolutely laughing at myself when she was like that. Yeah, you should say word milk. I was like servered milk. What's going on here?
Uh
Hello
Oh, you have item. Oh
Oh, she's dead
Oh, that's
No, she's not she's she dead on the floor
I mean, are we here still moving? What was the bonus of that equipment?
It gives you resistance and stuff
Centrina was part you killed Michaela her other hat. Oh
Ah
That wasn't really the end and I was glad she was really curious about this character
I didn't really want that for her
Wow
That was wild
You want to go back to the main game that we're not complete yet?
What did it how far did we get we actually got pretty far?
Well, we go kill the queen's bed chamber. What?
We unlocked the Elden Throne
But we didn't
Did we win on the Elden Throne?
I don't remember getting this far
Oh, wait, no, I had to burn it
Hey, wrap it up wrap it up. Well, I need to burn it
Yeah
Good luck in your Elden Ring. Thank you for all your help. Have a good day. Okay, right. What do I need to?
Uh, it's hard to get the exact end and you want without looking up again literally
I need to burn
Need to do the fate by the fire giant which is him
Okay, it looks like it's him. So I'm gonna jump on
Here
Hmm
And then we'll very quickly blast to the main game since uh, we're like overpower this book
Uh, right fire giant is this way. So
Wait, what? No, it's not it's the grand lift. What the fuck? Where the fuck is the fire giant? Where the fuck are you?
The royal route
What
I can create a little here
Where the fuck's the fire giant
We bam doesn't know that way
The grand lift brings you to the top where the fire is
Are you the grand lift be honest? No
What are you?
Yeah, you are that how did I get there?
No to actually beat redone in my world
Oh, it's like I have to go all the way over there
How did I get there?
You want east capital rampart
East capital rampart
Grace for the fastest axis
Horn's scent did nothing wrong at all. By the way, they were on the cusp of achieving great things
You go to the lift to open a huge door
Not on my own I do
Right, we're in east rampart
My evil wiefling income
Oh
I'll need a guide for this all right
What's that even though I finished the dlc, I'm still gonna play that's right. You can't get rid of me
You can't get rid of me. I'm obsessed
Any streamsnap game gets been going
Can I not get a wholesome reef linen? I think it's only evil reeflings right now
Hmm my evil reefling take me. I am your hostage your prisoner take me to where I need to go
I can hear those bubble blown babies
Right. I'm not fighting them. They're not my problem. Don't care. Don't aggro to me
No, you stop blowing your horn right now. No, you stop that you're scaring me
You're making me upset. I'm on my own. Okay
I don't have backup the way I used to have backup. So I'm not cocky any
It's fine
It's good. We're fine
Oh my god
This guide is crazy
Got me parkouring and shit. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, that bubble's coming after me
Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, that bubble's about to get my arches. Oh, yeah
Oh my god the gargoyles with some bullies thinking the gargoyles
Aye
Oh my god. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah
Oh, I'm running
Oh my god, keep me alive
Show me where I have to go
Okay, I'm alive. Okay. We did it. We did it. We did it the scenery popcorn, bro
That bubble literally had my ass crack
It was it was a reverse fart that bubble was going up my ass crack. I was getting nervous, you know
I was going to swear you're not the good kind. Right. What happens in here?
Okay
I can just you follow the reef thing
And we go upstairs sure that we go upstairs
Okay, you keep going reefing you just
We'll just pretend there's no enemy behind me at all
There's no enemies behind me whatsoever or in front of me. Hold on. Let me grab this
I'm gonna go butterfly
I'm such a girl though. I see
Shadow wizard money gang. I love running away from NPCs right come. Oh, please disappear
I love you. No right now. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
Okay, I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. I got this
Please finger out finger hocus pocus
Please magic word, please jellybean turn around touch growing bags. I'm not it. Thank you
You can get our trees favored push to tell us man in this area
You know I can get fucked because I can't use some in the reef
No, no, hold on block. I'm ready. I'm ready. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you better keep swing
Hmm
Where we're going
There's not some of you guys up here
No, I already have my tingling on my tingling is on I repeat my tingling is on
Hmm
Also, don't follow up if you get this out yet, but the sword special has a follow-up heavy attack
Oh, does it? Whoa enemy. Hold on
Fuck you, bitch
Oh, that wasn't it. I don't think that was correct
Okay, that's good. That's good. That's what I want to see. That's what I want to see. I want to see one shot
Not miss your chance to blow this opportunity that comes once in a lifetime
I want a moment. Oh, I can't take my horse out. Oh, I bet I can't even rate. No, what?
Can I take my horse out? No, no, I can't take a reef one out either. This is abuse
This is abuse. I'm off. No, this isn't. Nope. I don't have a horse in this race quite literally
I don't have a horse in this race. I do not care to fight unless I have my replay
No, it's fine. I didn't want to fight. I don't want to fight. I don't want to fight. I'm out of energy
Stop it. I don't have enough stamina for your fighting
Everybody was coming by doing yeah
Those kids were fast as lightning
Even though it was a little bit frightening
Expert timing
Although it was a funky kind of man
From funky china time where the fuck is a save state? There should be somewhere that I can summon you then get me
There'll be a save thing nearby surely
Take the lift in the middle
There's a funky kind of reef land and a funky kind of game
Where the enemies are
Attack the same
Oh
Okay, who's not had a shot in a hot second
I think is there anyone that's not
Kua, I don't recognize you koala
Even I had a shot in game
Oh
Summoning co-op partner summoning co-op partner summoning co-op partner
And by up I mean turn why of course
And then smart you've not been in for a whole second
Okay, and then evil refling or is there evil refling here? There is you're so evil. You're so mean. You're so stinking
Are you laid out behind me
Hold on let me get my weapon on
Uh
Oh, hold on. No, I was gonna pancake you
Yeah
There we go. You've been blessed right you're next smart getting my fanny
Gorgeous 10 out 10 I do it to invade your refling
But I hurt you and then it triggers the boss music and it's really allowed in my ear and so
Okay, where we going now?
Where we go? I have no idea where you where you are here. Uh, I'm going to the giant
Cannot travel for us in multiplayer. Okay. That's okay there. Oh
Okay, I'm following the light. I'm following the light
Whoa
Are you naked and fighting?
How are you doing that much damage that he's not she's not possible how you do it no
Can you win elden ring with just your fists?
Did you hear that in my throat? There's a fucking frog in my throat. Yeah name
Wait, where's the other refund? Did we lose that smart? Where are you?
Reflang
Are you in the distance? You are you're coming. Okay. He's coming. He's taking his it's okay. It's okay
Let's not get too split up in the fog. Okay. It's dangerous to go alone. Take mummy with you
Okay, there there. Okay. We're here. We're together
Where are we?
Aye
Aye, there's poison. Uh, hold on hold on
positive tunes
Get that off get that piss off of me right now. Whoa
They're literally in the bushes. What is this?
Get out of here
Get out right here. Oh wait. I need to go kill that scottish giant. Don't know. Is that one about it? I think so
Let me solo her used to wear just a pot in his head. I'm like 99 percent sure. Yes
99 red bonus
Whoa, I'm helping I'm helping
Wait check those bushes. I don't trust them
For heal
Mmm
Are we almost through this fog? It's never ending. Oh, there you go
Oh, I got it. I got the seed. Thank you for your seed briefly
Oh
Wait, that's from man. I don't really bother
Why don't we get this one?
He's stuck. Why not? Sure. I'll take it
And then we can all heal up a bit
What are those scottish stones that strongman worship called again dinny stones dinny means no like don't
Do not don't you do that. Don't do that. Don't do that stones. What?
You welcome mommy wherever that came from
Okay, okay. Let's beat that absolute
We're dlc mother we're dlc players get fucked. We know what we're doing you can't scare us your base game
Oh
My apologies. I wasn't familiar with your game
I was not familiar with your game my apologies sir for such disrespect that was not intended
Uh, I was very much like my reeflings here. Oh, you already ready for me
How did you know I was gonna do?
Gimli
It's my kitty cat
and my
That's a quote from lord of the rings by the way
Before you think I'm randomly think my cats actually played my game with me pair fumer and lauren
I did not read that right at all. Hold on
I could just call do lauren
When in the special audience on patreon come this month, uh, 48 hours for me 24 hours for a snowberry and a bleeding heart
Hey, it's gimli. Hello my kitty. Would you like a head pat pat pat pat pat pat pat?
Hi gimli
I'll just name you vigo. Hi vigo
Okay, are you ready to get kablamo'd by this fucking thing again? I don't know if I need an evil reefling. Okay any come
Okay, let's try that again. I'm gonna take this marker. Oh
I'm gonna eat a crab stick
Okay, maybe don't
Maybe don't I'm gonna go pick up my souls first
DLC gamer I
Okay, but don't get too close. That's what I don't want to do is get too close when he swings that thing
When he starts swinging it's ogre
Whoa, his items just loaded in for me
Did he was he fighting handless that entire time?
He might have been
Oh, oh my gosh, we're good. We're good
Damn right enemy fail
I'm moaning
Jeez that was a beast of an enemy
You made work of them. Holy crap
I uh, I need to go summon you again. Oh, I'm alive. I'm a horse so good
Hi tauren. Oh look at the physics on my robe
Will someone please admire the physics on the robe? Look at that. Just straight balling on that thing
Just gorgeous gorgeous. Look at that. I love a good physics on some some clothes in
Uh
Okay, I touched the grave. Can I get you in? No, I can't get you in not allowed
And
You need to go up the lift before you can summon. Okay, let's
Do the grand old juke of york. He had 10,000 man
He marched them up to the top of the hill and he marched them down again
Oh when they were up they were up and when they were down they were down
And when they were only halfway round they were either helping them
There you go
Oh he rotating. Look at the dust coming off. Look at that. That's right. There would be layers of dust on that bad boy
You march them up to the top of the hill when you march them
And
Ooh
I'm no
Elevator
Do you think that's why they're called elevators because they elevate you to a higher position
Or elevate you
Can a blue reefling be summoned to um blue abodee abodee
And no way you did it right on my toes
Who's not had a shot in hot seconds
Uh, I need to check
Yeah
You just had evil leaf on time dex. We had a shot
Rushing your enemy and then it's over. No fuck you moved
The one at my feet I was at your next
I was over zero. That's you you're nice. Okay, so over zero
And
Then
Russian
And then enemy refling smart
I don't even know how to keep track of this. I'm just so MLG
Good luck with the rest of the game. Thank you so much. Rest well or sleep well or
Get food well eat a fucking mouse if you're eating. Um
It's 5 a.m. Over here. Oh, please. Yes, please sleep. Oh, no, I'm so sorry. We've been please sleep
Go to sleep. I get kissed asleep
Go to sleep go to sleep. Go to sleep. Go to sleep. Go to sleep refunds
Go to sleep if you need go to sleep. Okay
I'm just pinching you don't show my pinching
Relative just eight. We're doing a late game shenanigans. Okay by late game
We mean base game shenanigans because we skipped the base game to play the dlc and never
Never doing the fire giant up here
Mounting top of the giant
So go to sleep if you need a rest
Because we're just bum rushing the
What's the map look like? Oh, no, do I need horsey-worsey?
I might need horsey-worsey to progress
I forgot about this
Oh, no, this was the guy that killed his body
And he's like skin walking as him
Are we beating them up? He's a bad man
He's a bad bad man
Who would be lord oh my
Why the long face I fear that you were previously acquainted with this vessel. You're a bad man
That is most unfortunate
For he is dead and how did he die?
He gave it to me
I
Hope you can make your peace with
Uh, I mean did he give it up
Uh
Are we beating them up
I
Time for attacking. Oh the grace site. Sorry. Mummy's playing. Mummy's no garlic. So I'm sorry. Sorry
He is letting you get
Are we beating him up?
He gave it keep talking to him. Hello
Dear to tread
The poor girl if you are prepared to show resort
And attain lordship through righteous hardship
The words of I
Shabri
Mm-hmm audience with the three fingers and the flame of frenzy
If you inherit the flame of frenzy your flesh
Or to save doing mommy doing
Should we do it like that
The path of the lord of chaos
Burn the earth tree
to the ground
and incinerate
all
that divides and distinguishes
Oh may chaos take the world
He's the kill. Oh, I wouldn't want to kill everything
Take the world
Honestly, we just killed kain the mackayla so we could burn the world as a fit in
Did we do the chaos one?
Chosen the tarnis and descend
Okay, okay. All right. Wrap up wrap up
Uh
May chaos take the world. Do you want to do the chaos ending?
I've never done it before or would it like ruin it if we did
All right, I'm jumping him. He's my problem. Fuck you beach
No, don't you start casting spells on me?
Oh, we all
Oh my gosh, these things are this guy bad
He's bad news
Has a cut in a secret ending cutscene if you spare the girl
Millennia will get mad at you, but I still don't have to sacrifice or do if I thought if you got the frenzied flame
You could burn the tree and not sacrifice out, but you could still pick a different ending when you kill
Am I going mental?
Thing is we would need to be millennia in case we want to revert the frenzy flame
Wait, you need to kill
There's too many aims in this game and too many ours as well. We'll might up
Is that coming after me? I hear something. Oh, it's an eagle. I was gonna say I could I swear I can hear something
We're getting barred
I
To heal the frenzy flame you need the unalloyed needle obtained from this place which was killing millennia wait, I could
Is millennia my maid my maid my maiden?
What's the name of my maiden again
Melina
Melina is me then
of a fuck
malena blade of mackayla
But we can still kill blade of mackayla, right?
Oh scarlet retusie. Yeah, we're gonna kill the scarlet retusie anyway
Uh
So what's the problem? I got you to carry me through it. Okay
Uh, what's the what's the what's the problem me? What's the problem?
Don't do it don't do it if you have to kill your maiden. No, I don't want to kill her. I want to keep her alive
Uh, no, don't take all the aims my brain's gonna start moving them all together
Right is this the manual are we gonna make it across alive? Be honest
There is no way I'm gonna comprehend
So this is how it plays out in my head. I go grab frenzied flame. I destroy tree
I I destroy the thorns
But then I do a side quest to
De frenzy myself that way maiden didn't have to die everyone lives happily ever after the end
As tempted as I would be to go for that no horsey walk honestly
That is correct. Okay. I don't see a problem with that, right?
And then that way she lives and we still get a different ending because I married my
Uh
The that was incredibly lucky timing. Um, I married Rihanna. Nope. Her name's not Rihanna. That's the singer's name. Um
The blue one
My lovely blue doll. I married the doll
So I've not done it where I become the lord
so how about
We don't sacrifice our maiden and we become a lord
Amen
Thank you Rani. There we go. See coastal Rihanna. I was near that offer
Melina doesn't die at all. What does that mean?
That's right. Fight me bitch
Fight me bitch
I'm out of stamina. Hold on. I'll fight you in a moment. Let me breathe
Through the secret ending is like a direct tie into the lord of frenzied flame ending so it will look out of place
The one with the doll. Aye the doll that I'd shag honestly. I'd fucking beat the shit out of her
No whole left unseasoned. That's not very nice. Don't say that out loud. Um
It works fine saying did it after unknowingly taking the flame so she could get the Rani end
It's a long quest time to get the needle
A part of which would require a fight where you can't summon. Right. We're not doing it. Sorry tihi
I'm just becoming ill done lord. Tihi. Sorry. Sorry my wee maiden sauce, but you're getting burnt to a crisp. Tihi
What's that not allowed the reef lens? Well, I hope you like things nice and hot and toasty darling
Not my problem anymore
A fight without my my darling
And it really is it was in with someone fight exactly see I know you understand
It's time to push my line off a cliff. I literally oh right off the pop and you were destined to do whatever
Whatever other piss your mum fucking told you to brainwashing. I think and it was normal to get fucking burnt to a crisp. Uh, yeah off you pop
Hmm
I hope you like Hawaii. It's nice and warm over there
Bit of vitamin d from the sun. Nice toasty warm. Let's go for it
Okay, and then we become elder lord. You have Millicent helping you if you did that fight
Okay, let's be up this guy
I mean, how long is the needle quest we could muck about and do it tomorrow if you want
I have two hours left. Come on. That's not enough time
There's actually not enough time in the day to stream
I can't believe it
I'm gonna be him up. There we go. Come get him
Okay, mommy it's still late for me. I'm going to eat rest well cpa. Bye. Bye
That goes for any refland that needs to rest. Don't be afraid of rest and finish it tomorrow. I mean, I cute
Nido is not so long. You just teleport to five points spam talk then fight a monster and some NPCs
Right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I think we'll do the frenzy flame. Fuck it. Fuck it. Fuck it
We'll do the frenzy flame and we'll play
Whoa, we'll play elden ring tomorrow as well. So I don't need to be creative and think of anything smell
Okay, we're gonna be up this giant
I can't sleep as long as mommy screams aren't your eyes like bulging out your skull from tiredness?
I'm not exactly a streamer. You put on to fall asleep to either because when I get excited I start getting really loud
I'm gonna get like really loud. I can't help it. It just gets what happens
Okay, I'll stick the word right so we'll grab frenzy flame so we can save little
Maid and then we'll undo it. Okay. We'll undo it. We'll be good boys and girls and undo it
That's the good part the Scottish for shame. I have fucking bam
I'm not supposed to be up here
I'm not to be up here
I don't know. Are you good me right now?
No, you're gonna give yourself a heart attack
Don't have energy drink just to stay up
That's bad
Sleep if you need to sleep you can always like watch me in times two and if you have youtube vans you can watch me in times five
Oh, I don't even know if you'd understand what i'm saying at that point
Y'all
Choir materials a fire blossom
I love a good
Love a good blossom
Sorry i'm getting company
Mummy up and fighting speed sounds like a fever dream honestly
It's against it
I don't know what you're talking about
I'd use an advancement and advancement. Yes, that's the word I use. Use bird's-eye telescope.
Eh? Oh look! I can see you from up here! Hi, reflings! Where's enemy refling? I don't
see him. Oh there he is, he's right next to me. He's throwing a ball. I can see you from
here! Did that cost me five souls to use? Okay, fight. You hate this boss? Oh, is this
where the fog comes down? I can see my refling. I can see my husband here. Where is he? I mean,
careful what you wish for, but where is he? Hello? Hello? Are you here? Okay, I should have
been careful. I'm sure he is. He's spawning in somewhere. Oh, something's happening. I can't
see shit. I don't know about- fuck it, I'll put my light on. There you go. I'm helping. There you go. I can see
through the snow storm. Yeah, I'm sure that light helps. Ow! Something's getting me. Fucking
busty crustaceans are going for me. Oh, I found him. I found him. Didn't you worry, I found
him. Big body Alice, the freezing fog. I bet ya. Oh, I'm out of energy. Hold on. Alright.
What is going for me? Ow! Whoa, that fucking damage is insane. Do I have like zero magic resistance?
I think so. I must have like limited magic resistance. That's terrible. Stop it. Oh, that's not
your arm. I need my glasses on. I'm so sorry. Did you- I thought that rock was his wing. I got
so excited. I was like, oh my god, easy peasy attack. Dumbass. Fucking dumbass. I sure showed
that rock who's boss. Oh god, I'm actually gonna hit him. Okay, that'll do. Whoa, whoa, whoa, please
don't. Please don't die. Don't be selfish, Reflins. Don't leave me to fight this boss.
Don't be selfish. Why are you going for me? Good thing I got stamina, but it's not going
for me now. Oh, I got good wall upon him there. I can't see nothing. Okay, he's not going
for me. He's going for the jellyfish? Yeah, fuck that jellyfish up. Show it who's boss.
Show it who runs this lake. What does that move mean? I don't know. Oh, it just means
ice storm. Okay. Okay, okay, okay. Let's get closer. Oh, roll. Okay, well, I did want to
roll, but I was already in attack mode, so. Oh, I'm getting away. This is hard. Oh my god, please
go for his feet. Okay, I hit his wing. You're welcome. I hit his wing on the way out. That
breath of ice is insane damage. It's actually Buckus. Oh, you got him. You got him. You did
it. You did it. Go, Reflin, go. Go, Reflin, go. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. It's your birthday.
Hold on a minute. Real quick before you disappear. It's your birthday. It's your birthday. Oh,
yeah. Oh, yeah. It's your birthday. Let's go together. Birthday. I tell you, you can use the
birthday. I found a very similar years. Okay. Why would you tell me that now? Defeat the dragon.
By the way, did you know? No, I didn't. I didn't, but sure. Right. We go this way now. You need
to be someone. I will find a place to summon you. There's a church here. Maybe there is a seed.
Sorry, I just realized how bright I am for the section of the game. Sorry. I'll make myself less
be. It's because you used the one we'll encode more, but it can't show you tutorials. Oh. Go, Reflin, go.
Proceeds to vanish, honestly. I just, wait. Hold on. I get wary of these churches because they always
seem to have a fight in them. I don't seem to see the white trails either, suggesting that it's a save station.
Or do I? No. Fuck off. I don't trust it. I don't trust it. I want Reflin. Go away. Let's go back to the road.
On the road again. I never fought in a church, Elden Ring. It's safe. Are you sure?
A mummy, the glowing angel down from the heavens. The thunderous clap deafening all those who witnessed.
No, go into that church. Okay. I just remember all the... I never even saw that. That was so far away.
Oh, get off the horse, please. Okay, we grab the Sacred Tear, and then we sit down at the Grace, which is y'all?
Hawaii? And then we sit down here. Can I even level up, or is it...? I can.
I could just put into health. Why not? Max out of health, YOLO. And then Flask? Yeah.
Okay, we've got an extra Flask. Feels good, man. We can talk to... No, I don't want to talk to her. Sorry.
She's not going to be happy with what I'm about to do in a minute. I don't want to talk to her. She's going to spank us.
We've been naughty. I'm sorry. Oh, my shoulders hurt. What do you mean?
Right, hold on. Let me check if there's someone who's not been here for a hot day. Tarnished. I don't know you.
Okay, Income Tarnished. Yarnished to Arlene.
Got to sleep early tonight. Good luck. Good luck on your sleeping early. Rest well.
Edge Lord McGee, you've not been in.
And who's my evil refund? Who's not being evil? You've not been evil very often.
I don't even think you've been evil once, actually. Oh, there's only two? Those are blood spots.
Okay, you can be evil if you're slim, then.
Navigol. W stream. What, I think? You mean getting my handheld through the game is a dub?
Well, yes, I agree. I couldn't agree more, actually.
Am I just a drip inspector shows up to see what I've done? Ah, I would definitely fail.
I think the drip inspector knew that I swapped out clothes really quickly.
Oh, you want, you want blessed? Okay, I'll bless you. Sorry.
I'll get, can enemy roofling move away so I don't accidentally hit you because I don't want the battle music to play.
It's really annoying when it plays. I bless, I bless.
Are you cowering? You cannot cower from my buttocks.
My buttocks, my cheeks will always find you, I assure you.
Ah, right, I guess we just go this way.
Back on the road, and then once we're on the road it should be fine, right? Right, right.
It's expected to change an earfinest drip for the drip inspector? Okay, so I'm not gonna get exposed for...
Where is that map? Oh, it's up ahead. Like, on the path.
Hey, Momay, how flexible are you? I can put my legs behind my head.
Like that, if he was one HP in a dream.
I believe in you guys, you got this.
My legs are super flexible. My back, unfortunately, I injured it.
I used to go to the gym, and it was a guy, gym assistant, and he went, long story.
Oh no, that's a shame. I think he was a long story short.
He was treating me a lot stronger than I actually was, and I hurt my back.
And now I can't, like, arch my back.
Oh, shit, are we supposed to sneak past those guys? I wasn't paying attention.
Okay.
Okay, so imagine Mummy wraps her legs around your neck to play. Yeah, I could probably do that easy.
For some reason, my life completely unaffected, but my back and my shoulders and my arms...
You know how people can, like, touch their shoulders backwards?
One arm has way worse than the other, and I'm damaged.
I have something wrong with my shoulders as well.
I used to go for sports massages, and the wife, she was so lovely to me.
She used to compliment me. She was like, oh, you're so pale.
And I'm like, oh my god, stop.
She used to be like, oh, I want pale skin like yours, and I'm like, I don't go outside.
But she was lovely, honestly.
Sorry, I'm not paying attention too, because you're rambling about my fucking massages.
But when she gave me my massage, she was like, what's wrong with your shoulders?
What do you do? And I'm like, am I gamer?
And she was like, this? You do this to yourself, gay man?
And I think I, like, hold myself up weird or something, and I don't realize it.
I was gonna try and see if I could find a place to go for sports massages again,
but I'm really scared, because I saw a fucking...
Right, this sounds bizarre. I don't know if it's real or not.
But apparently a lot of, like, massage parlors have a hidden camera,
and they, like, sell the footage, and I don't know if I should believe it or not,
but I didn't want my fanny out there, like...
Like, if I'm putting it out there, the reflins get to see it first.
I said what I said.
I blew out my knees because of the worker.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry for you, but...
Wait, are we gonna... Am I not supposed to be this way?
Never thought about that. Yeah, like, apparently there's, like, a...
Whoa! Hold on.
Ah, I'm so skinny.
Right, where am I going? Oh, up the ladder, the ladder.
Of course, the ladder! You mean that really obvious thing right here, yeah.
That blends in.
Probably need to do shoulders.
Well, she, the lady that was helping me, she was like,
you need to rotate your... You know, there's, like...
Oh, I can't even do it right now. It hurts to much to think about it.
You know, if I pointed to this guy with my hand, like, my arm all the way up,
and then went in circles, I don't know what that particular thing is called,
but she was like, do that every single day, forward and backward,
because you're so fucked up, and I was like, oh, okay.
And did I do it? No. And now I'm, like, got even worse mobility.
I'm broken, okay, reflins, I'm broken.
A rotary cuff injury? No, like, it can be fixed.
Oh, I'll go this way. It can be fixed.
But the problem is I don't do anything to fix it, i.e. I don't go to a massage person.
A masseuse? A masseuse, massage person.
I mean, it's not wrong, but...
It is a person who... Whoa! Rebling!
Are you dead?
Where did you go?
Am I going crazy?
Did he not go in there?
Hydration check.
Oh, now you're right.
Hold on, one hydration, please.
Damn. Where's these massage parlours so I can avoid them?
Did I tell you she almost touched my fanny in one of the massages? I was like, oh yeah.
So I left my wee boxers on, and...
So in order to do your gluteus maximus, your butt muscles,
they have to pull down your wee boxers and mat, but then they also go around your thighs as well.
And I was like, are you aiming for this? What's going on here?
I did not tip you the extra five. What's going on here?
What's the problem?
Where am I going?
Sorry, I can hardly string a sentence together right now.
I wanted to do a roleplay like that as well, where I was your inappropriate masseuse person.
Wait, did I not make that? Am I going crazy?
Hold on a minute.
I'm getting a memory. Did I not write that?
Where are we going?
I'm following you. Are you as lost as me right now?
Okay. I'm following you.
Wait, we've been here.
Quick hand from Johnny.
A happy ending. Yeah, I could have sworn I wrote a happy ending.
Did I write it for one of the girls recently?
Yeah, now that the script is back, maybe I wrote it only for me.
I'm thinking.
Maybe I started writing it for me. I don't recall giving it to any of the girls.
Like, anyone's more lovey-dovey stuff, so I wrote that.
I mean, I wrote a maidscript for AC, but that doesn't sound like anything like that.
Maybe I did write one.
Did something have a massage element in it, maybe?
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you, Reflinks, for leading me.
Why poison yourself? What are you eating? That's poison anyway.
Oh, jeez. Okay, okay, I see who it is.
I wonder if there's any Reflinks to spawn.
Did you include silly comments in the script too?
I feel like I made a meme script, but I can't even recall nothing.
None of the details or anything.
God, there's so much blood here! What the fuck is ahead? The Giants!
Why is there so much blue?
Okay, right. What are we looking at?
Okay.
Uh, Gary, he's not been in any of these.
Oh, that's not red.
That is red, get? I read the else.
Mm-hmm.
And one.
Why?
And then, here's my evil Reflinks real question.
Cat top season.
No, what? Oh, right, because there's blood everywhere.
I'm already off it, what the fuck?
I was like, that's why ovulation's coming up.
Because after the sea of red, it goes good.
Who is my last evil?
Midra's Disciple? I've not had you.
Hi.
Mm-hmm.
She's still going. You can't stop me.
As soon as it comes, the endurance goes up even further.
As soon as it comes to when you guys have the ability to play with me,
you should see my piece of paper.
Actually, I'll need to take out a ton of...
I need to put my papers together.
Mm-hmm.
Hey.
I wish this game had CrossFit. I'm so sorry.
I promise, I promise.
Hopefully, games that have more CrossFit, I promise, I promise.
I can see your butt line. What's going on here?
Okay, where are we going?
Come.
Let's go together.
Show me the way.
Okay, let's be gentle.
Be gentle with me.
Mm-hmm, that stopped all.
I, A, I technically stopped to pee and eat.
But unfortunately, I'm getting close to the VOD limit,
which is making me nervous. I hear that.
Come on, YouTube. Update so there's no VOD limit,
so I can do a 24-hour stream for the YOLO.
Come on.
Monster Hunter better have CrossFit. I've got a boner for it.
What?!
Honestly, me.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. Oh, I got a somber smithing stone.
Not bad.
You've still got 2.5 hours to go.
But it's not enough, is it?
It's not enough refund time.
Oh, I'll say my voice is really starting to hurt to talk
and I feel really bad because I don't want to, like, stop talking.
Oh, there's an item back here.
Do excuse me. I'll pick this bad boy up.
Please be a smithing stone.
I did.
Another one.
I need vocal rest. I do.
I do actually need vocal rest.
Oh, god, the giants are fighting.
Do we just ignore the giants?
I'm gonna ignore them, okay?
Just let them fight, okay?
That's not mommy's problem.
That's not mommy and reflin's problem.
What they do on their time off is nothing to do with what I thought it would be.
Is this the one where there's a fight and it's the guy's blade or something?
I remember you giving me a blood blade here.
Whether or not there was this life or another.
Okay, it's safe, it's safe.
Church of repos.
That's where the reflin's at.
I'm like, Pokemon? Ah, that's what I've been doing.
I just need to ignore.
Okay, absolutely good to hear.
Let's go.
Hey!
Sorry.
Yes, I am.
I've been up since midnight. Be nice.
Becaine!
It's technically my bedtime and I kid you not to.
I'm gonna be streaming it in my bedtime.
Where the fuck did you go?
Dude!
Yeah, I swear you guys just disappear right in front of me.
Up the rock?
Oh, careful!
I'm to go up the rock?
Or is this not the correct rock?
If you think you are graduating Elton Ring without kissing my cock, you are dead wrong.
Well, you've been at this since 2 p.m. my time and it's 2 a.m.
Yours, I believe.
It's 1 p.m. for me.
I'm in Australia, can't...
Ha ha ha!
Oh, something's going for us.
Oh yeah!
No!
There will be no avian vichabers!
They're acting like this on the side.
Hi, how you doing?
Straight to my...
Real Andrew.
Your bedtime is 3 p.m.?
I wake up at midnight, so if I record ASMR for example, it's quiet.
Well, for the most part, there's not going to be any cars that would interrupt me.
But when has that ever stopped a car interrupting me or a plane going overhead or this or X or Y or Z or P?
No crow vichabers!
I'll go to this grey site down here.
I don't know if you survive or I'll survive.
Your sleep schedule is just foobar?
Isn't that strong enough?
What does foobar mean?
Gigi.
I don't know this word.
It's 11 p.m. for me, but screw sleep, mommy's streaming.
No! Go sleep if you need to sleep.
No slimes, no avians, you're just the one's to have fun!
I bring you the fur-
Actually, no, I'm sure there's been another YouTuber out of the McDonald's Happy Meal variety before.
Foobar?
Fucked up beyond repair.
Oh!
That's what foobar means?
F'd up beyond all repair.
Have I gone the wrong way?
What are you hearing at?
Eh, Macarena.
I didn't vanquish it!
Oh god, is this a fight?
Okay.
Situations all, normally all left up.
Snafu.
There he is!
Damn, I didn't get the cutscene.
Cutscene?
Is he not a cutscene boss?
Can I go on my horse?
Am I reeflings here?
Hey reeflings, are you still here by a chunk?
Hey reeflings, you wanna come help?
Reefling, reefling, reefling.
I'm scared.
What does this attack?
He really said deforestation, that's my attack.
Okay.
How'd I deal with him?
Cutscenes only if he survived a phase two.
Is that my lightning?
Oh yeah, you have to go for his gammy leg.
I'm disgusting.
If I can even get close enough to his leg.
Oh he's AI'd to me.
Go away AI, you stink.
I fucking rolled right into that.
That's hilarious.
Oh my god, one beat his foot up.
He left his bone behind.
And his wee dreadlocks.
Oh my god.
How do you know?
It's so hard.
Whose gameplay is this?
It's shit, honestly.
I'll go for his other foot.
I'm helping, okay.
I'll just go for the other foot.
Oh you did it!
Oh my god.
Scotland forever.
Oh I hate that, I forgot about that.
I forgot about that.
I'll give you that, you win this one.
Oh my god.
Oh don't touch it, just leave it.
Will I ever do a react Andy scene?
Maybe to the Sonic Heroes dub thing in my ballpark.
I got quite a few requests for that.
P.O.B. picking up hot food.
I thought he was going to fix it there.
Oh my god.
I forgot how terrifying he is in this form.
I'm helping, I promise.
Oh.
Don't mind me getting a few telewax.
Don't mind me at all son.
What did he mind me?
I'll go for his thigh, okay.
There we go.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
I helped, I totally helped.
I got an achievement.
Defeat the fire giant.
Right, so I don't want to burn my maid, okay.
How did you, what are you doing to make yourself explode?
Okay, I don't want to hurt my maiden.
So now where do I go to get the frenzied flame?
Mummy and Wiefling.
Just completely the one in the boss which was that mummy's the Elden Lord.
Need to go back to Light and Dell.
Go deep into the sewers.
Light and Dell.
Oh god, this fucking creepy place that I hate.
Light and Dell, Avenue Balcony?
Avenue Balcony is the place you want for the sewers, okay.
Please tell me I can spawn you then.
I know where to start.
I can't spawn you then.
Cause I've already done, I'm like 9% sure I can spawn your asses in.
Not only have an enemy gate, okay.
I hope you're ready to run fast to the sewers.
I'm going to be sewer sliding.
Take me to the sewer shittling.
No, that was me.
I didn't mean about you.
I promise I did.
My brain was like ha ha sewer and ling and my brain said shittling.
I'm sorry.
I have a dry arm but we'll be close.
Oh, it's deodorant.
So did I put deodorant on or not?
I can't remember.
Yeah, I must have put deodorant on.
Okay, I'm ready. Sorry.
I was inspecting my arm put.
I was inspect elementing my arm put.
Okay, sewers, sewers.
Easy.
Take it easy.
Okay.
Uh huh.
Yes.
Faster. Here.
I'm off. I'm away.
You don't have to tell me twice.
Okay.
What's going on here? Open.
Open.
Open sesame.
Open sesame toast.
Hold on. I'm going to grab that.
I am real quick.
I think it's going to get me jumped.
Something's trying.
Okay, easy.
Easy.
Okay, where is it?
Where did you? You're so quick.
You're too fast for mommy.
Mommy can't keep up with your pace.
Please slow down.
You're too enthusiastic, little rooflin.
Oh, I spoke too soon.
Okay, I'm sorry.
You must be able to see that as well.
Right.
Let's put this light on.
What's the situation?
There's definitely stuff down there.
What are they?
Can I tingling?
No, I can't tingling here.
Um...
Hmm.
Do I just run?
Like a damn jackhammer.
Okay, well I missed that item, but it's not big deal.
Please open faster.
Oh my god.
I kind of remember.
I'm having a memory.
There's a big enemy here, but there's a room here somewhere.
Oh my god, room.
Get the rooflins in.
Send me down, send me down, send me down to reset that enemy.
So he's not freaking locked onto me.
Sit down, sit down, sit down.
Okay.
Okay, I'm sat.
I'm sat.
Don't have to tell me twice.
I have sat down to reset that enemy.
Okay, who's not had a chance?
You are my enemy guide.
Not Alessandra, you don't have a chance.
Okay, don't ever do it.
Have a damn heart attack in this game.
I think Azura is playing dead space as well.
I don't know how she's not going to have a heart attack.
Can we have a heart attack in a while?
Have you had a heart attack in a while?
I mean, nice.
You were in...
You were in a different column.
That's how long ago it was you played.
Jal da beos.
I'm not actually...
Jal da.
Big Jal da.
Big Jal da boss.
You sound like a planet like Tatooine.
Or like the other planets that I've already forgotten.
Oh.
An Overlord Reference?
Oh, I don't know that one.
Sorry, I'm hydrating.
I'm making sure I hydrate.
I want no more donals telling me to hydrate.
I'm hydrating, okay?
You don't have to give me money to hydrate.
You can just type Hydration Check, mom.
Okay.
Right, are you ready?
I'm ready.
So there's that fight with this guy.
There's two of them here.
Yeah, one there and one...
Oh god, there's three of them.
What the fuck, I don't even remember that much.
Okay, let's beat them up.
They weren't...
They were just intimidating.
I remember being really intimidated.
Right, okay.
I fucking love refunds.
Sorry, but...
It actually makes game accessible.
What more can I ask for?
I get to have experience for the first time with you.
Okay, right.
I hope you see...
Okay, rats in here.
I remember the Suraphybes.
I will clear it, fuck it, we'll clear it.
Just so we're not getting jumped from behind, you know?
Okay.
And then we need to find the frenzy.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Oh, refund, I'm sorry!
I think I almost killed you there.
Sorry, Dolphys.
Oh shit, I'm sorry, I fell down.
I don't think I was supposed to go down.
Sorry.
Tee hee.
Uh...
Yeah, I was just going to be up the basilisk.
Oh no, those aren't basilisk.
Those are just weirdos in the dark.
Oh my god, they're just ghosts.
Let me open this.
Sorry, sorry.
We are...
Batang!
Get the poopy ones.
Are they all poopy ones?
There.
They drop...
Flash? Why would they drop flash?
Trying to get another streamer friend through this labyrinth who was playing without any co-op.
Someone's was a nightmare.
Hmm...
Seems like there's a bit of a lag delay.
Okay, I'm following torch.
Jump.
That refund fell!
Wait, was that supposed to fall?
Or did I wait here for them to come around again?
Wait, how do I know if I'm supposed to jump or not?
Am I supposed to jump or not?
Come down?
Ah, fuck it, I'll come down.
We'll look at...
I'm following...
Oh, okay, well...
Nine hours of Elden Ring cover for...
I only have this endurance when it's a stream-snap game.
I get a lot of...
What would you call it?
Energy?
Okay, I get like a lot of energy.
Enthusiasm?
I don't know about that word.
From...
Huh?
I think we're all getting a bit...
Oh!
Oh, well, this is somewhere new at least.
Uh...
Right.
There's a lot of things lurking around in the dark here.
Wow!
Hold on.
Motivation?
Yeah.
Oh, uh...
Well, that wasn't supposed to happen.
Oh dear.
Okay, well, I'm glad that's gone.
Um...
She's absorbing our energy.
So, Succubus is dealing Life Force, right?
Like...
Um...
I got the delay on those slugs registering their deaths.
This is pretty fucking wacky.
Um...
Succubus is like energy, right?
But it's only taken through ink.
Yes?
Ow!
The poofy slug got me.
Oh, there's an item here.
Yeah, they steal Life Force through the ink.
Okay.
So, I steal your energy being around you?
So, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
I don't know yet.
Oh!
What?
Do you need help?
No.
No, I need help, clearly.
Leave him alone!
We even won't ink for you at any time.
That's what I like to hear.
Okay, open door.
Open...
Because it's not open. Cumin.
Okay, and then...
Can I go...
Hey!
And then I open this lever to make a comeback faster.
Something, something off your mum's teeth.
And then...
A little to the right.
And then this is downwards to the frenzied flame.
Why would it be in the sewers?
That's so random.
I guess maybe they would want to hate it's existence.
They're like, ah, well, we made this.
Let's go.
Bro, die! Jeez, he's like infinite 18.
Infinite 18.
A grace mimic.
Curious.
How could you need that?
Like vampires are different variations of the lore.
Yeah, how they live changes on...
Where?
I'm on the wrong way.
What's going on?
Oh!
Oh, and I got a smith in stone.
I got a smith in stone.
And I didn't have to do anything for it.
I got some string.
I got a warming stone.
Yeah, fuck these plants up you.
That's what we think about you.
Uh, yeah.
I remember the first time I played Elden Ring.
Those plants were the bane of my existence.
I was so bad against them.
Uh, are we just running through this?
Did you take fall damage for that?
No, you took...
Oh, there's basilisks!
Okay.
This could have gone slightly better.
I'm gonna be honest.
I'm out, I'm out.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Run, Reflings, run!
Run, Reflings.
As soon as you come in the hallway, it's safe.
It's so safe, there's a fucking...
Why would there be one here?
Go to sleep, please, permanently.
Don't ever come back, thank you.
Are they chasing us up the fucking thing?
Out.
Okay, right, I think my bottle's okay.
Is he still alive?
Oh, I missed.
I'm sorry, Reflings.
Okay, jeez.
No.
No what?
Where we go?
We go back?
Nope, I woke up that plant.
Wait, are we lost?
We finished the DLC.
We're just doing the base game again.
And we're gonna do the mad...
A little bit of madness.
Okay, we got the plant.
I think it's like 0A, I think that.
Okay, one minute!
Did we go the wrong turn?
Emmy had 50k!
Yeah!
Happy 50k, Emmy!
You're halfway to the play button.
And you smell like one too.
Congrats, Emmy.
We love you.
Okay, we're in...
Here.
I would watch but spoilers.
For the base game?
Yeah, we finished the DLC so we went back to base game.
Oh, they're all in here?
Okay, let's...
I didn't say that didn't stagger him.
Yeah, Emmy, play button, no!
Emmy, get play button, no.
I've got the special attack, I didn't do anything.
Hee hee!
All me, baby.
Golden centipede all the way.
Okay.
Oh, open door, open door.
Okay, big...
Oh, sorry.
A birthday bunny raid!
Oh, happy birthday, Serenity!
Oh, did you don't even start already?
I saw your Twitter post, did it already start?
Please pass out and rest well.
Oh, thank you so much for the read and write, Serenity.
I'm Strony from
Generation 1 and Doge from Vealor.
I'm currently doing stream sniping on Elden Ring,
so if you'd like to join, you're more than welcome.
Please don't worry, Aim.
But happy birthday, Serenity, we hope you have happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
I know she's awake to sleep right now.
I do have a five-minute subscriber
chat thing on, so don't worry
if you can't talk.
I'll talk to you though, let me talk to you.
But yeah, we are...
Oh, she's...
Oh, sorry!
Sorry, Beefland, sorry. I thought you were an enemy.
But we Elden that ring, hell yeah we are.
I'm currently being gated.
We finished the DLC.
It totally wasn't because of a glitch.
Sorry, I've just hurt you again.
We're just going to do
the base up game
because I never actually finished it.
I jumped straight to the DLC
and we're going to do the frenzied flame
right now because I don't want
to sacrifice my maiden.
Sorry, we keep absolutely tearing up this
Beefland. He's like, bruv, I've had enough.
Distracted by raid accidentally boxed.
Where's all the Beefland? Have we lost them?
Did he fall down somewhere he shouldn't have?
Did we go in this pipe?
Mario style?
You want me to go down?
I'm not going down without you going down.
I thought we had to go in that pipe or something.
Go down, you're scaring me.
Fine, I'll go down.
Kick ladder.
Oh, kick ladder.
I would not have done that if you didn't.
I kid you not, I would not have done that.
Thank you, Beefland.
The maiden will hate you for it.
But then I'll take it away
with the needle.
And so then I'll be a good little
I'll be a good
Elden Lord.
And then we're just going to do the normal ending
because I've actually never done the Elden normal one.
I always end up marrying
a Rhianna.
Rhianna, Rhianna.
They get rather large down here, don't they?
Does Milena forgive you if you cure the flame?
Rani.
Her name is Jumpover.
I don't know where that other Beefland is.
There's no way he's catching up to us.
Unless
he knows the route.
I don't know where
my second Beefland went.
The four blue hands
to touch.
Just a little lost in this maze.
Just a wee bit.
I don't know.
One of these holes are for jumping in.
I don't know what one yet.
Because I just killed that rat there.
I'm being pranked.
They're pranking me.
You need to jump down in what hole though.
I found my Beefland.
I don't know how you got here, but I found you.
This one?
Nope, they seem to...
They seem to think it's this one.
I got Flintstone.
Can I open this?
I can!
Alright, let me beat him up.
Oh, there's a basilisk.
I'm scared of it.
This one?
Again, need to leash for their
reeflings, honestly.
Mummy's lost her reeflings this stream?
No, the first time was terrible.
We could not figure out where that reefling was.
And then all of a sudden,
I'm at the boss.
What do you mean you're at the boss?
We are where the boss is.
You can't be at the boss.
That's not how it works.
I prefer when the pots look like this.
Not the meatback version.
Oh!
Oh my.
You cannot pass.
We're going to run a train on this pad reefling.
Head to our block again, this one.
Pat, pat, pat, pat.
We're all going on the lift together.
Are you clapping?
Who's making clapping noises?
Are you putting me to sleep?
I swear.
What is it called? Is it like
Samofili or something like that?
I think so.
Whoa! Reefling, no!
Okay, don't die, don't die.
Okay, touch grace.
Touch grace.
The platforming to get done is going to be fun.
Okay, this is the part I'm not
looking forward to.
Because I think this is where
it goes terribly wrong for us.
Does it not?
Rest well sleepy head.
Go sleep.
Reeflings, I need to sleep.
I don't normally stream at this time.
Oh, here he is.
Okay.
I completely
forgot all attacks this guy does.
So I'm just going for it.
I missed.
Oh, he does blood spells?
One, I'm not sure that one.
I didn't like that one.
Wait, is this not the guy that's
outside the egg?
In the star world?
Oh, jeez.
He guards the frenzied flame?
It's complicated, yeah.
I do get that impression.
Oh.
How unique.
Oh wait, blood magic.
And he does the fire one as soon as I go under it.
Oh, there we go.
We did it, we did it.
Madness, no.
I got an achievement for the
Madness.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We did it, we did it, we did it.
I'm going to touch the grace.
I don't think I can summon you for a while.
Is this the one where I open the chest
and then knock at it or something?
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to level up if I can.
I've got 600 things.
This is just his day job, honestly.
Sure, let's put my
thing up by like 5 points.
Okay, I'm like 99% sure.
Yeah, I'm not allowed to go.
I like bump this and then it goes
behind.
Is that a bump?
Yeah, okay.
And then I'm not allowed you guys
for this, but I'm like
100% sure I'm not allowed to.
Yeah, they're like all twisted and stuff.
I think there's only a few that actually
fight.
They don't want to fight or something.
Hear them.
I can't remember the...
Yeah, isn't there an item here?
Yeah, there is.
Hold on, how do I get into it?
Roll.
Oh, I can't.
I can't get the item?
Sure, whatever.
I like playing music and stuff.
Uh...
Oh, sure.
Okay, this is
not gonna go well.
This is gonna take me quite a few
days.
Is something targeting me?
I'm edging.
Gentle.
Okay, that's a good game.
Does he attack me or does he just
keep playing whilst I hang out here? Hey,
it has got me.
Praise the merchant.
He is very lovely.
Gentle.
You have to use enemies.
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe not this time for me.
Okay.
So...
So, so, so...
So, doesn't it?
Because...
This one?
Is something swinging at me?
It sounds like something's swinging at me.
Is this one right?
The corner one?
Wait, actually?
The corner one does not
look right to me.
Go down and roll onto it.
Roll onto it!
Oh, you have too much faith in me.
Roll? That looks like a jump to me.
Like...
Oh, God, and roll really that much?
Honestly,
that one looks more promising.
It's ketchup, not blood, it's fine.
Okay, okay.
Here comes the death counter.
For fuck's sake, right?
That's why we're not rolling.
I don't know why you said roll.
Okay, the death counter is one.
Surely this won't take me
to the end of the endurance stream.
Surely.
Hold six feet.
Take armor off.
Okay, naked time.
You don't have to tell me twice, right?
You, off.
Then you, off.
Then you.
There we go.
Fuck them up.
Jump down here.
There was one guy here.
I don't really care enough
to fall over that.
Oh, Jesus, I'm so fast.
I mean, it's not really
that important to me.
I have the souls, but sure.
Right, I'm going to believe you
again to roll.
You know what, fuck you. I press B.
I press B.
Okay, we're on two. That's fine.
You need to take the helmet off, too.
Wait, actually, if you
get those guys to shoot, they're fired.
Nah, that's okay.
Okay, let's try again.
That's fine.
I've got Aldi.
I don't know about you, but I have Aldi.
Right, who is squeaking
about over here? Someone is making noises.
It's you.
I can hear you.
Give up.
Grace, mimic.
I don't really know.
I'm not really bothered about his drip right now.
I can come back for it.
Right, fuck you.
How many times do I have to teach you
this lesson, old man?
Right, drop down.
Right.
Now, I'm going to do what I want to do,
which is a curve jump like that.
Yeah, take that, bitch.
Oh, no!
That went incredibly well.
All things considered.
What?
How did that work?
I don't know how that worked, but fuck it.
Okay, where'd I go next?
Corner?
Behold.
Oh, that's the furthest I've
literally ever gotten.
I don't know how I
freaking went backwards there, and it worked,
but it worked.
The furthest I've ever gotten, so progress.
Clam slam can skip
the whole segment. Wait, real?
Okay, that's three.
Okay, let's just...
Not the wrong way.
I kind of feel bad killing the same guys
over and over. I wonder if I could just leave them.
I feel like it's really mean.
Okay, well, maybe...
I think I feel rushed if I don't kill them,
so maybe I will kill them next time.
Felt a bit rushed, you know?
Whereas I can take my time.
Impatient mummy. I was trying to get to the good part
at the end.
Can you blame me?
Okay, that's fine.
He's not an enemy.
Okay, let's try that again.
Did they really say,
let's play relax and music, because we know
they're going to be wanting to shoot themselves
trying to parkour in this game?
No, you did the B thing again.
How strange. I'm not used to that. Hold on.
Hmm.
Did we test this lamb?
Do you want me to?
I don't know why they made it, like, so tricky.
The music was actually taught
then by sentry to help them sleep
in Easter suffering.
I...
What is it? Yeah, I don't...
There's no way that's going to keep me
from perishing.
Oh, the hate killed me.
I wasn't actually slamming on to something.
The hate killed me. Hold on.
I need to slam onto, like, a tomb slab thing.
Test on me in any game.
I just need something to land on.
Like, your cock.
Oh!
I was trying to look in the direction.
Okay, another time, another time.
Yeah, I need to land on something.
Drop to the bottom beams first, okay.
Just aim for a corner.
I did, and I messed up.
I'll go in the second beam.
Yeah, he knew I was coming.
As if you do that much damage.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, I took off my armor.
I took off my armor.
I forgot.
I forgot to cut off, okay.
Right, so what, like this?
And then whose corner piece is first?
Honestly, this is the only corner piece that I can see.
Should I just be trying to, like, get as low as possible
to try and bypass it all?
Like, I can do this.
Why the fuck did you move like that?
What, and then climb slam?
Alright.
No, it's too much.
Am I, am I, like, mmm.
Hmm.
Rest well, sleepyhead.
Mmm, have a good night.
Have a good night.
How do you be so nice?
Oh, I forget I'm super weak against these guys.
Hold on.
Actually scared of them now.
Actually scared of them.
Hold on.
Okay.
Whoa, can you maybe, oh, that worked out rather well somehow.
Okay, right.
Now jump over there.
Why?
That was correct.
Is it canceling immediately?
No, I'm not even getting in position to do it.
I'm, like, falling off.
Man of fellow.
Because I'm naked, I'm now scared of the merchant guys.
Which is adding to my pressure!
No! You come!
She's just so sure for you.
I am scared of the merchant, no!
Because I'm so naked.
The arseholes.
Don't look at me, I'm naked and afraid.
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, next.
No, it's not apparently.
Why did you randomly jump?
Well, I found the platform at least over here.
If I hit it.
Did it just do it with full armor on?
Is it banished now, I think?
The gauntlets of Solitude, yeah, bruv.
I'm definitely not as fast.
I spent jump for...
I just feel like I'm so heavy, though.
Fat bitch.
Sorry, I shouldn't say that.
Oh, and jump.
Sprint jump.
I definitely feel like I'm lacking critical information here.
Like, or did the developers want it to be like this?
Like this.
I mean, if they wanted it to be like this and shit, yeah, that's different, but...
Oh, and you're gonna miss it.
Okay, thanks for even attempting to touch that.
Stop the tour.
What's the death count?
I'm not even counting anymore.
Building up your madness?
Real and true, actually.
That's a really good point.
They're like, hey, we want you to do the same thing over and over again to really...
really get into the character that you're about to enter.
And I'm like, oh, okay, thanks, we're good.
And I missed.
Okay, well.
Not falling prevents taking lethal damage, real.
It's Miya...
Miya Zaki, so you're suffering as intended.
Hating the fall that kills you?
What, it's gravity?
Oh, I didn't mean that.
Well, okay.
Okay.
It's the sudden stop at the end.
I mean, yeah, that is her gravity word.
The love of gravity.
Let there be death.
Yeah, amen to that.
Go there.
Like that.
And I go...
there.
No?
Okay, or just slide off it?
Why not?
It's not like I want it to be alive down here anyway.
Giffy falling noises.
Thank you KOT Bricks for the extended membership, honestly.
Take your time and lean it up.
Yeah, lean up the fucking cockamuckers.
They're like, what the fuck is this shit?
Snapping your tentacle off at this rate.
Like...
Is that not lined up?
And then I'm gonna probably get fucking Kablamo'd off of it.
Right, run and jump.
Now I need to run and jump.
But they give me a fucking pixel fame prayer for one fucks sake.
Oh, it's just those games.
Oh, I'm so excited to play those games.
I love the way I get to hammer and run into it.
Whoa, oh my god, it turns me on.
Get teacock fun.
Oh, of course it was a corner piece.
That wasn't paying attention to fucking bastard.
Hmm.
Equipping ornaments.
You can equip up to three ornaments that time.
Okay.
Okay, I guess.
Okay, I love ornaments.
I love me a good ornament.
I don't know about you, but...
They really get the old blood going.
Hmm, line it up.
Line it up.
Back on the street.
Watch me not hit this.
I don't need to run on that one.
Then jump on that one.
And then the corner one.
First.
Okay.
And then that one.
And then the corner one.
Oh, it's not corner.
It's a lie.
That's what it is.
Don't fall for the lies.
Right.
How do I get on this one below me?
Do I just edge on it?
Do I edge on it?
I think I edge on it.
I can't listen.
I do.
Ooh, I definitely do not edge on it.
Don't edge on it.
Wherever you do it.
I do not edge.
Don't edge on it.
Was this supposed to go back to the other one
and then plop myself down?
I don't think I...
I'm not sure.
The vision was the one.
Jump towards the corner.
Rest well.
Sleepy head.
Thank you for hanging with me.
Oh, rather than this.
I'm gonna go up a look.
I'm gonna go down a look.
Then run around the look.
Then run into the corner.
Ooh, or do a little...
Ooh, wherever that was.
The game aim.
Oh, and then just don't hit that one.
Hit the coolest move you've ever done
and then just don't do anything
at the next platform.
Hee hee.
I'm a president.
And before it's only a Smith and Stone.
No, it's the next part of the story
that I want to do
because I've never done this part.
So I'm trying,
but my hands are getting really sway.
An anger?
Yes, my hands sway when I get angry.
No.
You cannot embarrass me about it.
I know my hands are sway.
I've accepted that.
I will always have sway hands.
It's just how I am.
And we missed again.
Make sure you do a flip.
So make mommy angry then.
You want to lick my hand sway?
I'm not...
I'm not sure you want that.
I get very sway when I play console.
Like controller.
But when you get mildly angry or frustrated,
this sway is like dripping.
I'm just angry.
Oh!
Hee.
Self-repricating.
I have the same issue when I get angry.
Extra spicy for a handy.
Purposely making my autistic girlfriend angry
to get extra wet handjob ASMR when?
Right now.
You can do it strong.
I believe in you.
I'm fucking doing it.
Just shake me when I watch this.
I just jumped to that one in the corner there.
Wait, it looks like it's on its own though.
Where am I supposed to jump to?
It looks...
It looks such a...
That's fine.
I didn't want to...
I didn't want to do this ending anyway.
Is your sway thing autism related yet autism?
I have permanently swayed hands and feet.
Speaking of hands,
I'm fucking gonna lick them right now.
Hold on.
Hold on. Let me wipe my hands on a fucking tissue
so I can actually grip the controller.
You can buffer the run on the spot
if you jump and hold the run button.
What?
Buffer?
Oh wow.
That is some fucking verical leap if you hold it.
I want to miss.
Whee!
Hyperhydrolysis.
Oh yeah.
Hold it.
Maybe.
Delivery catacombs.
Whee!
Oh, I'll piss off.
Ugh.
This only has autism.
What point did the number come clear?
What point you had dose?
Sorry.
Hee hee.
Okay, that went well.
That could have actually have...
No, stop pressing.
Why do you do that, honestly?
Can you identify it?
Right.
Well, if you're gonna do it, do it now.
Oh, and the one time that I do it on purpose,
it doesn't work.
Ah, right.
Then I see how it is.
Astronautism.
Jess woke up and mommy's still screaming.
Did she beat the tears?
Yeah!
I beat that boss so hard.
We pummeled that boss into the ground.
Isn't we refling?
We pummeled the DLC boss so hard.
We pummeled him so hard coming up that lift.
The way he didn't anticipate our gravity shift.
Ooh, we got him good.
We encountered the freaking co-op glitch.
Oh, you fucking bastard, honestly.
Hmm.
VodWATCH is fast forward two days.
Real, I can't even argue against that.
Actually real.
I don't know if I can do this.
I'm being honest, I genuinely don't think I can do this.
Yeah, there's a DLC glitch where if you go up the elevator,
or the lift together and co-op,
it kills the fucking boss instantly.
So we didn't even get to do the fight,
so I had to be summoned into another refling's game.
Stop going fucking backwards.
I'll literally never use that button for anything else.
And the game's like, oh, did you want to do that?
No, I didn't fucking want to do that.
You fucking bastard, honestly.
I don't know if I'm better doing this off stream,
and then I come on tomorrow when I'm at the bottom.
That's real sure.
I
have no words.
My character has never moved faster.
My character has never moved faster than the entire game.
Against any god.
Godwin, fucking morgue,
fucking Rinala,
any of these gods, nah,
she doesn't give a shit.
The moment it comes to being delicate,
fucking dainty movements,
or let's just eat myself like a fucking catapult,
right, or right then.
Make it make sense, actually.
Like, so does the dev team know exactly what I want right now,
and they're not giving me it.
I honestly didn't care what they say,
they're actually such liars, like two-faced bastards.
Oh, gon' piss off.
Alright, actually that worked out well, sorry, excuse me.
I was not familiar with your game.
My apologies!
You fucking whore!
Oh my god!
I don't even know how I did that second one.
I don't even remember ever getting there.
Right, enough with the fast movement.
Relax.
I don't know why yours like so fast.
All of a sudden thinking it's Sega.
Nah, this is Formsoft, okay?
Or Fromsoft, whatever.
Just slow it down, seriously.
I don't know why we're going 100 miles a minute.
Relax.
And now, all of a sudden,
we're going 100 miles an hour, right?
Stop moving.
We're not gonna make that jump unless you run at it,
but you need to not fucking do that backwards jump thing, okay?
Ah, progress!
Right, same as before, it's not in the fucking corner,
but don't fly at it!
Oh my god.
Okay, same as before.
Don't do the backwards fucking jump either.
I swear to god.
Oh, am I here?
Did I do it?
Oh my god.
Did I need to put my armor on?
I'm scared, I'm putting my armor on.
I don't trust this, I don't like this at all.
Can I put it on here?
I don't trust this at all.
There's like someone here that beat me up to ruin my day right at the end.
I don't know who it is, but there's some fanny here
just waiting to jump scare me.
Is it him?
Are you evil?
Am I here?
Did I make it?
Can I come down?
Go down?
Oh my god.
I don't even have any serotonin at the end of that.
Just misery.
Now it's over.
Alright, what happens in this room?
I have to remove my armor?
Sure, I'll go naked, why not?
Did I take off my weapon as well or...?
That was awful, sorry.
If you can hear me moving about, I'm flapping my hands to get them to stop sweating.
To let the air...
Don't do it!
Get fingered.
No serotonin, only misery the truth.
I'm self-experienced.
Have you spoke to Melania at the grey she scolds you, but fuck it, we roll.
Excuse me for not taking my time at that.
She can get to you fuck.
That's actually kind of scary.
Damn, she looks like me for real, for real.
Wait, so only people who get to the bottom of that are allowed to become madness people?
Or is there different... there must be different ways you can get madness.
It burns!
It hurts so good!
Hand tug.
Talked to her at the grey, oh am I getting scolded by my maiden?
Oh, is she gonna be pissed at me?
Oh look at her skin, we are burned, we literally carry the mark!
Hello!
She's gonna be pissed!
Hi, I did it to save you bitch.
I did it for you.
Yay!
Goodbye, my companion.
Goodbye, torrent.
Oh she has to leave torrent behind?
Oh that's a shame.
I did it for you, I did it for you.
I went through all of that for you, you just relax then.
I'll take it off me, okay I'll take it off me in a minute, just relax.
Did it for you!
Right, so then I go burn myself at the tree, right?
There might be enough time to be the game on stream.
Right, I go up to the ball, right?
Look at your eyes.
Oh are they glowing yellow?
Oh shit, let me take this off, hold on.
Oh yeah they are, I glow with it!
Wow.
Oh god did I forget to pick up the damn thing?
I forgot to pick up a grey sight back there.
I'm frenzied, plop plop plop plop.
You can remove the burn marks in character customization.
Oh no that don't bother me none.
One hour life for stream though?
Oh it was a tight schedule.
Wait how did I get across here?
What?
Chain, chain now.
We'll burn it and then we'll be goody goody gum drops and take it off with this needle.
Frenzied flame stones heal you now instead of causing madness?
Oh that's a good detail, I like that detail.
Oh wait I've got the wrong sword on.
This isn't my sword, I need my big peepee sword.
There we go.
Wait did I just take it off my face?
I did!
Right maybe, I don't know, take the sword out?
Still a madness spell gives you more madness though.
I suppose you could argue that too much of anything is bad for you, even if what a part of you is.
There's not a fight here, is there if there is already for gore?
Is there a fight here?
No, there can't be, there's not a save station.
Come on I'm torn.
Where do I burn myself?
Is it at the age of it?
Or is it the right side or the left side?
I can never remember.
Oh this side.
Left side.
There's never a thing such as too much moume?
I guess if we don't finish today then tomorrow can be a shorter stream and I can do some behind the scenes work which is not a problem.
The madness and juicing ASMR.
Torrent!
You're wet fart, you got me nervous.
Right, can I sacrifice myself here?
Listen to the sound of flame?
That sounds like it to me.
Time to burn.
Call me big rabbit cos I'm about to burn.
After the poet Robert Burns.
I offer myself unto thee.
It definitely sounds like madness in there.
I should have taken my clothes off.
Am I going to burn alive?
Yeah.
Okay where do we go for the needle?
I like how I just don't say anything.
I'm just happy to be here.
Hmm?
If I put my body in there how am I still being chillin'?
You died? Yeah hell yeah I died cos literally what?
The flame keeps you alive.
Oh the frenzied.
Why get rid of it now?
Because I don't want the world to end.
I want it to save my maiden.
Oh god we're in the dragon place now?
Church of the Plague in Caled.
Dragon Disney.
I need to find a...
Okay I'll find the first save thing in my Bulber.
Can I turn on this? Thank you.
Right we'll go to Caled. I just need to find a grey site.
Can I have one grey site please?
Whoa.
Okay I knew it was this way.
I didn't realise there were that many gaps.
Where's the grey site?
Azula?
Not Azur or Duly?
The hit VTuber for Gen 1 indulge?
Can I run through this? Surely.
I'm sure it's fine.
I'm off.
Little bit of bloodlust never hurt anyone.
Yes I'm going to sit down. Leave me alone.
Leave me alone. No let me sit down.
What?
You guys are such liars right now.
Be so free all.
I'm literally not allowed to sit down.
I'm getting fucking gang violence.
Oh piss off bro I got it.
Did I hit it?
I just wouldn't let me sit down.
Whatever.
At least I had to do that.
Right we've got our first thing.
So I need to go to Caled's womb.
What was it? The church?
A church? This church?
Church of ruins?
I want church of the plague.
Wait why can't I?
You cannot travel to a site of grace right now.
Why not?
What have I done?
What have I done to deserve this fate?
Rest first. Okay rest.
You need to rest.
How did you know that?
Last time?
Yeah sure until it's on me.
Okay.
How did you know that?
That was very strange.
What was it? The church of the plague?
The church of the plague?
Caled, how are we so free?
Caled, how are we?
Smothering wall, Caled ruins.
I don't seem to have a lot of the...
Astray?
Astray from Caled, how are we doing?
But yeah.
Tomorrow we'll finish the base game.
I can't believe I'm saying that after finishing the DLC.
But yeah we'll...
No no not that one, the other one.
No no, not that helper.
These helpers.
Okay there's no helpers.
Astray...
Has anyone able to play?
Is everyone asleep?
I willed it too hard all the refunds are asleep.
Astray from Caled, how are we?
Or is it only one?
Follow the path around the swamp
to the gates of the shack on the right?
I have to do this on my own.
Follow around the thing
and then there'll be a shack on the right.
This way?
No no, go sleep, rest well.
Thank you for hanging, go all the way to the right.
And a shack over here.
Big shack.
Are those flowers attacking me?
The sun's attacking me.
That's no fucking me.
I need to kill the commander.
There's a shack, oh I found a shack.
Big shack here, just won't talk about you.
I'd rather run down if I do say so myself.
I've got crab eggs.
Okay now that man at the shack won't.
Fine shack, spam talk to get every wrong shack.
Okay let's try again.
Please don't have a random dragon attack me.
Commander should be done first
if you want to skip one part of the quest.
I know where the shack is, oh it's clearly here.
By the smithing stones.
Is that attacking me?
The middle of the swamp?
Is where the commander, I can't open the map
because that thing's pretending to attack me.
Really?
Go away.
I assume this is the middle.
Are you the middle of the lake?
Something's coming out of the lake.
Naughty boy.
You're naughty yes you are.
Get out of here.
I want my reeflings and you stand in the way.
The shack is in the middle of the swamp.
Can I open up at now?
This?
The shack is in the middle of the swamp.
Any swamp enthusiasts?
By the way I'm comforting myself
when I say those words.
I am not mocking you
for telling me what to do.
I am comforting myself
because the shack is in the middle of the swamp.
Oh well.
I wasn't supposed to happen.
Can you piss off?
Why did you take me off my horse?
My listen?
Can you come up and fight me here?
Just so I don't get reticid?
Can you climb up?
Thank you.
Thanks I appreciate it bro.
No no.
It's all good.
Thanks bro, I appreciate it.
Can you come back up again?
You cheeky bitch!
You cheeky fuck.
Go to sleep.
Alright, okay.
Don't do that again.
Don't make me fight or mourn again.
Commander in Swamp Shack
is on the right of the path
past the giant
on Clifftop
past the hillhounds.
This?
Is it that guy?
I seem to recall something here.
Whoa! Ow ow ow!
Get me out of here.
I seem to recall
a strange man in a shack.
I'll piss off O'Neil, no one cares.
Ah jeez Louise,
can I get out of here?
Oh brother.
Yeah I know I'm in Caled.
Have you seen the place I'm in?
Of course I'm in Caled.
Alright follow the blue line.
Oh you need to kill that boss?
Oh for fuck's sake.
Alright alright alright alright
alright I'll go kill him.
I'm so strong
and I'm so
brave.
I am not afraid.
Where is he?
Are you O'Neil?
O'Neil?
O'Neil!
Where are you?
I've lost you.
Wait, what?
Did I just hear a Weflin symbol?
I did! What the fuck?
Why do you snipe me so well?
And you come?
Wait what?
You're an NPC, you're not a Weflin.
What do you help me fight?
Adopted daughter?
What do you do?
I need to go north.
Wait.
But you are a Weflin.
How the fuck are you sniping like that?
That's insane.
I'm like going like crazy all over the map.
This is a boss room?
Turn around?
What south?
Oh I found him!
I found him!
He's here. Oh I'm standing on the scarlet rock.
Sorry.
Yeah piece of ghost.
Oh I missed.
Whoa.
I'm at heals.
I'm at stamina, not heals. I've got 11 heals.
I've got enough heals to deal with her.
Oh my god.
Oh I'm getting scarlet rotted up.
Joint.
Oh she got a crit on him!
Oh I missed.
That was too late.
Oh my god.
Commander meal?
More like
commander
banana peel.
Cause you slipped and fell in your face and died instantly.
Okay and then now I go to the man?
I go to the man in the shack.
Oh did you leave me something?
What did you leave me?
Obsidian
What weapon is that?
An obsidian.
I can hardly hold anything you guys are gifting me.
I'm just so small and cute and oo-woo.
And it's totally not because I've not
levelled up these particular attributes.
Oo-woo.
Big check.
Okay now I speak to the man.
Hello I would like to be cured of the frenzied flame
and I know you know how to do it.
So let's not beat around the bush.
So your little guard dog doesn't scare me.
Fuck you.
See that? Shit guard dog, you need a new one.
I remember that dog cause it scared me.
The way he's sitting.
Are you okay?
Gary.
My ilk?
What is an ilk?
Boom.
Okay.
Here are the requests.
Your ilk.
Your cane. Your level.
It's Sir Albert's weapon
that gets you a quest lane.
It has two so I figured to give you the second one.
Oh!
Speed me around.
Right Danny go see that lady.
Am I summoning to use in for this bit?
Okay I'll just summon you cause I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh!
I already got the needle.
Don't summon.
Oh shit.
You'll need to reload the area.
Sorry Phoenix.
Well thank you for the de-spawn.
That old craftsman
who grasps the essence of life.
Can you give me some time?
Sorry I'll get you in.
No.
Can you give me some time with this?
As well made as it is.
Okay so now that he says snap in half
quit and reload.
Like come back to him.
To the tail menu?
I mean shit.
I just listened to what you see.
Yes refling.
Anything else refling?
Dropped it before I realized she was gonna
play it with her.
Okay now he's giving me new dialogue.
Give me dialogue now.
Hello! New dialogue please.
Yes yes.
Okay now what to do with the needle?
After this travel to the church of the plague.
Church of the plague.
Oh!
Are you alright bestie?
God damn you some fuck up.
Actually I have something for you.
Give the alloyed needle.
An alloyed guild needle.
Give her that needle then rest.
Yeah go for it.
Yeah sure.
I don't know magic or something.
I don't know it's just the lore.
Okay don't question Elden Ring lore.
It's too difficult.
Yeah sure sorry.
It's a video game.
It's not me.
Well that was easier than expected.
But why do I feel so...
So what?
Is she okay?
I think I made her worse.
I would like to pass the time until morning.
Oh you're standing.
How do you feel?
Hi.
I hope to see you again.
For when last we met.
I fainted before I could even thank you.
Everything is as you said.
Since inserting the needle
with scarlet rot
has ceased to ride.
Even the nightmares have abated.
And now
though I can scarcely believe it myself.
I can move as I please.
Not that I could ever truly repay you.
I would like you to have this.
By way of thanks.
Try arms but you don't have the right...
After this dialogue rest at the grace
and then go back to the shack.
Time for the shack.
It's not raining today.
Oh shit she gone.
Oh right.
You can't just teleport to the shack.
I rageous have to
actually walk a little bit
in this game.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Like down this.
Are you squinting me right now?
I give to go sailing for a couple of days soon.
Yeah?
Time sailing without anyone else around.
I am really looking forward to it.
Make sure you have the safety precautions alright?
Like
the tracker thing
and it like pings your location
at someone and stuff. Right last rabbit?
Thank you for the super chat.
But you got the safety precautions right?
Don't make me nervous.
I'll cry.
You are doing the safety stuff right?
Whoa whoa whoa!
Now give me the fuck out of here.
How did I go down?
Is there a way down?
What's the fuck? How do I go down?
Oh here we go.
Be safe when you sail.
Excuse me Mr. B.
Apparently you killed...
What? I killed it like half an hour ago?
Silly.
If you just teleport to this one.
Probably.
I hope you have fun though.
But definitely be safe.
Make sure someone got your
location. I think they have those GPS
tracker things.
Oh here. Oh the guy is gone now.
What's up hen?
Hello again.
My butt cheeks are sore.
Oh but he's not here.
Okay good. We got a safety thing.
I'm happy. Okay I hope you enjoy your sail
and last rabbit. Thank you again for the tip.
Exhaust her dialogue.
I'll massage her for you mummy.
I like so fucking sore.
Yeah you're gonna stay strong.
Okay she wants to stay strong.
After this go
to a place near Stargate's
hill site of grace.
Which is Kaelit?
Cheese is sore but I don't know
what it is.
Altus plateau.
Is that the underground map
thingy my bobber?
Erd tree grazing hill site of
grace in Altus.
We've got about 50 minutes left.
North? Here?
No it's not Altus.
Oh wait wait wait this?
No.
West of
Lindell.
Erd one of these ones.
Altus plateau.
For Vinlands.
Ba ba ba ba ba.
Harrow wall, hermit shark.
That's one of these genes isn't it?
We Altus.
What the fuck is it?
Capital rampart?
Where the fuck is it? It's here.
You, you, no Avenue balcony.
Shit.
And the other shadowy part of the map?
Where? You have
you have the Altus highway junction?
Where is it?
Bro this must be so annoying.
More to the left, okay.
These are water.
I have the windmill.
Outer wall battle. Outer wall fountain tree.
I'm still going strong after 10 hours.
Abandoned coffin.
I'll get there.
I'm getting close.
I'm getting warmer.
I'm just getting warmer.
Altus.
What the fuck is it?
You're just on an urge tree grazing hill?
This?
I like making you work right?
See how worked up and frustrated you're getting
when I was edging over it?
Yeah that's what I'm gonna do to you tonight.
I'm gonna fuck you up.
Right what do I do here?
I don't know what to do here.
Up the hill. Up the hill.
Did I just go on my horse?
Maybe a refling gate?
You don't have to fucking tell me
to ice tingling.
I'm in.
Enemy refling.
Shlumpling.
I've got an enemy.
Am I not allowed to eat nice reflings?
It's called me a cliff because I'd be edging.
I'd click victims for everything in the way.
I've got my baggage reels in the way.
Hydration check.
I'm gonna stop at the VOD limit
and we'll finish it tomorrow.
What that means is
Monday originally was gonna be Elden Ring
but I didn't realise how
how much you guys
were gonna carry me through the game.
Oh no I can't have a wholesome refling.
Have a well behaved boy.
Monday originally was gonna be Elden Ring
but it's not. I'll get swapped out now.
There's water and whiskey right?
Yes there's technically.
Are you getting steaming?
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Give me a minute.
I'm spawning in reflings.
You're still impatient.
Mister.
Okay, I don't see any other marks
so I guess that's it.
I don't know.
It may not be working so well
especially because of how long the incense
is going on.
I wish I had a pizza.
Oh hello.
We're doing it again.
Yes, you feel better.
Yeah, yeah.
I saw it.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Oh sorry.
Wait, does she want to perish her?
Because of the scarlet well?
Okay, baby.
Why are you looking at her?
Where are we going now?
After this dialogue you'll need to make your way
to a poison castle
and get an armed prosthesis for her.
I too enjoy good prosthesis.
Perhaps even
some sort of chicken nugget prosthesis
will do just fine.
How do we feel
about the level of chicken nugget
that NPC is?
Should she be more
or less of a chicken nugget?
Where did you just go?
Oh, sorry.
For no particular reason
I will inquire about this.
How long does stream have left?
Very unfortunately
less than 50 minutes.
So we are playing Elden Ring Tomorrow base game.
Oh yeah, piss.
No, I'm no dealing with that.
That's not my problem.
One can always be more of a chicken nugget.
Oh, well that refland said
excuse me.
Candy.
What are you?
That certainly doesn't look friendly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, get fucked.
You're scaring me.
Where did he come from?
Did he jump up?
Oh my god, where did I go?
I'm scared.
Oh, are you going to be okay?
Okay, we're okay.
Follow the refland following.
The refland, the refland, the refland.
If it's a boy, are they a chicken tender?
How do you feel about a chicken nugget?
If...
Whoa, that thing can move.
Do you need assistance?
Hold on.
Okay, he got an ultimate hit.
Maybe a chicken tender.
Okay, right, no more chicken nuggets.
I'm going to run out.
That's right, that's right.
I bring it up, but then I say no, no, no more.
Bad refland.
Are you a machine?
Not just like playing games with you.
Oh, Castello, I'm getting a memory.
I'm getting a memory of being
taking around all sorts of locations
in this castle.
I'm getting a distant memory
of being carried through this area.
I'm being carried through this area.
Oh, how...
Oh, this refland found it.
Oh, how history repeats itself
in a good way.
Okay, this is the entrance.
Naughty.
Beholds.
Ah, Gracie!
Gracie?
A fried chicken?
Prosthesis is in a chest
behind a clear rot night.
I think I killed shaded castle rampant.
Okay, calm down.
Sweet chariot.
Coming for to carry on.
Come on.
My voice is really starting to hurt.
I'm so sorry.
I'm trying to not talk
at the same time.
Is it blabbermouth?
I'm such a blabbermouth.
Hmm.
I appreciate the community.
My refland.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you, refland.
Oh, whoa, sorry.
Sorry, too busy getting my ego stroke
there to see the anime.
Alright, we're going to take a lift.
We love your blabbering.
If I could get my audio to not peak,
then I would save my streams
or like peak, like falling asleep stuff.
But...
Yeah, no, it's when I...
I just want to get a little bit...
Okay, so there's an enemy up ahead.
Got it.
This?
Go to sleep.
Go to sleep. Go to sleep.
Close enough.
Oh!
I've been impaled by the scarlet reticcy.
Hold on.
I'll let you finish them off.
If I can scarlet rot, scarlet rot.
Yes, please.
Jeez.
What's that?
It's creed.
It heals?
What is it? Oh, it must heal.
Hmm, I feel it inside me.
I'm healing. I'm healing.
Whoa!
You're a bird all along?
Flying.
Hello!
Oh!
Okay, we got the arm.
Then I teleport back to her.
Or are we just manually walking?
After getting the arm,
go back to where you found her before
and get her the arm.
But in the field, right?
Not like back at the
church where we
found her all mangled and stuff
and really keeping her alive because they were...
I don't know, they were preying the rot
inside of her?
I'm not sure.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Okay, okay.
Okay!
Wee!
Hmm, Danny, if I...
Kind of looks like a...
Okay, that was a terrible miss.
A swing in a miss!
Whoa!
Alright, get off that
fucking high horse. Jesus.
Right now, I'm out.
I'm skipping. I'm skipping.
Why are you moving?
Why is it so slow? Am I being trolled right now?
Why is that so slow?
I mean, I didn't get poisoned.
Oh yeah, piss.
Are we supposed to do this?
Okay.
Whoa, that was a good one.
That was a good one.
Good attack, good attack.
What is this?
I have an item.
Rotgris.
You tried running in knee deep surge.
Oh!
You tried running in knee. It was Lucy's idea.
He's getting dragged off it.
Oh, he's getting beaten the fuck up.
They said, nah, we're not letting you escape.
You entered the space window.
I can't open up the map
to show you where I am.
To call in a new reflim.
No working.
Whoa!
You scared me.
Wow!
They're not going to talk to you.
Hello.
How's Marias is ruined?
Just deserts for
falling for the severed harpy.
No surprise that Gilly Cretan took the castle
and her
storied sword.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
You're too quick for me.
I know the Vod.
I know we have to think of the Vod.
Please, someone think of the Vod.
I know.
We're playing tomorrow.
We have more time. We can play tomorrow.
Much better time for everyone
because I don't normally stream at this time.
I'll tell you, for the last 20 minutes
we'll read marshmallows
in a nice and cosy deal.
I'll put my blankie around me
and get ready to sleep.
Okay, very interesting attack pattern.
Please don't do that again.
Yep, no poise, get wrecked.
Thank you.
How well the reflins...
We've finished the DLC.
We've gone back to base game
and I haven't done before.
I've kept
my maid in alive
and we're just trying to undo the frenzied flame.
We seem to be
doing pretty alright.
No, stop
locking onto the reflin. He's a guide, okay?
Okay, here we go.
It's rather lonely
when it's just the three of us.
Hokusha, sleep on that thing
the big comfy match.
Honestly.
No, honestly.
Okay, we're healing.
Oh, this is the boss fight
I've ever seen one.
I'm sure
this reflin will carry me, right?
This reflin will carry me.
Yeah, nice part is tomorrow
you can take your time and enjoy more.
Okay, this will be fine.
No pressure on the other
refling at all.
No pressure.
Oh.
That reflin's had enough.
What a strange attack.
Force the head with a magic sword.
Thank you, reflin, for your sacrifice.
You know you can just use the finger, right?
You do this every time.
Okay, what are you?
What are you?
Oh my god, I'm destroying the dainan table.
Do you know how much all that would have caused?
Fuck you, I have the bigger sword.
Oh my god.
It's a rave.
I'm out of stamina, hold on.
Hold on, I'm out of stamina.
I can't even save him.
Yeah, take that.
Elmer of the briar, more like
Elmer of the friar
because you'll be working in an efficient chip shop
after this job.
You'll get fired.
I got it, I got it.
I touched the grace.
Now what?
I got an achievement for that.
Oh my god, reflin turned into a tree
of one sort, a phoenix.
Did I do that?
Get created on.
Look at the painting, it's so pretty.
Alright.
Go to quest, go back to
on the stargazing hill.
Oh yeah, it's okay.
Stargazing.
Let's go.
Attu's plateau.
A bit of a plateau by you.
Of course.
Oh wait, she was like right here.
She was like very cool spy.
I don't think I need a torrent for that, hello.
Give her.
Yeah, sure, sure.
I don't really have much of a use for it.
It doesn't really feel like someone else is doing anything.
Defeats the purpose of
having another arm available.
It's possible for me to wield a sword again.
Yeah, if you want, sure.
If the arm serves,
it might be possible perhaps,
then I can aid you in battle.
Yeah, if you'd like.
If the arm, it might be possible perhaps then.
Okay, go to windmill village next.
Where was the windmill village?
Windmill village.
Need a hand.
Give her a round of applause.
Clap, clap, clap.
Is she here?
I don't seem to see her.
Is she propped against something?
Some in the reeflands?
Oh, there we go.
Fanix, she never got a shot.
Mitra's disciple?
You're not an NPC.
You're just fucking with me though.
I like the name like that.
She's near the end of the village.
Like, off into it.
And then, naughty, refling,
slips, and I just had to use her belly.
I swear, you give off NPC vibes,
and you're not though.
No, no NPC would move like that.
It's just the name.
It's just something the game would put in.
Right, we don't need to hurt the ladies
if they don't hurt us, you know?
Come, come, come.
Let us go together.
Okay, let's go together.
After boss, fight, talk to her,
and then it'll be a while before you see her again.
Or you'll need to get access to Makayla,
which you'll need to find the medallion.
Oh, are you okay, dar?
Well, crazy over there.
Right, they don't attack us,
so there's no point in putting them.
They seem happy as long as they're flourishing.
The next part will take too long.
Okay, I'm okay to read marshmallows for the rest then.
Whoa!
What did we do to annoy them?
Whoa, why are their eyes red?
I didn't do anything!
I don't know why they go aggressive.
That wasn't fun.
Okay, we'll read marshmallows after this bit, then.
Two lovers.
Am I supposed to summon her here or something?
Or am I just to kill this boss?
Uh, did I kill the boss?
No, it's just to fight.
Okay, right, I don't need to summon her.
But we'll get madness going.
That's right, pop, pop, pop, get madness.
Ooh, straight charm, strong.
Okay.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, enemy fell.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, get pop.
This is a celebration of madness.
It looks really good.
Like the...
Why are you kneeling?
We won!
Uh, then what?
The lady appears at the shack.
Do I need to reload the rest at the grace and then she'll show up?
Okay.
Pass time.
To the morning.
Just when it's not that hard, if I said.
How long is this stream?
Uh, the vod's about to expire in 20 minutes.
Are we gonna go between me?
Oh, there she is.
Hello.
Hi.
Now look at your arm.
Is it gorgeous?
Yeah, you like it.
Aw, that's lovely.
Oh, I've got a little tingling.
Got one more for Eep, time to relax.
An expression like that.
Okay.
Is that us?
I'm so Eepy.
I'm very happy to say tomorrow's stream is probably just a regular two hour stream.
Uh, I don't...
I think we can progress.
We're talking to her here.
There is one more fast step.
Travel to ancient Snow Valley ruins and talk to her there.
Mm-hmm.
Do I have that unlocked?
I don't think I have that unlocked.
The...
Ancient...
Ancient Snow Valley ruins and talk to her there.
Okay.
To the mountain, to the top.
Oh, jeez, you are right on a high.
Yes.
I'm on Google trying to finish your quest line, darling.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Do I have the medallions?
This for here?
Oh, is that what you're saying?
I don't have enough time to do it?
Mm-hmm.
Is it Marshmallow time?
Do medallions next time?
Okay, we'll do medallions tomorrow.
Yeah, I'll take like 32 minutes.
My body hurts.
I'm gonna try and stretch though.
Okay.
No, I'm not tired.
Okay, I'm a little tired.
Well, there isn't a pause in this game,
because that would be too convenient.
We're 35 hours into this file.
Quit the game.
Yes, I want to quit the game.
I will play it tomorrow.
I'll make myself feel big.
Be big strength.
Okay, let me rid some marshmallows.
35, and you already beat the DLC?
I got carried.
I got all my items gifted and everything,
so please don't think I'm good.
Big man.
Big.
Next stream, we just found the
Albina Eric women?
What?
There's far too many vowels for my main
to be written right now.
Hey, mommy, wishing the Elden Ring was cross-played
so I could have played with you. I'm sorry.
Also, please make a cut with you.
I want to feel warmth from being here.
Can I be the
the big spoon,
and then I'll hug you from behind,
and I'll hold on to your tummy?
Am I allowed to do that? Huh?
I want to do that.
I want to hold on to your belly
from behind.
She carried us
as if you carried me. Are you joking?
Thank you for the long stream cutters
I've been watching since I began. How are you awake?
And I've been in and out of
consciousness as I deal with the flow.
I did catch you talking about giving
a show for the delivery guy.
I did not give a show for this delivery guy.
I bet that would have healed me right away.
I hope you feel better soon. Try your best
to hydrate. That is how you
fight viruses most efficiently.
The more watery your
blood is, the better.
The white blood cells get
the virus. You're welcome.
That's a very big oversimplification
of what actually happens.
My tummy's all chubby.
You don't know?
I like
big bellies. I like
big bellies and I cannot lie.
Have a good rest. Love you.
I love you too. Make sure you get rest too.
I love mommy. I want mommy.
Hugs with mommy. Cuddles with mommy.
Nuzzles with mommy. Hugs and kisses
with mommy. I want mommy to tell me
she loves us on the telephone.
I love you. I love you. I love you.
Please just R.
That went
exactly
Thank you
Nogan for the 20 gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught it with your face.
Those were kind of you, Nogan.
Thank you.
It was
a beautiful gifted membership.
Did you beat the DLC? Oh yeah.
I beat the crap out of that boss.
Well, it's not big
but like it's 20.
Yeah. I'll make it bigger.
Thank you again,
Nogan, for the 20 gifted
and Mass for the gifted earlier.
That was insane.
Mommy, please just R.
with the hic at me already. Consensually of course.
Why of course?
Mommy, I'm coming tomorrow.
We do even
more stream sniping tomorrow.
This might be a stretch, but is Reefling
a reference to something?
You're my Reefling.
Just because it was
spelt like another streamer's
audience doesn't mean it's the same.
You're my Reefling.
Okay, Mommy, I had
an idea. What if for your audience,
you had them connected by having
you always doing something
factual at various jobs
and the reason Strony has to keep getting new jobs
is for being actually inappropriate
towards the customers and managers
to keep running
into the listener at every new job.
Strony Audio Universe,
Strony Strony Audio Universe,
Strony Audio Universe, if you will.
Not totally different, just like a winky dink.
Completely winky dink.
To add to my
degenerate sleep fantasy,
hold on a minute.
You'd wake up to the smell of breakfast that I
cooked for us so you could have another healthy
meal.
Yeah, you like stream sniping
on the weekends?
Aw, did you
like it on the weekend? I picked the weekend
because I knew more people would be available
for this game on the weekend, although Elden Ring
is a rather expensive game I have to admit.
It's not exactly the cheapest
stream snip game I've done so far. Hydration check.
Strony Audio Universe must be a wonderful play.
What a wonderful play.
Dear Cuttle Pop, yesterday's stream
was a technical gun.
The most of my both stream and my system.
I want to...
I can't read that. Are you... Reflin!
You can't say all of that
and then go also, how's the Diary?
I love you. Right, Reflin, you're done.
You're done.
You're actually in trouble.
Thank you reluctantly saying for the tip.
Fucking
what an ending.
I was like, goes into war.
Live and do it any way you like.
I'm allowed to do whatever I want to this Reflin.
By the way, how's the Diary?
One? How dare you? Two? Alright then.
I wanted to play Elden Ring with you today
but haven't started the DLC. I'll definitely try and help tomorrow.
Hopefully I can kill Malania for it.
Yes, we're doing base
only now.
You know, I need to try and fit the base.
We're speedrunning
for your freedom. No!
I literally planned Elden Ring for three more days.
That's how long I thought it was going to take.
I didn't realise how much you guys were going to be
able to fucking
carry me. That was like
insane.
I didn't expect it
at all.
You already did it.
Good thing I've got a big barely.
Also, this is from the same Reflin that wanted to be held since
I couldn't join you in Elden Ring due to cross play.
Man, fuck cross play.
Me and my Reflins hate cross play. We just
want to play play.
I unlocked a new emoji slot.
Wait, do I even have anything on my desktop
that can...
Can I use a picture?
I'm sorry, I'm so white right now.
I'm so pale.
Wait, do I even have a picture?
I have a picture of Sin Sister.
I'll just put a random picture of that on it.
I can put you in your wee chain.
Hold on, wait, this might work?
I don't know if this is going to work. Hold on.
Bear with me.
This is going to be a really
soft emoji, but it's going to be worth it.
Hold on. That was my PC.
That was my PC. Hold on.
I want to see how fast this works.
How fast does that work in chat?
It says changes saved. If you refresh,
can you see a new emote up?
Just literally a random cinema.
That was Ms.
Muzz.
I'm not sure if you can see it. It might not work.
But we got a new...
Oh, it worked! Oh my god, it worked.
What the fuck? It was so quick.
It had to be squished really awkwardly
to get it to accept the files.
Let's see.
Thanks for the full day of entertainment. Love you and see you tomorrow.
I'll see you tomorrow. Love you too, Evelyn.
Thank you for hanging in.
I understand. It was very, very long.
Love you lots and lots. No, I love you lots and lots.
Your dedication is
admirable
and I adore your passion and love for the reef.
Big hugs and well wishes. Hope you get some good rest.
Yeah, I'm going to get beaks and beaks.
Love you. Love you too.
Oh, by the way.
No, go away.
I'm not reading that.
Yes, you can be the big spin mummy.
I'd love it.
Yeah.
It's funny love.
Be sure to rest.
Nori love.
Any recommendations for gamers up?
I'm trying gamers up for the first time in a membership stream.
So I'll be able to actually tell you
what flavors I recommend the most.
I'm going to like rank the flavors.
So it's going to be like a weird hand cam stream.
Half not half on.
Mum, may I selfishly request
another sample of you making the very realistic
sound using your finger and saliva?
Maybe.
Thank you for the stream mum.
I'm going to go ink myself to you now.
Okay. Well, you said it.
You said how it was. Thank you.
I'm going to miss you a lot.
Get huggies.
I'm a pirate, but even pirates need hugs.
Yes.
If you're the big spin,
we have hum in our ears to help us fall asleep.
If you won,
I would sing
Legend of Zelda. It's a classic.
I've completely
forgotten the sound of Legend of Zelda
because Elden Ring is currently in my ears right now.
What's that? Oh god.
Wait.
That one?
It's a little bit nicer.
Obviously my voice isn't fried,
but it's a little bit fried right now.
You know, sometimes talking
for over 16 hours will do that to you.
Because I was having to communicate to the team
before my stream started, you know.
Oh, someone asked that.
Oh my god. Someone asked that and I never answered.
Someone asked,
is it hard to bring new people into the team?
Yes, it is next time possible.
It is incredibly hard to find.
Trustworthy people
that
aren't trying to groom the girls.
So I have to
basically use people with extensive portfolios
or
work history, etc.
You know what, I just did the same.
Love that the codes give free shipping right now.
Yeah, if you want to test out,
you can get free shipping gold.
If you're the big spin,
would you kindly give this refill?
No, she can reach around. Please and thank you.
Since she said please.
I'm still here enjoying the stream.
I forgot to do a main story
on my new game plus character.
So I'm going to catch up and be shy tomorrow.
Love you to be slim.
Yeah, don't be shy to stream snipe.
I ain't going to beat you up.
And if you die, please don't be embarrassed.
I literally cannot even play this game.
I will say it again.
If it wasn't for you,
yes, you right now listening
to this, I would be incapable
of playing this game.
This game would be locked away from me due to skill.
And no, I'm not embarrassed
to admit it. No.
It does not upset me to admit
that I can't play this game on my own.
It is the truth.
And it's
very nice that we can play it together.
It's subnautica stream snipe.
You're saying subnautica is a riot.
Is it multiplayer?
Or did I misunderstand your sentence
and I just got excited?
No, it's not.
Just taken.
You got my hopes up there.
Could you hear it in my voice?
I was like, I stream snipe.
Okay, sorry.
There's the mod, but no.
Time to go, mommy got anime towards you.
Rest well, enjoy your anime.
Are you squinting me right now?
Love you, mama.
Wishing you a big hug.
I can't really hug this microphone.
At least with the 3D, I can prove I'm hugging it
because I can make you listen to my heart.
Which is proof that I'm hugging.
Thank you anonymous for the tips.
I'll be back.
Wow, wow, wow.
I fixed the trainer wiefling so it doesn't have
a strange box around it.
Wait, you already fixed the ammo?
Second?
Oh my god.
Wait, no, it has to be like the same...
What's the word?
The same width and height or YouTube don't accept it?
I don't know how to explain it.
It has to be the same width or height
or YouTube says no.
Go away.
Wait.
You already did it right? What the heck?
No, no, you didn't get it right.
The aspect image ratio has to be
one for one, unfortunately,
or else it doesn't work out.
So you're getting squished up wiefling chain
and won't get rekt.
And you'll like it, okay?
Extensive portfolio.
What if I forget project management?
There's main different industries.
We don't actually need any more staff right now.
We might need staff for expanding engine too.
I don't know. It depends what happens.
So I'm still streaming every day for a year.
I don't know when Gen 2 pop out.
I'm probably not streaming every single day.
I don't know.
We'll see what happens.
If Gen 2
just happened to be completely
independent creators that thrive,
then, well, I don't really need
to take any dudes off.
Because
we're getting a manager
and the audio manager's in place.
My only responsibilities
are going to be whittled down to
do you want to help with scripts, yes or no?
Do you want to help with content analysis, yes or no?
That's literally me.
As for what we need for Gen 2,
I have
a second manager just in case,
but obviously
with this is the way it works.
I need an audio editor that I need.
I need an audio editor that's already got
history and proof that they edit.
And the problem is, it's so rare
to have ASMR audio
experiencing edit.
It's so rare in a portfolio.
So it's next impossible to find people
and it's next impossible to get hired
for such a niche unless you offered
your services. The only thing I can
think of to expand your portfolio
into what we need
is you offer
for
a smaller creator that might not have time
to edit their own ASMRs or whatever.
Just offer it and be like,
I'm looking for experience because I'm looking
to get hired in the ASMR thingy
and I want to offer it for free and see how it goes.
That's the only way I can see what I need.
But I need audio editors
both for ASMR and both for regular
audio roleplay.
So we should remember
to savor the daily stream.
It depends.
So if Gen 2
happens to be fully
independent
or
they're not needy, they know what to do next,
they know how to analyse content
then really
I'm next to useless.
At this point in time, I have
scripts to write for Shibi and
Amy
on YouTube in some shorts
and that's literally it.
That's all my background
work right now.
Because the audio
Patreon person has come in, like audio manager
I don't know what you want to call them.
So if Gen 2
came on and they were like,
I need this, I would like this, I would like that.
That's different.
That would be like, well
I need to...
Shani don't say you're useless.
Not useless in that way, just like
there's no thing for me to do.
Sorry, I'm probably not the best at articulating
what I need to say right now.
I know, shocking.
12 hour stream, been up since midnight
and I unable to articulate myself
well, who would've guessed?
Hi Cuddles, your model's so expressive.
Are you still running non-calibrated
to your face? Yeah.
I still haven't done it.
I'm sorry.
It's not calibrated to my face.
I can do a lot.
I still frog blink because I didn't calibrate
the eyes, that's why I randomly
frog blink. Even though
I'm not frog blinking in your life.
It's okay, we get you.
Mummy, it's almost time limit. What's the time limit?
55 minutes?
So it only gets better?
Yeah, basically.
One minute,
there was a joke about the gooch being called
a backboard and you seem confused.
So here's examples.
Wait, what? You sent me a picture of your asshole?
Wait, it's an MP4 file?
Did you send me a video
of your arse? Be honest, Riflin.
Oh, it's Hentai.
Okay.
I just went straight for that.
There's no other logical explanation
to what this cat box file is.
It has to be you. It was Hentai.
Sorry about that, Riflin.
Sorry.
My apologies.
Are you disappointed or relieved?
I was scared, but I still opened up the file anyway.
Always look at it.
It was just Hentai.
Why do you think of lollipops?
My shells!
They're transparent and perilous
and they change colour
and they hue shift and all that.
Although they might not do it when my models react
as they probably don't hue shift as much.
Hello, nice to meet you.
Beep boop, I too am a bot.
Should we see if you can
do the full calibration of the model
in the future? Are you joking?
I have no idea how to do that.
I have no idea.
I've no got a Scooby-Doo
and what to do.
She's braver than me
and hard to draw.
You don't like my lollipop?
After one year of straight shoo-min,
it would be a huge change in adjustment to stream length.
That's what I'm worried about.
About me, we'd miss you for sure,
but you could finally probably rest,
so I just wish you have the strength and health
to do it.
As I said, when I go outside,
thankfully I don't have to go outside recently all.
The only thing I need to go outside again
for is my skin check,
which I've not booked the appointment for.
They just need to check
if they need to cut anything out of my skin
because I'm in the land of the sun
and it's super dangerous here.
The food delivery today was fun.
That's my only exposure to getting sick
unless Gimli and Vigo
pass something on to me from the garden.
I don't really have
the capacity
to become sick.
Capacity is the wrong word.
The opportunity to become sick,
opportunity is also the wrong word,
but I am very minimally
exposed to outside sources,
which means I
most likely will not fall ill
and even if I did fall ill,
I do know for a fact
I'm a boot-up balutrile
and get you to hold my hand
through every single hand of cards I play.
Vulnerability,
that's the word, vulnerability.
Mummy turns into Catwoman.
Cat Scratches can do it.
I use antiseptic
if there's ever an accident
with the pooders when we play.
Mummy, I saw this and thought of you.
Obviously the tail would be a tentacle,
but I think you have a picture.
What?
None of this card.
What are you sending me?
Monka?
Yeah, that's a good suck at this one.
I like that one.
No more opening up the infield.
Please don't forget to wear pants,
when going out.
If all else fails,
I volunteer my fate real.
Should be playing balutrile sick in bed
when it comes. I mean, I could stream...
Oh no, I couldn't.
I have to stream in a PC.
Why did I think I could stream from a bed?
I would have to move my...
Okay, wow.
Maybe...
I don't know. I could probably just do an ASMR stream
in the bath if I'm sick
and try and air out my airways and stuff.
If all else fails,
there's a soiled loincloth.
Bruh, that was crazy.
10 minutes.
Phone, PNG stream?
Is that a thing? Can be to Brazil?
You aren't useless, you're my favourite puppy girl.
I would do that,
but it really hurts my voice box to pant right now.
Hi, mommie. Do you have an oshi?
Do you still have time to watch others?
What do you do to relax?
I don't
relax!
Everything
is work
and trying my best for you.
I watch video game reviews
to see if there's a new game
that I might like to play with you
or a new game that I want to play in general
on screen.
On stream, pardon me.
I don't have time to watch
any other
VTuber at all, not even a stream.
I did a RuneScape
reacting to my gen mates content
because I don't even have time to watch
my gen mates, which is a shame.
The only guilty pleasure
that I have at the moment when I do find
time, and I can't even
complete full episodes,
there's this show
called the Financial Hammer and people
come on and they have debt issues
and spending habit issues
and addictions or whatever
to spend and then
this guy goes like
what are you doing? You're in debt!
Stop buying these frivolous
things!
That's my guilty pleasure at the
moment.
There was a guy on it recently
and he unfortunately
needs a bit of mental health
help.
He's got a way of communicating and his
perception of reality caught my eye
because I was like oh that's interesting
because his perception of reality
has warped. Five minutes?
I'll stop yapping about a different
YouTube show.
As for an Oshidaes
let's just say my gen
mates honestly. Not to be
biased, but my gen mates
unironically, I just
love them to bits, I love them to pieces.
You know
I can catch maybe
five minutes of a session.
Sometimes if I have a shorter stream
I catch mercy quite a lot because mercy is
really good for me when I'm kind of wrapping
up the end of my day.
God, six minutes.
Mummy, could you please hum
the Reeflings to Sleep?
What do you want me to hum? I've forgotten
how Legend of Zelda goes.
The Listerine?
Yeah, for accuracy.
I don't know how to
hum.
Klerushaka
Domenzu
Sone la matina
Ding ding dong
Why is this dealer?
Taking the piss?
I've been standing here
for three minutes.
Why is this dealer?
Taking the piss? I've been standing here.
I need
my things.
That's all I know.
Are we for a moment in the human
singing? My voice is so shredded
right now, I wish I could sing a bit more.
Don't remind me.
You better off alone
Domenzu
What? Are you sent me?
The last reefing I sent was a fixed version
of the Reefling Hold and Leash since it had some odd artifact
but here's the remote fix. Wait, is it going to work?
Can I send it before the Vod breaks?
Oh my god
it's squishy. He's so squishy.
Hold on.
You're so squishy.
I don't know why you do that.
Okay, save.
Oh my god, that is so
steep.
YouTube is so steep when asking for
new emotes lots, honestly.
It's like
145 new members ships needed.
That is honestly insane.
Three minutes until Domenzu.
Yeah, there you go. There's a new emote.
Why ain't the streamer
taking a piss? She's been streaming
here for 12 hours, honestly.
Okay, I love
you.
Are you going to be okay if I wrap
it up?
I'll give you a kiss for every
Reefling that was in game.
I kid you not, I can do that right now.
Okay, one, two, three,
one, two, three,
seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve, nineteen,
eleven, twelve,
seventeen, nineteen, nineteen, twenty,
twenty, twenty-one, twenty-two,
twenty-three, twenty-four, twenty-five,
twenty-six, twenty-seven, twenty-eight,
twenty-eight, twenty-nine,
thirty, twenty- dozens,
twenty-one, twenty-nine,
twenty-two, twenty-three, twenty-
thirty-four, twenty-five, twenty-
twenty-seven, twenty-eattie,
twenty-nine, twenty-
forty, forty-one,
forty-two, forty-three,
forty-four,
forty-five, thirty-one,
forty-six, forty-seven,
forty-nine,
forty-fifty,
forty-one, fifty-twenty,
mwah, 53 mwah, 54 mwah, um, lefty-five, lefty-six, lefty-seven, lefty-eat, lefty-nine,
60 mwah, 61 mwah, 62 mwah, 63 mwah, 64 mwah, 65 mwah, 66 mwah, 67 mwah, 68 mwah, 69 mwah,
71 mwah, 72 mwah, is still going, 73 mwah, my mouth is covered in spirey now. 74 mwah, 75 mwah,
76 mwah, 77 mwah, I've only got a minute. Okay, fuck it. Mwah, I'm literally just gonna go for it.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah,
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, done!
Done, that was all the Reeflands at Streamsnake.
Okay, I love you Reefland, I'll see you tomorrow.
I'll have fun with you tomorrow, okay?
Streamsnake me, okay?
I'll see you tomorrow, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
Have fun, bye Reefland, bye bye!
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
Mwah, mwah, mwah.